ASSEMBLY BUDGET COMMITTEE SUB
FOR INFORMATIONAL HEARING ON
THE EMPLOYMENT DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT THIS IS OUR THIRD
INFORMATIONAL HEARING ON EDG. I
HAVE BEEN ASKED TO RESCIND
DIRECTIONS REGARDING PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION IN TODAY'S
HEARING TO HELP ENSURE THE
SAFETY OF EVERYONE HERE WELL
LONG FULL PUBLIC ACCESS TO THIS
DISCUSSION. FOR THE PUBLIC IN
THE ROOM WE'RE HAVING TO
PHYSICALLY DISTANT IN PERSON
HEARING. EVEN THOUGH THIS ROOM
IS A LARGE HEARING ROOM IN THE
CAPITOL WE CAN ONLY ACCOMMODATE
A FEW MEMBERS A MIDDLE
CONTENTION OF STAFF. A LIMITED
NUMBER OF PUBLIC AND MEDIA SO
WE CAN KEEP SIX FEET APART.
THEY'RE ALSO STRICT PHYSICAL
DISTANCING PROTOCOLS FOR THE
PUBLIC TO ENTER AND LEAVE THE
CAPITOL. FOR THOSE HERE TODAY
TO MAKE PUBLIC COMMENT. AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. I WILL
RESTATE THIS ONE PUBLIC COMMENT
BEGINS. BUT IF THE NUMBER THE
PUBLIC IN THE ROOM WHICH IS TO
SPEAK. THEY WILL RAISE THEIR
HANDS AND I'LL ASK THEM TO
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE- I
WOULD AK THE PUBLIC TO RESPECT
PHYSICAL DISTANCING. AND NOT
TOUCH THE MICROPHONE. YOU HAVE
ONE MINUTE FOR PUBLIC COMMENT.
YOU CAN EXIT UPON. YOU CONNECTS
THE HEARING. WHAT'S YOU'RE
PUBLIC COMMENT IS DONE RETURN
YOUR SEAT. BUT PLEASE OBSERVE
PHYSICAL DISSENTING UPON
LEAVING THE CAPITAL INCLUDING
LEVELING ELEVATOR USED TO ONE
PERSON AT A TIME. THE PANELS ON
THE AGENDA IT. IN THE L. L.
PAYING USING ARE DONE ARE SET
UP IN THE CAPITAL IN THE
RESPECTIVE OFFICES IN OTHER
SPOTS THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
THERE BE NO VOTE ON THE
COMMITTEE TODAY. THERE PUBLIC
STATIONS AVAILABLE ACROSS
CALIFORNIA TO ALLOW PUBLIC
COMMENT. THEY DID A CONTAINS
THE LOCATIONS OF THESE
LOCATIONS INCLUDING ONE IN
CAPITOL PARK. IF YOU ENCOUNTER
ANY PROBLEMS PLEASE CONTACT THE
ASSEMBLY BUDGET COMMITTEE AT
NINE ONE SIX. THREE ONE NINE.
TWO ZERO NINE NINE IN A STAFF
MEMBER WILL ASSIST YOU. THE
PUBLIC MAY ALSO SUBMIT WRITTEN
TESTIMONY TO. BUDGET SUB SIX
THAT'S THE WORD BUDGET S. U. B.
SIX AT ASM DOT CA DOT GOV.
PLEASE NOTE THAT ANY WRITTEN
TESTIMONY. TO BUTTRESS OF SIX
GIVE ME SENT TO THE EMAIL
ADDRESS OR CONSIDER PUBLIC
COMMENT MAYBE READ INTO THE
RECORD WE'VE ROLL CALL PLEASE.
HERE YOUR LAST APPEARED.
TODAY'S HEARING WILL LOVE TO
HEAR FROM THE DISTRACTING ON
THEIR ASSESSMENT OF EDTA AND
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR ADDRESSING
ISSUES AT. WE'LL DISCUSS THE
NEXT STEPS FOR IMPLEMENTING THE
STRIKE TEAMS RECOMMENDATIONS
AND DISCUSS HOW WE KEEP EDT
ACCOUNTABLE FOR IMPLEMENTING
THEIR RECOMMENDATIONS WILL ALSO
DISCUSS THAT ONCE THESE
EXPERIENCE WITHOUT ANY DEFAULT
HAS AFFECT THEIR COMMUNITY IN
ORDER TO BE MINDFUL OF TIME
WE'RE GOING TO SKIP OPENING
REMARKS FROM MEMBERS AND START
WITH OUR FIRST PANEL WE'VE A
TIME CERTAIN START OF TWO
THIRTY. FOR PANEL TO THE
QUESTION FOR PENTWATER NOT
COMPLETE WE START PANEL TO WILL
RETURN TO PEDDLE. ONE LATER IN
THE HEARING. US LOCAL OPEN UP
WITH PANEL. HELLO WE HAVE A LOT
YOU WANT TO RICH. SIR OF GO OPS.
SURE IN HILLIARD DIRECTOR OF
EDT. AND CHASE. HELLO FOR THE
L. L. L. L. SO MR WILL HAVE A-
MISS RICHARDSON. GOOD AFTERNOON.
WELL I THINK YOU MAY BE. OKAY
YES OKAY THERE YOU ARE THANK
THE COOPER FOR THAT GO
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR BELLICUM
MEMBERS. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO APPEAR TODAY TO
SHARE INFORMATION ABOUT THE
WORK COMPLETED BY THE STRIKE
TEAM AS YOU KNOW THE STRIKE
EAM WAS FORMED BY THE GOVERNOR
TO MAKE RECOMMENDATIONS ABOUT
IMPROVING THE PROCESSING OF
CLAIMS AND MODERNIZING THE EDT
YOU AYE CLAIMANT EXPERIENCE IN
THE FUTURE. WHEN I LAST
APPEARED HERE I PROVIDED YOU
WITH A STATUS REPORT ON THE
WORK OF THE STRIKE TEAM SINCE
THEN WE'VE COMPLETED OUR REVIEW
AND DELIVERED OUR
RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE
GOVERNOR. ARE STRIKING REPORT
AS WELL AS THE DETAILED
ASSESSMENTAND RECOMMENDATIONS
HAVE BEEN MADE PUBLIC AND ARE
NOW IN USE BY EIGHTY D. AS A
ROAD MAP. I COULD HEAR THE
STRIKE TEAM WITH JENNIFER. A
CALIFORNIA AND WELL KNOWN
EXPERT IN GOVERNMENT SYSTEMS
AND TECHNOLOGY. THE GOVERNOR
AND I ARE GRATEFUL FOR HER
DEDICATION TO IMPROVING
GOVERNMENT. AND THE TIME SHE
CONTRIBUTED AS A CITIZEN OF
CALIFORNIA. TO HELP MAKE OUR
UNEMPLOYMENT SYSTEM BETTER. THE
STRIKE TEAM ALSO INCLUDED AMY
TONG DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY WHO IS
HERE WITH ME TODAY AND RICHARD
RODGERS R. CHIEF DEPUTY. AS
WELL AS WE DIE A PATENT IT HAD
OF THE OFFICE OF DID OF OFFICE
OF DIGITAL INNOVATION. WE WERE
ALSO SUPPORTED BY AN OUTSIDE
EXPERT TECHNOLOGY TEAMS WHO
HELPED US TO BETTER UNDERSTAND
THE TECHNOLOGY SYSTEMS AND
OPERATIONAL PROCESSES WITHIN
EDT. AS OUTSIDE AS WE WERE NOT
BURDENED WITH THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF RUNNING THE
PROGRAM DURING A CRISIS
INCLUDING BRINGING UP NEW
FEDERAL PROGRAMS AIMED AT
PROVIDING RELIEF DURING THIS
PANDEMIC. FOR MOST OF AUGUST WE
MET WITH FRONT LINE EMPLOYEES
CHALAMET'S MANAGER'S LEADERSHIP
STAFF. AS WELL AS MANY
LEGISLATORS AND MEMBERS OF YOUR
STAFF TO BETTER UNDERSTAND
PERSPECTIVES ABOUT THE PROBLEMS
THAT EDT AND POTENTIAL
SOLUTIONS. THE TEAM VISITED
OFFICES AND SHUTTLE MANAGERS
AND STAFF AND CITRAL DOCUMENT
MANAGEMENT IDENTITY
VERIFICATION AN OVERPAYMENT
UNITS. AND MET WITH IT
SPECIALIST WHO RUN TEN
INDIVIDUAL IT SYSTEMS WITHIN
EDT. TO UNDERSTAND HOW EACH OF
THEM WORKS AND WE'RE CHALLENGES
LIE. THE TEAM ALSO SPOKE WITH
CLAIMANTS REVIEWED SOCIAL MEDIA
AND CHATBOX QUERIES REVIEWED
NOTICES REVIEWED CALL CENTER
DATA AND LOOK AT IT LIKE TRONIC
AND MAIL COMMUNICATIONS SENT BY
CLAIMANTS TO AYE TO EDT. THE
TEAM OBSERVE PHONE SESSIONS AT
THE EDT SERVICE CENTER TO
EXPLORE WHERE BREAKDOWNS ARE
OCCURRING. MOST IMPORTANTLY THE
TEAM FOCUSED ON DATA AT EVERY
STEP WE USE DATA TO UNDERSTAND
THE PACE OF CLAIMS PROCESSING
TECHNICAL SYSTEMS AND WORK USE.
AS I HAVE PREVIOUSLY MENTIONED
THE PROBLEMS THAT EDT ARE
COMPLEX AND MULTIFACETED
NEVERTHELESS WE HAVE MADE A
SERIES OF RECOMMENDATIONS THAT
WE BELIEVE WILL LEAD TO THE
IMPROVEMENT AT EDT IN THE SHORT
MEDIUM AND LONG TERM. AS YOU
LIKELY KNOW BY NOW WE
RECOMMENDED THAT YOU DID THE
INSTALL AND IDENTITY
VERIFICATION TOOL THAT IS NOW
IN USE AND IS MAKING IT EASIER
AND FASTER FOR CLAIMS TO VERIFY
THEIR IDENTITIES WHEN. FILING
FOR UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS.
SINCE IT ME WAS IMPLEMENTED
STARTING LAST THURSDAY MORE
THAN ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND
INDIVIDUALS. HAVE USED THE TOOL
THROUGH FOUR PM YESTERDAY
INCLUDING NICK NEARLY FIFTY
NINE THOUSAND PEOPLE WHO VERIFY
THEIR IDENTITY WITHOUT NEEDING
ANY ASSISTANCE. A LITTLE MORE
THAN SIX THOUSAND PEOPLE GOT
ASSISTANCE TO VERIFY THEIR
IDENTITY WITH A TRUSTED REFEREE
USING VIDEO CHAT. AS INTENDED
THIS IS A SIGNIFICANTLY
REDUCING THE NUMBER OF CLAIMS
THAT MUST BE HANDLED BY MANUAL
PROCESSING. IT IS ALSO SLOWING
THE GROWTH OF THE BACKLOG BY
ELIMINATING THE NEED FOR MANUAL
VERIFICATION OF MANY CLAIMS.
THERE ARE INDICATIONS THE TOOL
IS WORKING TO BLOCK BLOCK
INVALID CAIMS AT THE DOOR. BUT
MORE DATA IS NEEDED IN THE
UPCOMING WEEKS TO MAKE A CLEAR
DETERMINATION ABOUT WHY CLAIMS
ARE AND AREN'T MAKING IT
THROUGH IT. AFTER A THOROUGH
ASSESSMENT OF INCOMING
APPLICATIONS IS COMPLETED AS
WELL AS REMAINING DOWNSTREAM
FIXES TO COMPLETE THE
AUTOMATION OFIDENTITY
VERIFICATION. EDT WILL PROVIDE
A REPORT ON THE PROPORTION OF
NEW CLAIMANTS WHO ARE GETTING
THEIR CLAIMS PROCESS IN AN
AUTOMATED WAY. BASED ON WHAT WE
HAVE SEEN IN THE LAST WEEK I'M
CONFIDENT EIGHTY D. IS ON A
PATH TO MAKE STEPS IN THE
PROCESS EASIER FOR HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF APPLICANTS. THE
STRIKE TEAM USED TECHNOLOGY
EXPERTS WHO WERE ABLE TO
EXTRACT DATA FROM PD SYSTEMS TO
INFORM OPERATIONS. THIS IS A
CRITICAL CHIFFRE ET DE KNOWING
WHERE IN THEIR SYSTEM CLAIMS
ARE GETTING BOGGED DOWN. AND
ADJUSTING STAFF AND OPERATIONS
TO ADJUST THEM. WE RECOMMENDED
OPERATIONAL CHANGES TO REDUCE
THEBACKLOG BASED ON DATA
INCLUDING INCREASED USED UP ALL
CALLING TO CLAIMANTS TO RESOLVE
ISSUES. WE RECOMMENDED A TWO
WEEK RESET TO IMPROVE SYSTEMS
DURING WHICH CLAIMANTS WOULD
FILL OUT AN ONLINE FORM AND BE
NOTIFIED LATER OF AN
OPPORTUNITY TO APPLY. THIS
RESET PERIOD WHICH ENDED SUNDAY
WILL RESULT IN MANY OF THE
CLAIMS DELAYED DURING THIS
PERIOD TO BE PAID FASTER. WE
SUGGESTED EDT PUBLISHED A NEW
DASHBOARD UPDATED WEEKLY THAT
CLEARLY IDENTIFIES THE U. I.
BACKLOG AND PROVIDES AN
ESTIMATE OF THE TIME IT WILL
TAKE TO PROCESS THAT BACKLOG
BASED ON DATA. I BELIEVE EDG
HAS BEGUN MAKING THAT DATA
AVAILABLE WE ALSO RECOMMENDED
THAT YOU DO MAKE IT EASIER TO
USE YOU AYE ONLINE BY MAKING
YOU AYE ONLINE AND ASSOCIATED
TOOLS WORK BETTER ON MOBILE
DEVICES. FOR INCREASED USE OF
THE INCREASE EASE OF USE AND
DECREASE USER ERRORS AND DATA
ENTRY. ERRORS CAN ACTUALLY
CAUSE DELAYS. BUILDING ON THE
RECENT IMPROVEMENTS AND
DOCUMENT UPLOAD WE ARE
RECOMMENDING EDT MAKE IT EASER
TO UPLOAD DOCS UPLOAD DOCUMENTS
TO THE EDT SYSTEM. USING THEIR
MOBILE PHONES OR COMPUTERS TO
SPEED CLAIMANT'S ABILITY TO
RESPOND TO REQUESTS FOR FURTHER
VALIDATION OF THEIR CLAIMS. AND
REDUCE THE MAIL PROCESSING
BURDEN ON EIGHTY. WHAT THE
IMMEDIATE FIXES IN PLACE THE
STRIKE TEAM RECOMMENDED THAT
EDIE USE DATA DRIVEN EFFORTS TO
PREVENT FRAUD AND ABANDON OLDER
PROCESSES THAT ARE NOT BASED ON
THE MODERN ATTEMPTS TO DEFRAUD
EDIE'S PROGRAMS. ADDITIONALLY
WE RECOMMENDED EDT SHOULD
REVISIT THE B. S. M. PROJECT
AND REIMAGINE IT FOR THE FUTURE
IN WAYS THAT PRIORITIZE
CLAIMANTS NEEDS AND MAKES THEIR
EXPERIENCE WITH ET D. EASY FAST
AND RELIABLE. THIS EFFORT DONE
IN TANDEM WITH THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY AND
THE OFFICE OF DIGITAL
INNOVATION SHOULD BEGIN
IMMEDIATELY ONCE THE BACKLOG
HAS BEEN RESOLVED. WE ALL KNOW
THAT THE CODE NINETEEN EPIDEMIC
TRIGGERED AN UNPRECEDENTED
VOLUME OF CLAIMS THAT HAS
OVERWHELMED THE DEPARTMENT OF
SYSTEMS AT ITS CORE. THE
DEPARTMENT HAS GROWN OVERLY
RELIANT ON A SINGLE GROUP OF
PEOPLE WHO MUST PERFORM HIGHLY
SPECIALIZED TASKS TO PROCESS
CLAIMS. IN THE LONG RUN THE
DEPARTMENT MUST TAKE STEPS TO
SIMPLIFY THAT WORK BY
MODERNIZING THE PROGRAM
TOGETHER WITH THE NEW
TECHNOLOGY. FOR THIS REASON WE
HAVE RECOMMENDED THAT EDT
EXPLORE THEIR OPERATIONS AND
TECHNOLOGY AND AGAIN BOLD CROSS
DISCIPLINARY MODERNIZATION
INVOLVING AN OVERHAUL OF
ADMINISTRATIVE RULES AND
PROCEDURES. OPERATIONS AND
TECHNOLOGY WHAT THE CENTRAL
FOCUS ON IMPROVING THE
EXPERIENCE OF THOSE FILING FOR
UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS. THIS
PROJECT WILL ALSO RESULT IN
LOWER ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS TO
TAXPAYERS IN THE DELIVERY OF
THESE BENEFITS. GOING FORWARD
THE STATE WILL NEED HYBRID ECH
POLICY TEAMS TO SUPPORT THE
GOVERNMENT DEPARTMENTS TO
ASSESS AND IMPROVE SYSTEMS
BRINGING TOGETHER THE WORLD'S
OF REGULATIONS REQUIREMENTS AND
PROGRAMS TOGETHER WITH
OPERATIONS TECHNOLOGY AND
SYSTEMS TO BETTER SERVE
CALIFORNIANS. I BELIEVE THE
STRIKE TEAM HAS HELPED EQUITY
D. WAS THE NEW TOOLS AND NEW
APPROACHES TO IMPROVE
OPERATIONS AND ATTACK THE
BACKLOG WITH MORE TRANSPARENCY
AND A STRATEGIC APPROACH THAT
WORKS PROCLAIM ITS EMPLOYEES
MANAGERS AND EXECUTIVES ALIKE.
THEIR NEW DATA AND PROCESSES IN
PLACE AS WELL AS A TRANSPARENT
METHOD OF REPORTING THAT WILL
ASSIST YOU AS LAWMAKERS ALONG
WITH THE SECRETARY OF LABOR AND
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT TO
SUPPORT BDD AND MAKING
PROGRESS. I AM EXTRAORDINARILY
PROUD OF THE PACE WITH WHICH
THE TEAMS HAVE COLLABORATED
FROM THE RAPID COMPETITIVE
COMPUTER MEANT OF THE
PROCUREMENT OF THE ID
VERIFICATION VERIFICATION TOOL
TO A SUCCESSFUL IMPLEMENTATION.
MANY HARDWORKING DEDICATED
PUBLIC SERVANTS HAVE WORKED
AROUND THE CLOCK LITERALLY IN
RECENT DAYS. TO BRING UP THESE
IMPORTANT CHANGES THAT EDT AND
I AM SO VERY PROUD OF THEIR
WORK. WITHIN MY AGENCY THE
GOVERNMENT OPERATIONS AGENCY.
THE DEPARTMENT OF THE
TECHNOLOGY AND THE OFFICE OF
DIGITAL INNOVATION WILL
CONTINUE TO SUPPORT THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE PRIMARY
RECOMMENDATIONS. THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO APPEAR TODAY.
THANK YOU MISTER JOHNSON ALSO
ONE THANK YOU AND LOTS FOR ALL
YOU'VE DONE YOU'VE BEEN- VERY
COMMUNICATED WITH ME SO I
APPRECIATE THAT NEXT UP. IS
MISSILE YOUR. GOOD AFTERNOON.
GOOD AFTERNOON YOU HEAR ME WE
CAN HEAR YOU BUT WE'LL SEE YOU.
UP OKAY HOLD ON. CAN YOU HEAR
ME NOW YEAH WE HEAR YOU BELIEVE
WE'RE SEEING THIS RICHARDSON
STILL JUST TALKING AND THEN
IT'LL- NEED TO KEEP TALKING
KEEP TALKING YOU'RE FINE ALL
RIGHT OKAY LET'S GET STARTED I
GET AFTERNOON A- GERMAN
GOVERNMENT COOPER THE REMAINING
FOLKS IS BECAUSE I'M GLAD TO BE
HERE AGAIN AND YOU AN UP. LIKE
I DID LAST TIME I PROVIDED SORT
OF A SLIDE DECK OF THE MOST-
THE CURRENT INFORMATION- ANNA
AND RESPONSE TO SOME OF THE
QUESTIONS I KNOW OUR INTEREST
THAT YOU MIGHT HAVE SO
HOPEFULLY HAVE ADDRESSED OR
CAPTURED EVERYTHING THAT YOU
WANT TO HEAR ABOUT IF NOT WE'LL
BE GLAD TO TAKE BACK ANY
ADDITIONAL. CONCERNS OR NEEDS
AND BE SURE TO GET BACK TO IT
AT A LATER DATE SO HOPEFULLY
YOU HAVE IN FRONT OF YOU THE-
FLIGHT DECK WE SENT. OVER AND
GOING TO FIRST PAGE AND FOR OF.
NOTHING OFF OR SECRETARY
RICHEST LEFT OFF AROUND THE
STRIKE TEAM ARE. I'M TO READ ON
THE WORD OF A ALLOW RECOMMEND.
OF THOSE RECORD WE'VE ALREADY
COMPLETED TWENTY TWO OF THEM
THIRTY SIX ARE IN PROGRESS AND
THE REMAINING FIFTY THREE YEAR
UNDER EVALUATION AND- WAITING
DEPENDENCIES AS SOME OF THE
OTHER PROJECTS. NOW WE ARE
MEETING WEEKLY WITH THE LABOR
AGENCY AND THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE TO REPORT THE STATUS OF
THESE PROJECTS AND- LET THEM
KNOW WE'RE ACTIVITY UPDATES-
ANY CONCERNS- WHEN SURE THAT WE
ARE BEING ACCOUNTABLE AND-
GETTING THROUGH ALL OF THESE
ARE RECOMMENDATIONS AS SWIFTLY
AS POSSIBLE. I'M ALSO GLAD TO
REPORT- INDUSTRY TO REPORT
ITSELF IF IT'S HOT FOR-
RECOMMENDATIONS- THREE OF THEM
WE'VE ALREADY COMPLETED WHICH
ONE IS DEALING WITH THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
DASHBOARD- THE DEPLOYMENT OF
I'D ME. ADOPTING A BURN DOWN
PLAN OF THOSE THREE HAVE ALL
BEEN COMPLETED AND THE FOURTH
ONE WHICH WAS TO COMPLETE
DEPLOYMENT OF THE CURRENT
DOCUMENT UPLOAD SOLUTION. FOR
ALL TYPES OF DOCUMENTS- WE
ALREADY COMPLETED PHASE ONE
WHICH ALLOWS FOR IDENTITY
DOCUMENTS TO BE UPLOADED. AND
WE'RE GONNA START WORK ON
LOOKING AT OTHER DOCUMENTS SUCH
AS WE AGE VERIFICATION
DOCUMENTS MILITARY CLAIMS IN
FEDERAL CLAIMS SO THAT'S UP
NEXT. SO THAT'S WHERE WE ARE
WITH THE RECOMMENDATIONS AND AS
I SAID WE ARE MEETING WEEKLY
WITH- THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
SOUNDS AGENCY TO ENSURE THAT
THESE ARE ALL BEING DONE SO
WITH LAKE. IT'S MOVING TO THE
NEXT PAGE- ET RESET IT
VERIFICATION. OF THE SOLANO
RICHARDSON- STATED OR THE NEW
ID NEED BEGAN WE ACTUALLY BEGAN
WORKING ON IN JULY THAT WE
SUCCESSFULLY IMPLEMENTED
OCTOBER FIFTH PARTNERSHIP WITH
THE STRIKE TEAM- AND WE'RE VERY
EXCITED IT'S IS WORKING AS WE
EXPECTED SO FAR AND- WE'RE JUST
SO FAR IT'S WORKING AS
DESIGNED. AND WE'RE THRILLED TO
HAVE THIS NEW TOOL UP AND
RUNNING TO ADDRESS AND
STREAMLINE OUR IDENTITY PROCESS.
STARTING OCTOBER ONE OVER
HUNDRED THIRTY SIX INDIVIDUALS
WERE CONTACTED TO COME BACK AND
APPLY THROUGH IT NEED FOR A
SOFT LAUNCH. FROM OCTOBER ONE
THROUGH THAT OF OVER SIX SIXTY
FOUR THOUSAND USERS
SUCCESSFULLY VERIFIED THEIR
IDENTITY THROUGH IT. SO AND
THEN ALSO WE ARE ON SCHEDULE
FOR PAYMENT WITHIN ONE WEEK OF
THE SAN FIVE LAUNCH FOR ALL
CLEAN CLAIMS SO WE REMAIN ON
TRACK. FOR MOVING TO THE NEXT
PAGE THE ATV RECEPT. WE ARE
AND- SCHEDULED TO LIQUIDATE THE
BACKLOG BY JANUARY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AND DURING THESE
THAT WE CONDUCTED- 240-003-0080
SEVEN OUTBOUND CALLS AS PART OF
AN OVERALL COME COME PAIN. WE
CONTACTED CLAIMANTS WHO HAD
CERTIFIED OR SHARED NEED WAGE
INFORMATION WITH US SO- THAT
WENT VERY WELL AND WE DID FIND
IT AND MAKING ALL THE CALLS OF
THE TOP THREE REASONS WHY
PEOPLE DON'T CERTIFY- ONE MAJOR
DON'T KNOW THEY NEED TO THEY
WENT BACK TO WORK OR JUST
DIDN'T NEED YOU I BENEFITS OR
THREE THEY WERE UNABLE TO REACH
ET SO THIS WAS VERY HELPFUL
INFORMATION AS WE CONTINUE TO
DEVELOP DIFFERENT STRATEGIES TO
ADDRESS THE NEEDS OF OUR
CUSTOMERS. WE ALSO LIQUIDATED
EDT CALL BACK LIST ON SEPT WHAT
SEPTEMBER TWENTY NINTH SO ALL
THE- PEOPLE THAT WERE ON THE
LIST FOR WAITING FOR CALLS AND
WE HAVE. COMPLETED THAT. WE DID
REDUCE OUR BACKLOG- BY
820-040-6000 CLAIMANTS-
BERSERK- AND HAD WE NOT RESET
AND DONE OF THE- RECEPT WE
ESTIMATE THAT OUR WORKLOAD
WOULD HAVE INCREASED BY SIX
PERCENT. SO WE'RE VERY HAPPY
WITH THE OUTCOME AND- IN FACT
WE'RE GOING A LITTLE A LITTLE
BIT AHEAD SO WERE EXCITED WITH
THAT. THE DEVELOPMENTS AND-
THIS RECOMMENDATION HAS IS
PROVING TO BE A SUCCESSFUL FOR
ALL OF US. THE NEXT ONE
STRIKING RECOMMENDED DATE THIS
MAN. AFTERWARDS US SECRETARY
RICHEST MENTIONED THIS AND ON
THE TOOLS PROVIDED BY THE
STRIKE TEAM EATING THE HAS BEEN
ABLE TO DEFINE AND IDENTIFY THE
BACKLOG INTO TWO DISTINCT
CATEGORIES. THE FIRST ONE IS
INITIAL CLAIMS AND IT'S AN
INCLUSIVE LOOK AT ALL CLAIMS
SUBMITTED MORE THAN TWENTY ONE
DAYS AGO THAT NEED TO BE
PROCESSED BY AT THE STAFF
REGARDLESS. OF IF THE CLAIMANT
CORTINI DEEP NEED TO TAKE SOME
TYPE OF ACTION TO DETERMINE
ELIGIBILITY. AND THEN TH
SECOND ONE THEY CONTINUED
PLAYING BACKLOG. THIS
REPRESENTS CLAIMANTS WHO
RECEIVED THE FIRST PAYMENT OR
PAYMENTS. BUT DUE TO SUBSEQUENT
ELIGIBILITY CERTIFICATION
ISSUES SUCH AS REPORTED
EARNINGS HAVE STOPPED RECEIVING
PAYMENTS. THE NEW DASHBOARDS
CAN BE LOCATED VIA EDIE'S
NEWSROOM ON THE DEPARTMENT'S
WEBSITE WHERE THERE ARE
DISPLAYED AND UPDATED EVERY
THURSDAY- SO. HELLO EVERY WEEK
AND WE ARE WE ARE DO ACTUALLY
PRODUCE OF DAILY FOR OWN USE
BUT WE'RE PUTTING OUT THERE FOR
EVERYONE TO SEE SO IT'S A
PROVIDES A COMPLETE
TRANSPARENCY. MOVING ON TO FROM
PREVENT MEASURES. WE'VE GOT A
LOT OF WORK AROUND THE PROBLEM-
THAT ISSUER FRAUD WHICH IS THAT
PLAGUED OF THE PAN UNEMPLOYED
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM NATIONWIDE
CALIFORNIA ISN'T AND ANY
DIFFERENT THAT'S THE STATE'S
BUT UP WORKING COLLABORATIVELY
TO MAKE SURE WE ADDRESS IT. AND
DO EVERYTHING WE CAN TO FIGHT
CRIME. SOME OF THE THINGS WE'VE
BEEN DOING FROM AT. STAND
OBVIOUS THE EMPLOYMENT ARMY TO.
IDENTITY DOCUMENTS ON THE FRONT
END OF AN APPLICATION IT'S
RIGHT THERE THAT'S A HUGE STEP
FORWARD AND- WE'RE MOST EXCITED
ABOUT THAT. OTHER AREAS LAW
ENFORCEMENT PARTNERSHIPS- WE
MONITOR AND ANALYSE ALLEGATIONS
OF FRAUD REPORTED TO THE EIGHTY
INVESTIGATION DIVISION. WE ALSO
WORK WITH CDCR TO OBTAIN
CURRENT ROSTER TO PEOPLE WHO
ARE INCARCERATED TO CROSSMATCH
WITH CLAIMS. UNFORTUNATELY
THERE'S NO STATEWIDE DATABASE
FOR US TO DO THIS SO- WE HAVE
TO WORK WITH THE DEPARTMENT TO
SORT OF. AS WE CAN AND GET
INFORMATION. EDT IS WORKING IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CYBERSECURITY INTEGRATION
CENTER TO USE A DIGITAL
FORENSICS TO IDENTIFY
FRAUDULENT ACTORS AND FURTHER
PREVENT THEIR CHILDREN OF THAT
INTO OUR SYSTEM. AND THEN
FINALLY- WE HAVEN'T
PARTICIPATING IN A NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF STATE WORKFORCE
AGENCIES IDENTITY- HUB. AND
UTILIZE OUR FORENSIC TOOLS AND
IDENTIFY IDENTITY SCHEMES WELL
LET ME HAVE DRINK OF WATER. AND
THEN OFF. BROWN POLICY CHANGES
WE ELIMINATED THE AUTOMATIC
BACK I'M DATING A FEW EIGHT.
AND THAT WASN'T A SEPT AND WE
SAW DECREASE IN RPO A CLAIMS BY
ABOUT 72% SINCE THEN. WE ALSO
SUSPENDED US HIGH VOLUME CLAIMS
FILED AT THE SAME ADDRESS.
HELLO MY LETTER TO TALK ABOUT
ME SURE CLAIMING ACCESS TO BEND.
ONE THING RIGHT OFF THE BAT
THAT'S NOT THIS ONE THAT I WANT
MENTION THIS IS A- NEW I DO PUT
IN EVERY TO BANK OF. REQUESTING
THAT THEY. WAIVE THE TEN DOLLAR
FEE TO. DEBRA I THINK THAT'S
SOMETHING I HEARD THROUGH THE
LEGISLATURE AS WELL AND I THINK
IT MIGHT HAVE COME UP IN THE
STRIKE TEAM. I DID PUT TO THAT
REQUEST. B. OF A HAS RESPONDED
AND THEY HAVE AGREED TO WAIVE-
THE TEN DOLLAR EXT- FEED TO
EXPEDITE AND THEY WILL BE
REFUNDING PEOPLE'S MONEY BACK
TO APRIL FIRST. SO I THINK
THAT'S A VERY GOOD NEWS. AND
THEN ALSO. EDT AND BANK OF
AMERICA- WE'VE BEEN WE NOTICED
A VERY HIGH UNUSUALLY HIGH
VOLUME OF CLAIMS ASSOCIATED
WITH THE SINGLE DRESSES AND- AS
WELL AS SOME OTHER FRAUD
INDICATORS AS A RESULT
APPROXIMATELY SIX HUNDRED
NINETY THREE CLAIMS WERE
TEMPORARILY SUSPENDED- ADD AND
BANK OF AMERICA ACCORDING
ADDITIONAL REVIEW OF THREE
HUNDRED ALMOST THREE HUNDRED
FIFTY EIGHT THOUSAND DEBIT
CARDS THAT HAVE BEEN ISSUED
PAYMENTS RECEIVED. IT IS ALSO
REVIEWING THREE HUNDRED FIFTEEN
THOUSAND CLAIMS THAT HAVE NOT
RECEIVED A PAYMENT AND PEOPLE
ARE GOING TO IDENTITY
VERIFICATIO PROCESS. NOW ALL
RIGHT NOW AS WE SPEAK ET- I AM
LABOR AGENCY IS CURRENTLY MISS
MEETING WITH THE BANK OF
AMERICA TO WORK THROUGH MANY OF
THESE CONCERNS AND ISSUES AND
HOW AND THE BEST WAY TO MOVE
FORWARD TO ENSURE WERE FIGHTING
FRAUD AT THE SAME TIME WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE WE'RE GETTING THAT
MONEY IN THE HANDS OF OUR
CLAIMANTS AS SOON AS POSSIBLE.
THAT IS OUR PRIORITY. WE ALSO
EIGHTY CONTACTED ALL THE
CUSTOMERS ASSOCIATE WITH THESE
CLAIMS ASK FOR DOCUMENTS TO
HELP. I ENTITY ET WILL CONTINUE
TO FOLLOW UP WITH EMAILS TEXTS
AND PHONE CALLS TO HELP
REESTABLISH PAYMENT QUICKLY FOR
A LEGITIMATE CLAIMANTS. EIGHTY
RECEIVE DOCUMENTS FROM TWENTY
NINE THOUSAND PEOPLE. AND THE
DEPARTMENT IS UTILIZING ALL
MEANS AVAILABLE TO EXPLOIT
EXPEDITE THE REVIEW AND WE HOPE
TO HAVE RESOLUTION OVER THE
NEXT FIVE TO SEVEN DAYS. FOR
THE REMAINING CLIENTS THAT DID
NOT PROVIDE US DOCUMENTS AT ALL
THE EDT IS REACHING OUT AGAIN
THROUGH EMAIL TAX AN OUTBOUND
CALLS JUST TO MAKE SURE WE
TOUCH EVERYBODY. AND IF THEY
NEED TO FILE FOR BENEFITS THEY
HAVE OPPORTUNITY. MOVING
FORWARD AT THE EIGHTY BELIEVES
IMPLEMENTATION OF OUR IT ME
VERIFICATION TECHNOLOGY WHICH
LAUNCHED MONDAY. AT A FRIEND
I'M PROCESS IT WILL REALLY MOVE
TO HELP QUICKLY AUTHENTICATE
LEGITIMATE CLAIMANTS. AND HELP
THE EDT LIST- PROCESSING THEIR
CLAIMS FASTER. IT WILL ALSO
MITIGATE OF FRAUD ACTIVITY FROM
OCCURRING IN THE FUTURE SO.
HOPEFULLY YOU KNOW MOVING
FORWARD THIS WON'T BE A
CONCERN- AT THIS POINT WE JUST
GOT TO MAKE SURE THAT UP CLAIMS
THAT WE- STILL NEED TO PROCESS-
ARE. PEOPLE THAT ARE ELIGIBLE
ARE THE ONES THAT ARE GETTING
PAID. SO THAT. RIGHT TODAY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU
NEXT UP IS MISTER ELMO. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR. CAN YOU HEAR
ME YES PLEASE PRESS THE ACCEPT.
CHAD ALLEN WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE- OUR OFFICE
PRODUCED- I BRIEF HAND OUT FOR
THE HEARING THAT'S AVAILABLE ON
THE SUBCOMMITTEE'S WEBSITE. AND
WE WERE ASKED BY STAFF TO
PROVIDE OUR ASSESSMENT OF THE
STRIKE TEAM REPORT AND
RECOMMENDATIONS AND ALSO ANY
RECOMMENDATIONS WE HAD AS TO
HOW THE LEGISLATURE MY CONTINUE
OVERSIGHT OVER- IMPROVEMENTS AT
THE EMPLOYMENT DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT. ARE BOTH SECRETARY
RICHARDSON AND DIRECTOR
HILLIARD PROVIDED A THOROUGH
BACKGROUND SO I'LL BEGIN ON MY
SECOND PAGE OF THE HANDOUT
HAVING TO DO WITH WITH OUR
PERSPECTIVE OF THE STRIKE TEAM
REPORT. IN RSS THAT THE REPORT
IS CLEAR IT'S EXHAUSTIVE AND
IT'S CRITICAL OF THE DELAYS AND
BACKLOG AT EDIE'S SINCE THE
PANDEMIC BEGAN- THE REPORT'S
FINDINGS ARE GENERALLY
CONSISTENT WITH OUR OFFICES
UNDERSTANDING. OF WHAT'S LED TO
THE BACKLOG AND DELAY. IN
THROUGHOUT THE REPORT WE'VE
IDENTIFIES WITH THREE RECURRING
THEMES THAT WE WANT TO SPEAK TO
TODAY ONE THAT A LONG STANDING
INSTITUTIONAL FOCUS ON FRAUD
PREVENTION. DURING THE PANDEMIC
PROVIDED LITTLE BENEFIT AND AT
GREAT COST. TO THAT VETERANS
STAFF HAVE BEEN HAMPERED BY A
PERFECT STORM OF SORTS MADE UP
FROM THE REQUIREMENT- FOR MANY
STAFF TO DO WORK REMOTELY. THE
SUDDEN SURGE AND YOU AYE CLAIMS
TO SUCH AN UNPRECEDENTED LEVEL
AND ALSO THE REQUIREMENT TO
TRAIN NEW HIRES AT EDT. AND
THIRD CONTRARY TO A COMMON
NARRATIVE- THE STRIKE TEAM
REPORT IDENTIFIES- THAT THE
BACKLOG IS DUE IN MANY WAYS
FIRST AND FOREMOST TO
OPERATIONAL POLICIES OR
CHALLENGES AS WELL AS POLICIES
THE DEPARTMENT HAS MADE IN THE
PAST RATHER THAN THE DEPARTMENT
RELIANCE ON OUTDATED TECHNOLOGY
SYSTEM GOING FORWARDTHE
REPORTS AND THAT THE REPORT'S
RECOMMENDATION SEEMS LOGICAL
AND THE STATE'S TROOP TO TASK
NOW IS TO ENSURE THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS GOING FORWARD.
I'M SHOULD THE FIRST PERSON
HAVING TO DO WITH THE EDT IS
LONGSTANDING INSTITUTIONAL
FOCUS ON FRAUD PROVIDING LITTLE
BENEFIT DURING THE PANDEMIC- AS
A RESULT OF THIS FOCUS WHICH IS
LARGELY IN RESPONSE TO FEDERAL
REQUIREMENTS THAT SET TARGETS
FOR OVERPAYMENTS I'M AT IS
SCRUTINIZED ROUGHLY 40% OF
INCOMING YOU AYE APPLICATIONS
FOR IDENTITY ERIFICATION SINCE
A PANDEMIC BEGAN AND DURING LOW
WORK LOAD TIMES THIS MANUAL
REVIEW PROCESS IS DURABLE BY
THE DEPARTMENT BUT DURING HIGH
WORKLOAD TIMES LIKE WE SEEN
THIS LAST YEAR- THAT THE CLAIMS
TO GO TO THE MANUAL REVIEW
PROCESS ULTIMATELY ARRIVING A
BOTTLE. THAT WE'VE SEEN IN THE
LAST SEVERAL MONTHS. AND I OF
TO THE STRIKE TEAM THAT THE
MANUAL REVIEW PROCESS IN FACT
DID NOT CAPTURE A MEANINGFUL
NUMBER OF FRAUDULENT CLAIMS AS
IT AN INTENDED I IN FACT THAT
THE STRIKE TEAM FOUND THAT THAT
OF EACH FIVE HUNDRED CLAIMS
THAT EDT STAFF FOR MANUAL
IDENTITY VERIFICATION OUT ONE
pFRAUDULENT CLAIM WAS CAPTURED.
THE SECOND THEME THAT WE WANTED
TO FOCUS ON IS AGAIN ABOUT THIS
PERFECT STORM AND THAT IS THAT
THE MOST EXPERIENCED STAFF AT
EDT HAVE BEEN HAVE BEEN
HAMPERED IN THEIR WORK VIA A
REQUIREMENT TO WORK REMOTELY.
BY THE SURGEON WHO CLAIMS AND
BY TRAINING NEW HIRES ET HAS
HIRED MORE THAN FIVE THOUSAND
NEW STAFF SINCE A PANDEMIC
BEGAN AND EXPERIENCED STAFF OF
BEEN ASKED TO HELP ON BOARD AND
TRAIN THE STAFF FIRST I AM
DOING SO I'VE BEEN DIVERTED
FROM- ANSWERING PHONE CALLS
AND- WORKING DOWN THE BACKLOG
OF MANUAL CLAIMS THAT THAT BOTH
THE SECRETARY AND DIRECTOR
MENTIONED. IN ADDITION THEY'VE
HAD TO WORK REMOTELY AND AS WE
ALL KNOW THIS CAN HAVE
PRODUCTIVITY AFFECTS. ON ONE AS
ONE EXAMPLE IN THE STRIKE TEAM
REPORT ONE COMMON PROCESS STEP
CALLED THREE COMPUTATIONS. ARE
DISTRACTING BROWN TOOK TWO TO
FIVE TIMES LONGER NOW THAN IT
DID BEFORE THE PANDEMIC AS A
RESULT OF THIS PERFECT STORM.
OUR OUR RECORD THEME THAT WE
IDENTIFIED HAS TO DO. WITH THAT
THE BECAUSE OF THE CAUSES OF
THAT THE DELAYED PAYMENTS AND
CURRENT BACKLOG AND WITHOUT
QUESTION EDIE'S RELIANCE ON
OUTDATED TECHNOLOGY HAS
HINDERED THEIR ABILITY TO MAKE
QUICK PROGRAM CHANGES AND IT'S
pLED THE DEPARTMENT TO RELY ON
WORKAROUNDS AND THAT TIME
INTENSIVE MANUAL PROCESS. BUT
AS IDENTIFIED IN THE STRIKE
TEAM REPORT. THE LARGE BACKLOG
AND BROAD FRUSTRATION FELT BY
WORKERS CAN ALSO BE LINKS TO AN
EFFICIENT OPERATIONAL POLICIES.
AS WELL AS- OUR C.
DETERMINATION MADE BY THE
DEPARTMENT IN THE PAST- AND
SPECIFICALLY THE APARTMENTS
FOCUS ON FRAUD PREVENTION- SOME
OF THE KEY POLICIES IDENTIFIED
BY THE STRAIGHT TEAM REPORT
THAT THAT LED TO SOME OF- THIS
BACKLOG THAT AREN'T NECESSARILY
TECHNOLOGICAL IN NATURE. BOB
REVOLVE AROUND THE CALL CENTER
STAFFING AND LIMITATIONS THE
CALL CENTER THE MANAGEMENT OF
MULTIPLE PLANT CLAIMS THAT COME
IN AND RECONCILING MULTIPLE
CLAIMS INTO A SINGLE CLAIM- THE
LIMITATIONS FOR OUTBOUND
COMMUNICATIONS HISTORICALLY FOR
EDT STAFF. AS WELL AS DOCUMENT
SCANNING AND OTHER INTERNAL
PROCESS STEPS. I'M. FOR OUR
OFFICE IS MADE FOR ONE BROAD
RECOMMENDATION FOR LEGISLATIVE
OVERSIGHT INTO SPECIFIC
RECOMMENDATIONS SO. FIRST THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF CARRYING OUT
THESE VIRGIN AND LARGELY SORT
OF ADMINISTRATIVE TASKS- THAT
WERE PART OF RECOMMENDATIONS IN
THE STRIKE TEAM REPORT FALLS ON
THE ADMINISTRATION AT THIS
POINT- THESE TASKS ARE ARE
TAKING PLACE NOW AS BOTH THE
SECRETARY AND THE DIRECTOR
MENTIONED AND THAT AND THAT
TENDS TO LIMIT THE
LEGISLATURE'S OVERSIGHT GIVEN
THE URGENCY OF SOME OF THESE
ITEMS- BUT THERE ARE ALSO
BROADER RECOMMENDATIONS
THROUGHOUT THE REPORT. AS WELL
AS SOME SENSITIVE FINDINGS THAT
WE BELIEVE WARRANT THE
LEGISLATURE'S ATTENTION AT THIS
TIME A COUPLE FINDINGS THAT WE
WOULD HIGHLIGHT HAVE TO DO WITH
ACCESSIBILITY SO THE STRIKE
TEAM. IDENTIFIED THAT THAT-
THAT THE EDT WHY SYSTEM MAY NOT
BE ACCESSIBLE FOR INDIVIDUALS
WITH DISABILITIES- THAT IT WAS
ALSO CHALLENGING FOR
INDIVIDUALS TO COMMUNICATE OR
CONTACT EDT IF ENGLISH WAS NOT
THEIR PRIMARY LANGUAGE- AND
ADDITIONALLY SOME MAJOR
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT WE BELIEVE
MORE LEGISLATIVE- ATTENTION
THIS TIME INCLUDE THE MAJOR
RECOMMENDATION TO RESTART THE
BENEFITS SYSTEMS MODERNIZATION
PROJECT THAT YOU NEEDS MAJOR I.
T. UPGRADE AS WELL AS
RECOMMENDATIONS OVER ALL OF
THAT THE STE THAT'S THE
DEPARTMENT. OF LOOK THROUGH
EXISTING USER EXPERIENCE-
FORMS- REQUIREMENTS AS WELL AS-
ELIGIBILITY CERTIFICATION
REQUIREMENTS AND IMPROVE THOSE
SUCH THAT WORKERS APPLYING FOR
BENEFITS WOULD BE FACED WITH
WITH FEWER YOUR CONFUSION OR
LESS CONFUSION I SUSPECT HAN
AND REGARDING OUR OUR SPECIFIC
RECOMMENDATIONS- THAT THE
SECRETARY AND THE DIRECTOR
MENTIONED BOTH OF THESE AND SO
WHAT WE WOULD REITERATE-
BECAUSE THEY STRIKE TEAM REPORT
INCLUDES SO MANY
RECOMMENDATIONS A HUNDRED
ELEVEN AS A DIRECTOR MENTIONED-
WE RECOMMEND THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION MAINTAIN A
PROCESS OR PROJECT TRACKER-
WITH EACH RECOMMENDATION JUST A
TABLE. AND ALONGSIDE THE
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR THE STATUS
OF WHERE THE DEPARTMENT. BERMAN
EXPECTS TO IMPLEMENT THAT
RECOMMENDATION. THAT THE REPORT
IS THOROUGH AND LENGTHY AND
HAVING A SHORT BRIEF DOCUMENT
OF THIS KIND WOULD HELP STAFF
AND MEMBERS FOLLOW ALONG AS ET
DE- SETS ABOUT THESE
IMPROVEMENTS AND BE ABLE TO
IDENTIFY MAYBE PROBLEM AREAS
WHERE THE LEGISLATORS
INVOLVEMENT IS WARRANTED. AND
FINALLY AS AS SECRETARY
RICHARDS AND MENTIONED- HE-
DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY IN THE
OFFICE OF DIGITAL INNOVATION
ARE INTENDING TO MAINTAIN
INVOLVEMENT WITH EDT AND HELP
GUIDE- SOME OF THEIR
TECHNOLOGICAL IMPROVEMENTS- BUT
AS WE UNDERSTAND IT DABABNEH
AGENCY ITSELF IS NO LONGER
DIRECTLY INVOLVED IN THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE STRIKE
TEAM RECOMMENDATIONS. AND GIVEN
OUR ASSESSMENT THAT MANY OF
THE- MANY IF NOT MOST OF THE
CAUSES OF THE BACKLOG AND DELAY
WERE OPERATIONAL IN NATURE
RATHER THAN TECHNOLOGICAL WE
WOULD RECOMMEND THAT THE
LEGISLATURE ON REQUEST THAT GOV
OFFICE REMAIN CLOSELY INVOLVED
WITH THE PROJECT AND PROVIDE
OPERATIONAL GUIDANCE AT LEAST
UNTIL EDT HAS ELIMINATED THE
BACKLOG. THANK YOU ARE HAPPY TO
TAKE ANY QUESTIONS. YOUR
CONVENIENCE SURE THANK YOU
MISTER ALMOST TALK ABOUT
OPERATIONAL SHORTCOMINGS THAT'S
NOTHING NEW TO EASY TO USE IF
THE CAR FOR QUITE SOME TIME.
TWO DIFFERENT CHANGES OF
LEADERSHIP IS THAT CORRECT. I
THINK I WOULD CHARACTERIZE IT
AS AS SOME OF THE OPERATIONAL
SHORTCOMINGS THAT. IMMEDIATE
DEFENSE DON'T NECESSARILY
APPEAR ASSHORTCOMINGS WHEN
WORKLOAD IS LOW BECAUSE THEY'RE
MANAGEABLE. BUT I DO BELIEVE
THAT SOME OF THESE SAME ISSUES
AROSE DURING THE GREAT
RECESSION MORE THAN TEN YEARS
AGO- THAT WE'RE SEEING NOW
DURING DURING THE PANDEMIC SO
YES SIR. WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT
THE FOCUS ON FRAUD- ISN'TIT IS
IT TRUE THAT A LOT OF THAT
FOCUS IS MANDATED BY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. NOT SO MUCH
CALIFORNIA POLICIES. THAT'S
TRUE SIR- THAT DO YOU I PROGRAM
IS A STATE FEDERAL PARTNERSHIP
THE STATE RECEIVES FEDERAL
FUNDING AND WITH THAT FEDERAL
FUNDING THAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT SETS PERFORMANCE
STANDARDS NOW THEY SET
STANDARDS ON UP OVERPAYMENTS
WHICH IS THAT THE FRAUD
STANDARD WE'RE TALKING HERE BUT
THEY ALSO SET STANDARDS ON
BENEFIT TIMELINESS- IN THE
OPINION OF THE STRIKE TEAM
REPORT IN SOME OF THEIR
FINDINGS THEY POINT OUT THAT
THE STATE HAD. TENDED TO
EMPHASIZE THE FEDERAL
REQUIREMENTS ABOUT FRAUD. MORE
SO THAN THEY'VE EMPHASIZED THE
FEDERAL REQUIREMENTS ABOUT
BENEFIT PAYMENT TIMELINESS AND-
WITH THE POINT WE WOULD RAISE
IS. AT THIS POINT DURING A
PANDEMIC GIVEN THE ECONOMIC
CIRCUMSTANCES. THAT BALANCE-
MAY HAVE BEEN. I CHALLENGE FOR
EDT N. AND ADDRESSING ITS
BACKLOG- GIVEN ITS HISTORICAL-
FOCUS ON THAT FRAUD PREVENTION
MEASURE BUT REGARDLESS THESE
ARE BOTH FEDERAL MANDATES
CORRECT. THEY ARE YES OKAY SO
ITEMS SUCH AS WILL MAKE IT
CLEAR THAT IS NOT SOMETHING
THAT CALIFORNIA. IS DOING OF
ITS OWN VOLITION IS MANDATED BY
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. I THINK
THAT'S A FAIR CHARACTERIZATION
SIR- THE MANDATES THEMSELVES
ARE PERFORMANCE TARGETS SO THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT PROVIDE SOME
GUIDANCE ON HOW WE SHOULD GO
ABOUT MEETING THOSE TARGETS.
BUT DOESN'T NECESSARILY
PRESCRIBE EXACTLY HOW WE WOULD
DO SO- ONE INSTANCES THAT IT
MAY WELL BE THE CASE THAT THE
STATE COULD HAVE REACHED ITS-
OVERPAYMENT FEDERAL TARGET. BY
USING A DIFFERENT STRATEGY FOR
VERIFYING CLAIMS- THE ID NEED
TOOL IS CERTAINLY ONE EXAMPLE
THAT THE STATE COULD HAVE
INSTITUTED. SEVERAL YEARS AGO-
TO READ SOME OF THE THAT MANUAL
VERIFICATION PROCESS BACKLOG
FROM ACCUMULATING. OKAY THANK
YOU. MY NEXT QUESTION FOR THIS
HILLIARD. I KNOW YOU TALKED
ABOUT CLINK CLINK CLAIMS. IN
THEIR EASY RESET I KNOW YOU'VE
DONE SOME CASELOADS BUT- IT
WENT DOWN FROM ONE POINT SIX
MILLION TO ONE POINT THREE
MILLION. SO NOT A NOT A BIG
DENT IN THAT. I GUESS MY
QUESTION FOR YOU IS- WE'RE JUST
STARTING IN OCTOBER. SO YOU'RE
SAYING THAT YOU WON'T LOOK AT
IT THE BACKLOG UNTIL JANUARY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. CAN YOU TELL
ME WHAT'S GONNA TAKE THAT LONG
TO DO THAT. I GUESS I YOU'RE
CORRECT- IT'S GOING TO THAT
LONG BECAUSE THAT'S THE THAT
THE WORK IS VERY COMPLEX AND
COMPLICATED. AND WE HAVE X.
NUMBER OF A PROFESSIONAL STAFF
THAT ARE SKILLED IN AND
TRAINED. IN THOSE AREAS EVEN
THOUGH WE HAVE REDIRECTED FOLKS
ADDS UP RECOMMENDED IN THAT
STRIKE FORCE. I IN THE STRIKE
TEAM REPORT TO ENSURE OUR MOST
EXPERIENCED PEOPLE ARE ON THE
MOST COMPLEX. TASS AND RT SIX
VARIANTS PEOPLE ARE NOT USED-
COMPLEX TASK UNTIL SUCH TIME WE
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO TRAIN
THEM. SO WE'RE UTILIZING ALL
AVAILABLE RESOURCES IN A VERY
SYSTEMATIC WAY TO ENSURE THAT
WORKING THE BACKLOG AT QUICKLY
IN. AND FILLING IT DOWN AS FAST
AS WE CAN AS WELL AS LOOKING AT
MAINTAINING THAT INVENTORY
THAT'S COMING IN. SO ON ONCE
WE'VE CLEAR THE AT THE BACK WE
DO BELIEVE WE'RE IN GOOD WILL
BE IN GOOD SHAPE MOVING FORWARD
TO ASSUMING. THERE'S ANOTHER
PANDEMIC OR SOME SOME OTHER
UNKNOWN THING COMES ALONG SO AS
FAR AS A BACKLOG GOES WHAT IS
THE OLDEST CASE YOU HAVE. IS IT
BEEN LIKE SEVERAL MONTHS OUT
THERE AND THEY MAY FACE IN THE
FOR YOU KNOW IN THE NOVEMBER
DECEMBER. WHAT WHAT'S WHAT'S
THE AVERAGE WAIT TIME ON THESE
CASES. YEAH IT JUST DEPENDS ON
WHAT THE SITUATION AND WHERE
THEIR- I GUESS STUCK IN THIS IN
THE PROCESS BUT WE DO HAVE
CLAIMS AS OLD AS OUT IN JUNE.
SUBMERGING JULY AUGUST THE
OLDER ONES. SO YOU'RE TALKING
JUNE JUNE JULY AUGUST SEPTEMBER
OCTOBER IN THOSE PLANS ARE
STILL PENDING OUT THERE AND
THAT'S THAT'S FIVE MONTHS FIVE
OR SIX MONTHS ALREADY. YES
THAT'S VERY LENGTHY- RICK
REGARDING YOUR THE YOUR
INVESTIGATIONS WITH CC ARE
OBVIOUSLY YOU'RE GETTING THE
INMATES LIST THERE'S NOT ONE
BUT WE SEE A LOT OF FOLKS IN
COUNTY JAIL INMATES HERE
SEVERAL COUNTY THAT HAVE.
RACKED UP TEN OR TWELVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS USING THE
STATE ISSUED OR COUNTY ISSUED
IPADS TO DO THESE CLAIMS. HOW
MANY INVESTIGATORS HAVE AN
EIGHTY D. WE HAVE TWENTY SEVEN
INVESTIGATORS. FROM AN EIGHTY
TWO FOR THESE PRODUCT THESE
CRIMINAL FRAUD ACTIVITIES- THE
CDC ARE IS IT IS VERY- MORE
AFTER THE FACT BECAUSE
UNFORTUNATELY THEY DON'T HAVE A
LIST THAT WE CAN CROSS MATCH IT
IN AT THE VERY GET GO. BUT WE
ARE WORKING WITH THEM TO DO
WHAT WE CAN TO IDENTIFY ANY
CRIMINAL ACTIVITY THAT'S GOING
ON UNFORTUNATELY WITH THE
PANDEMIC ASSISTANCE PROGRAM
THERE REALLY ISN'T ANY. IT HAS
IT'S LENIENT RULES THAT- IF
PEOPLE HAVE THE UTILIZED THEIR
OWN NAME AND SOCIAL SECURITY
NUMBER AND- YOU KNOW PRIVATELY
IT STATE OR NOT AND YOU KNOW
NOT A CURSE RATED. IT'S VERY
HARD TO DETECT LET'S WE KNOW
THAT THEY WERE ACTUALLY
INCARCERATED SOMETIME WE ONLY
KNOW THAT IS IF CDCR IS ABLE TO
GIVE US THE INFORMATION WE
NEED. SO THERE'S NO WAY YOU
WOULD KNOW IF SOMEONE'S DOING
IN THE COUNTY JAIL BECAUSE MOST
FOLKS ARE GOING BACK STATE
PRISON THESE DAYS. I THINK IT'S
INTERESTING BECAUSE THE COUNTY
HERE SEVERAL COUNTY WHEN FOLKS
WENT INTO CUSTODY A LOT OF A
RECEIVING GENERAL ASSISTANCE
THEY HAD THEY'RE ABLE TO TALK
WITH. THE SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT.
THAT ONCE THOSE FILES FROM THE
CUSTODY THERE STOPPED THEY STOP
GETTING GENERAL ASSISTANCE. AND
THAT WAS DEEMED TO BE VERY
EFFECTIVE WITH THAT- ARE. YOU
GUYS WORKING ON A PLAN TO TALK
TO THE COUNTIES I. AT THIS
POINT BEEN WORKING WITH
DEPARTMENT OF LABOR AND CDCR.
MORE ON THAT LEVEL- WORKS IN
FOCUSING ON THAT. BUT CERTAINLY
OUR HOPE IS TO WORK WITH THE
COUNTY. SURE SO SINCE YOU HAVE
TWENTY SEVEN INVESTIGATORS AT
STATEWIDE IN A STATE OF FORTY
MILLION PEOPLE. I NOW OKAY MOST
THIS FALLS ON THE LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT DOES IT AND I'M
GONNA POINT OUT MMHM I READ A
HIGH TECH CRIMES TASK FORCES
CENTRAL VALLEY THAT TARGETED
THIS TYPE OF- ACTION FOR THREE
YEARS. AND I JUST TO MY
COLLEAGUES THERE'S BEEN NO
INCREASE IN FUNDING SINCE TWO
THOUSAND ELEVEN SO NINE YEARS-
IT HAS INCREASED AT ALL THIS IS
BILLY TWO MILLION DOLLARS TO
DELIVER THE BEST TO GET IT. AND
THEY HAVE THE ABILITY TO DO
THAT SO- IF THAT'S SOMETHING WE
HAVE TO LOOK AT- SO REAL QUICK
ON ON THE ID ME. THAT USING OF.
FACIAL RECOGNITION. ANOTHER
THEIR CROSS MATCHING WITH A
DIFFERENT CREDIT REPORTS-
TELEPHONE AT BILLS A DIFFERENT
HOUSEHOLD FACILITY BILLS
THEY'RE ALSO LOOKING AT THE-
THE PICTURE OF THE ID'S IS. BUT
ON THAT. NOTE SAID NO INTEREST
YOU KNOW INTRICATE WORKINGS OF
IT BUT- RIGHT BUT I ALSO. I
ALSO DID PROVIDE YOU ALL THE
HAND OUT I HOPE JUST FOR YOUR
INFORMATION ON IT ME THAT THEY
PROVIDED ME TO TALK ABOUT THEIR
WE GOT THAT MY I GUESS MY
QUESTION ON THAT IS IF WITH ID
ME THAT THERE'S HOLOGRAMS THAT
WE HAVE ON OUR TO ISSUE ID'S.
AND SOMEONE TAKING A PICTURE
THAT YOU CAN'T LOOK AT THOSE
HOLOGRAMS. AND THOSE LABELS TO
TELL ON THAT SO I'M CURIOUS
ABOUT HOW YOU VALIDATE THAT
BECAUSE- IT'S VERY EASY. TO
PRODUCE A FAKE ID. THIS IS A
PICTURE AND- SO UNLESS YOU'RE
USING THAT IT I WAS WONDERING
ABOUT THAT. YOU KNOW PERSONALLY
I DON'T KNOW BUT WE CERTAINLY
COULD TALK TO ID MAN LET YOU
KNOW THIS FAR AS DIEM VIGO'S
OBVIOUSLY EVERYONE MOST PEOPLE
STATE HAVE A DRIVER'S LICENSE
OR ID. AT EMAIL HOW'S THAT
WORKINGWITH DMV HAVE ACCESS TO
THEIR FULL- I GUESS WHAT I
THINK WE'VE BEEN USING- MATT
ACROSS MATCH WITH DMV AND THE
SO SECURITY FOR MANY YEARS NOW
THAT HAS BEEN SORT OF OUR ARMED
I MAIN METHOD OF IDENTITY
PROOFING. BUT NOT NOT
PHOTOGRAPHS UP TILL NOW IT'S
JUST THE FACT THAT YOU HAVE AN
ID. YEAH. SO I GUESSI'M LIKE
WITH MY QUESTION FOR YOU DOES
IF YOU DO NEED MORE ACCESS TO
DMV TO THE DMV PHOTOS. WOULD
THAT MAKE THE JOB EASIER. WELL
I BELIEVE IT ME AS I MEAN IT
THERE THAT COMPANY IS WHAT WHO
ARE CONTRACTING WITH IN ORDER
TO DO THAT DON'T APPROVING SO I
THINK. THAT IS ADDRESSING ARE
ARE THE MAIN CONCERN OF WHO YOU
KNOW THAT WE'RE ACTUALLY DOING
BUSINESS WITH THE PERSON.
THAT'S BUT ALL THE INFORMATION
THEY GET IS ISRAEL TABLE THE
DARK WEB WE'RE MOSTLY FLEXIBLE
A DARK LIVING IN GETTING
SOMEONE'S NAME SOCIAL SECURITY
NUMBER ADDRESS I MEAN THEY HAVE
YOUR WHOLE PROFILE. SO SOMEONE
WOULD HAVE ACCESS TO THAT
INFORMATION IF ASKED IN
INCLUDES DON THAT THAT'S REALLY
AVAILABLE RIGHT NOW SO. I'M I'M
TRYING TO RECONCILE THAT FACT.
AND THEN WITH THE I. D. AND
THEN TAKING THE PHOTOGRAPH OF
THEMSELVES. RIGHT AT SECRETARY
RICHARD SAID I DON'T KNOW IF
ANY TIMES AVAILABLE TO TALK
ABOUT- ID ME AS SORT OF. HE'S
BEEN. PLAYED AN INSTRUMENTAL
ROLE IN THE IMPLEMENTATION AND-
PROBABLY SPEAK TO IT MUCH BUT
THAN ME. YES HI. HELLO CHAIR
AND THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THIS IS AMY TONG AND
STATE AT ITS MISSION OFFICER
AND- I CANPICK UP PERHAPS
ADDRESS SOME OF THE QUESTION
THAT WAS RAISED- BY MEMBER
COOPER- SPECIFICALLY- ALTHOUGH
REVERSE ORDER A MEMBER COOPER
SPECIFICALLY TO THE INFORMATION
THAT IS. A COMPARISON WITH THE
DMB BECAUSE DMB IN THEIR REAL
ID PROCESS ARE USING SAME
TECHNOLOGY ID ME UP THROUGH A
DOCUMENT VERIFICATION PROCESS
SO THE INTENT IS THAT AFTER
THIS INITIAL IMPLEMENTATION OF
ID ME SPECIFICALLY WITH EDT WE
WILL BE LOOKING AT WHETHER
THERE ARE SUFFICIENT FURTHER
EFFICIENCY THAT CAN BE GAINED
BY EDT AND EMB WORKING TOGETHER
TO- PROCESS- SOME IDENTITY
VERIFICATION FASTER A ONE THING
I DO LIKE TO NOTE FOR THE
INDIVIDUAL THAT HAVE ALREADY
SIGNED UP. WITH AN IDEA ME
ACCOUNT THROUGH THE DMB PROCESS
THEY DO NOT NEED TO RECREATE
THOSE ACCOUNTS AND KEY BE
AUTOMATICALLY LOG IN USING THAT
SAME ACCOUNT OVER IT EDT
WHETHER THEREFORE IN THE EARLY
RESULTS WE HAVE SEEN SINCE ITS
IMPLEMENTATION THERE'S ACTUALLY
OVER 25% OF INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
APPLYING TO EDT RIGHT NOW ARE
USING THE EXISTING. IT ME
ACCOUNT. AND YEAH AND- MEMBER
COMMITTED TO YOUR QUESTION A
WHETHER IDEA CONSTRUED A FACIAL
RIGHT WHEN USING FACIAL
RECOGNITION- I'M AT AND AGAIN
YOU KNOW THIS WILL BE A
QUESTION. OF BETTER ADDRESS
BITING ME DIRECTLY BUT FROM THE
EXPERIENCE THAT WE HAVE APPLIED
IN THIS THIS IS NOT A FACIAL
RECOGNITION TYPE OF
VERIFICATION IT'S ACTUALLY
USING- INFORMATION SUCH AS THE
INDIVIDUALS. A DRIVER'S LICENSE
AND- I'VE ACTUALLY PERSON HAD
GONE THROUGH THE PROCESS AS IT
ONE OF THE BETA TESTER. AND
THERE'S QUESTION ASKED ABOUT-
YOU KNOW YOU'RE YOU'RE
FINANCIAL DATA AND USE DOES AS
BACKGROUND INFORMATION TO
VERIFY. AND OTHERS OTHER
REGISTRATION INFORMATION OF USE
USING A PHONE ARE YOU IS THE
PHONE REGISTERED TO YOU EXEDRA
EXIDE RUSSELL THERE'S MULTIPLE
ALGORITHM DOLLARS USED. BEFORE
THAT OUR FACIAL RECOGNITION
EVEN BEING APPLIED TO ALL THOSE
LINES. ARE VISIBLE IN THE DARK
LEAD TO. EVERY ITEM MENTIONED
BILL ON THE DOOR WEB BECAUSE
THAT INFORMATION CAN. THROUGH
DATA BREACHES OVER THE YEARS.
PRICE I WANT TO SEPARATE IT OUT
SO- I'M ALSO A VERY MUCH AS
ONE OF THE ACCOLADE OF THE-
CALIFORNIA CYBER SECURITY
INTEGRATION CENTERSTHAT ARE
ENGAGED- WITH EDT ON A SEPARATE
EFFORT TO LOOKING INTO FRAUD
ASPECT. I WANTED TO SEPARATE
OUT THE INFORMATION ON THE DARK
WEB S. MIGHT HAVE BRED IS
IDENTITY THAT HAS ALREADY BEEN
STOLEN OR IDENTITY THAT IS
ACCOUNTS ARE CREATED WITH EDT A
FURTHER TO BE SOLD ON THE DARK
WEB- FOR THOSE IDENTITY THAT BE
STOLEN- THEY WOULD HAVE A- A
DIFFICULTY GOING THROUGH THE ID
NEED VERIFICATION PROCESS.
BECAUSE FOR THE INDIVIDUAL THE
WHOSE NEEDS TO VERIFIED YOU
WOULD NEED TO KNOW MORE THAN
ONE TO COMPONENT OF THAT ENTITY
IN OTHER WORDS NOT JUST YOUR
DRIVER'S LICENSE NUMBER. IS
YOUR DRIVER'S LICENSE PLUS
SOMETHING SIMILAR TO LIKE WHAT
IS YOUR MORTGAGE COMPANY AND
THINGS LIKE THAT THAT ARE NOT
SOMETHING THAT I PERSONALLY CAN
BE. BOUGHT THROUGH FROM A-
DRIVER'S LICENSE INFORMATION
PERSPECTIVE SO THERE'S THAT
MULTI FACTOR VERIFICATION
PROCESS. INVOLVED THANK YOU
MISTER SHE- THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN LET ME JUST START BY-
IT WITH THE GOOD NEWS ABOUT
THIS REPORT. THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT AND CRITICAL
DOCUMENT- I REALLY WANNAGIVE
KUDOS TO- OUR CABINET SECRETARY
GOVE OPS AS WELL AS MISS
PARKER- THE STRIKE TEAM
DESERVES. A LOT OF CREDIT FOR
TAKING ON THIS VERY DIFFICULT
TASK OF ANALYZING HOW TO TURN
AROUND THE AGENCY THAT IS
BROKEN FOR BEEN BROKEN FOR
YEARS. ALSO JUST TAKE A MOMENT
IN FACT THAT MANY MEMBERS OF
RANK AND FILE EDT FOR ALL THEIR
WORK DURING THIS TIME PERIOD.
WHAT I WILL SAY ABOUT THIS
REPORT IS IT SAYS. WHAT MANY OF
US IN THE LEGISLATURE HAVE BEEN
SAYING FOR MONTHS IN A
BIPARTISAN WAY THIS REPORT.
DOCUMENTS IN EXCRUCIATING
DETAIL HOW EDT HAS FAILED
CALIFORNIA IN EVERY IMAGINABLE
WAY HOW BROKEN THIS AGENCY HAS
BEEN. IN THE HUNDRED NINE PAGES
OF THIS REPORT WITH OVER A
HUNDRED RECOMMENDATIONS. IT
PROVIDES A ROADMAP AND MY HOPE
IS WE ARE AT THE LOWEST POINT
OF THIS AGENCY AT A TIME WHEN
OUR CONSTITUENTS HAVE GONE INTO
EXTREME DEBT DEPLETED THEIR
LIFE SAVINGS AND ARE HAVING
TROUBLE PAYING FOR RENT AND
PUTTING FOOD ON THE TABLE. I
THE NUMBER OF. COMMENTS AND
QUESTIONS LET ME JUST START
FIRST WITH THE ODOMETER ON THE
BACKLOG. TO DIRECTOR. AS WE
DISCUSSED IN PRIOR HEARINGS. WE
WERE NEVER ABLE TO GET. AN UP
FRONT ANSWER FROM YOU ABOUT THE
SIZE OF THE BACKLOG. AT A
MEETING WITH MANY LEGISLATORS.
YOU ANSWERED A QUESTION BY OUR
BUDGET YEAR MR TANG. ABOUT THE
SIZE OF THE BACKLOG IN JULY
WHERE YOU SAID THE BACKLOG WAS
A HUNDRED THOUSAND. NEW A FEW
HUNDRED THOUSAND A HUNDRED
THOUSAND. THEN TOWARD THE-
TOWARD OF A FEW WEEKS LATER THE
ADMINISTRATION TOLD US THE
BACKLOG WAS ONE POINT ONE
MILLION. TO BE CLEAR BY THE END
OF SEPTEMBER. AND THEN WHEN
THIS REPORT CAME OUT. LATE ON A
SATURDAY NIGHT WE LEARNED THAT
THE BACKLOG WAS ONE POINT SIX
MILLION CLAIMS. TO BE CLEARED
BY THE END OF JANUARY. SO MY
QUESTION IS GIVEN THIS HISTORY.
OF CHALLENGES OF UNDERSTANDING
THE SIZE OF THE BACKLOG AND
WHEN IT'S GOING TO BE CLEARED.
I HOPE YOU CAN UNDERSTAND WE
MAY LACK SOME CONFIDENCE AND
UNDERSTANDING AND BELIEVING
THAT THIS IS A SIZE OF THE
BACKLOG AND WHEN IT'S GOING TO
GET CLEARED AND I WANTED TO
ASK. ARE YOU FULLY CONFIDENT
THAT THIS IS THE SIZE OF THE
BACKLOG AND THAT IT'S GONNA BE
CLEARED BY THE END OF JANUARY.
WHICH BY THE WAY IS A DATE
THAT'S OBVIOUSLY MANY MONTHS
FROM NOW AND A VERY CHALLENGING
DAY FOR CONSTITUENTS. YES I
UNDERSTAND THAT I YES I AM VERY
CONFIDENT THAT THE- TO THE WAY
THAT WE ARE LOOKING AT THE
BACKLOG NOW SHOWS A VERY. OF
TOTAL POPULATIONS UP THE WAY WE
WERE LOOKING AT IT BACK IN THIS
SPRING IN THE SUMMER. OF WAS
REALLY BASED ON- WORKLOAD OF
WHEN PEOPLE TURNED IN- ITEMS-
NOW WE'RE LOOKING AT THE
RECOMMENDATION OF THE STRIKE
TEAM. A MORE HOLISTIC- NOT ONLY
UP WE'RE LOOKING AT INVENTORY
WORK THAT. WE HAVE. ON OUR
PLATE THAT WE NEED TO GET DONE
BUT ALSO WE'RE LOOKING AT.
CLAIMS WERE- OUR OUR CLAIMANTS
HAVE NOT RESPONDED TO US
BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT THERE'S
PROBABLY SITUATIONS WHERE THEY
TRIED TO GET WORK THROUGH US OR
GET A HOLD OF US AND COULDN'T
AND MAYBE STILL ARE OUT THERE.
SO WE'RE INCLUDING ALL OF THOSE
PEOPLE NOW AS PART OF THE
BACKLOG IT'S MUCH MORE
INCLUSIVE THAT'S WHY IT GREW SO
MUCH- SO MUCH LARGER. BUT WE
WANTED TO MAKE SURE WE ARE
COUNTING FOR EACH AND EVERY
PERSON THAT COULD POSSIBLY. OF
BE ELIGIBLE FOR BENEFITS AND-
AND WORK THROUGH IT SO. WE ARE
FEELING VERY GOOD ABOUT- LAST
TWO WEEKS AND ARE BURNED DOWN
WHAT WE'RE ABLE TO ACCOMPLISH
WE'RE ON TRACK- IT NEEDS
LOOKING GOOD SO AT THIS POINT
BARRING ANY OTHER. NEW FEDERAL
LEGISLATION OR OR OR OR WHAT
NOT. WE FEEL VERY CONFIDENT AND
VERY GOOD THAT WILL. CLEAR ON
<c.red>N JANUARY. OBVIOUSLY WILL BE</c>
MY THIS THE COMING MONTH
BECAUSE TO BE HONEST IT'S VERY
HARD FOR US TO TELL OUR
CONSTITUENTS. THAT WE HAVE A
100% CERTAINTY THAT THIS WILL
GET RESOLVED IN THE NEXT COUPLE
MONTHS GIVEN. THE TRACK RECORD
NAPS- YOU KNOW I APPRECIATE
THAT THAT YOU'VE EXPRESSED
SOME. SOME PRIDE IN IN THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF IT MAY. I DO
HAVE SOME QUESTIONS JUST ON THE
PRESS RELEASE THAT WE WERE
PROVIDED IN THE LAST TWELVE
HOURS. YOU SAID MORE THAN STE
ABOUT SIXTY FOUR PERCENT. OF
INDIVIDUALS WERE ABLE TO VERIFY
THEIR ID ONLINE TO READY MADE.
PRIOR TO THE IMPLEMENTATION YOU
TOLD THE PUBLIC THAT ABOUT 60%
OF APPLICANTS WERE ABLE TO
AUTOMATICALLY VERIFY OR PUT
ANOTHER WAY. 40% WERE FLAGGED
FOR MANUAL REVIEW AND THAT'S
WHAT TOOK SO MUCH TIME. SO FROM
WHAT WE CAN TELL LOOKS LIKE
WE'VE GONE FROM 60% AUTOMATIC
VERIFICATION. 66% AUTOMATIC
VERIFICATION WHEN YOU TOLD US
WEEKS AGO THAT ID ME WOULD
AUTOMATICALLY VERIFIED OVER
NINETY ONE. PERCENT OF
ADVOCATES. SO HAS THIS TO MEET
YOUR EXPECTATIONS IT DOESN'T
SEEM LIKE THAT FROM THE VERY
NUMBER PROVIDED US. YEAH
ABSOLUTELY IS PERFORMING AS
EXPECTED AS FAR AS THE UP THE
COMPLETE 9091% THAT WE'RE GOING
FOR IS STILL TOO EARLY TO TAKE
A LOOK AT. THOSE NUMBERS- WE
JUST HAVE SARTED GETTING
CLAIMS IN AND THEY HAVEN'T RUN
THROUGH ALL OF OUR AUTOMATED
PROCESSES EVEN OUTSIDE OF. IT
ME SO THE WE DON'T WE DON'T
REALLY HAVE ANY GOOD METRICS
YET AS FAR AS AS WHAT'S BEING
DONE THROUGH AUTOMATICALLY. WE
DO HAVE METRICS AS FAR AS HOW
MANY PEOPLE ARE. GETTING
THROUGH IT ME AND- WERE THERE
BEING VALIDATED AND THEY'RE
BEING CLEARED. IF I COULD JUST
SAY YOU KNOW WE WERE EXPECTING
AN AUTOMATIC VERIFICATION OF
91% AND WHAT WE'RE SEEING NOW
IS AUTOMATIC VERIFICATION OF
SIXTY FOUR PERCENT. THAT'S A
REALLY BIG DIFFERENCE I'M JUST
GONNA LEAVE THAT AS A COMMENT-
AGAIN I'M NOT JUST WHICH- IS
ACTUALLY MOVING THINGS FASTER
BUT I HOPE TO BE. UP ENOUGH
HOPE THAT WE'LL GET MORE
INFORMATION. MORE TALK FOR A
MOMENT ABOUT THE DASHBOARD AND
JUST MAKE A COMMENT ABOUT IT.
THIS LEGISLATURE LED BY OUR
COLLEAGUE ASSEMBLY MEMBER DALY.
MOVE FORWARD WITH BUDGET
TRAILER LANGUAGE- AND ALSO WITH
OUR CHAIRMAN. AB ONE OH SEVEN
SO THAT WE COULD HAVE A SENSE
OF. A TRACKING. AND I HAVE TO
SAY. I'D GIVE ET D. MAYBE A D.
WHEN IT COMES TO HOW YOU HAVE
SHOWN YOUR INFORMATION SO YOU
YOU YOU YOU PROVIDE A
DASHBOARD. THAT'S VERY
DIFFICULT FOR THE PUBLIC TO
FIND. IT SHOULD BE EASILY
ACCESSIBLE ON YOUR WEBSITE BUT
INSTEAD IT'S LINKED IN A PRESS
RELEASE. IT'S IN A PDF FORM. SO
IT'S IMPOSSIBLE TO COMPARE WEEK
TO WEEK INFORMATION THEIR
SEPARATE PDF FORMS. FOR DALY
INITIAL VERSUS DALY CONTINUED
BACKLOGS. IT'S CONFUSING IT'S
HARD TO NAVIGATE IT'S NOT
TRANSPARENT IT'S NOT
ACCOUNTABLE. THIS IS NOT THE
SPIRIT OF WHAT WE ASK YOU TO
DO. COULD YOU GIVE SOME
COMMENTS ON THE DASHBOARD. AND
HOW YOU ENDED UP. PROVIDE INTO
US THIS WAY. IN AB ONE SEVEN IT
WAS VERY WHAT WE WERE WHAT DATA
L. WE REFER TO. AND THAT'S
EXACTLY WHAT WE DID- I
CERTAINLY WILL GO BACK AGAIN
THANK YOU FOR YOUR FEEDBACK AND
ALL TALK MY COMMUNICATIONS
PEOPLE TO SEE IF THERE'S
ANYTHING WE COULD DO TO MAKE IT
MORE USER FRIENDLY BUT WE WERE
RESPONDING TO EXACTLY WHAT THE
LEVEL OF WHAT THE LEGISLATION
AND SAD. NOW WITH OUR NEW
DASHBOARDS OUR HOPE IS TO REACH
OUT TO THE COMMITTEE AND- SORT
OF THAT REPLACE IT WITH THE NEW
DASHBOARD METRICS AS AS
RECOMMENDED BY THE STRIKE TEAM.
I WOULD SUGGEST THAT- WHEN WE
CAN HAVE ANOTHER CONVERSATION
ABOUT IT BUT I DON'T THINK THIS
THE DASHBOARD YOU PROVIDED
MEETS WITH THE SPIRIT OF WHAT
WE WERE ASKING YOU TO DO BUT
THAT'S A CONVERSATION FOR
ANOTHER DAY. FROM WHAT I ASK
YOU A QUESTION RENT ACCESS AND
WHO GETS TO ACCESS YOUR SYSTEM
ARE YOU FAMILIAR WITH HOW MANY
CALIFORNIANS DON'T SPEAK
ENGLISH AT THEIR HOME YOU KNOW
THE NUMBERS. NO I DON'T NOT SIX
ABOUT IT'S ABOUT 40% OF OUR
STATE AND ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT THE STRIKE. TEAM REPORT
LAID OUT IS THAT INDIVIDUALS
pFACE INSURMOUNTABLE BARRIERS
WHEN IT COMES TO ADDRESSING
UNITY WE HAVE HEARD FROM- NOT
JUST OUR CONSTITUENTS BUT CIVIL
RIGHTS ORGANIZATIONS. WHO HAVE
BEEN. WHO CAN REACH OUT TO YOU
ON THIS UP WE I HAVE BROUGHT
THIS UP TO YOUR ATTENTION. IN
FACT IN REPORT I WAS- I WAS
PLEASED. YOU ACTUALLY COPIED
LANGUAGE THAT I HAD PROVIDED TO
YOUR OFFICE- WEEKS AGO- AND I
APPRECIATE THE PLAGIARISM
BECAUSE IN THIS CASE.IT
REFLECTS THE FACT THAT YOUR
AGENCY IS AT RISK OF VIOLATING.
OUR STATE LANGUAGE ACCESS LAW.
AND FROM WHAT I CAN TELL THERE
HASN'T BEEN ANY. PROGRESS IN
ADDRESSING THE NEEDS OF
INDIVIDUALS FOR WHOM ENGLISH IS
NOT THEIR FIRST LANGUAGE. I'D
LIKE TO ASK WHAT'S GOING ON IN
THAT AREA I'M HOPING THERE'S
BEEN PROGRESS BUT ACCORDING TO
THE STRIKING REPORT. AND
ACCORDING TO THE EXPERIENCE OF
OUR CONSTITUENTS THERE HAS BEEN
ON. WE GET LANGUAGE ACCESS IS A
VITAL AREA THERE WERE ALWAYS
WORKING TOWARDS- WE DO HAVE AN
NUMBER DIFFERENT AVENUES FOR
PEOPLE TO WORK THROUGH. WE HAVE
A VERY STIFF MULTIPLE LANGUAGES
ON OUR OUR- PHONE LINE. WE ALSO
HAVE A SERVICE OF PEOPLE CALL
IT'S NOT A LANGUAGE WE
IMMEDIATELY HAVE WE CAN- YOU
KNOW. BRING PEOPLE IN TO HELP
WITH THE TRANSLATION. WE
CONTINUE TO WORK ON FORM
CHANGES AND UPDATES ON. OUR
APPLICATION IS IN SPANISH AND
ENGLISH I KNOW THAT'S YOU KNOW
THEY'RE STILL MANY OTHERS IN
OTHER LANGUAGES. BUT THAT WE
TAKE THAT VERY SERIOUSLY AND WE
CONTINUE TO WORK ON IT EVERY
DAY. IT'S JUST NOT A QUICK FIX
IT JUST IT TAKES TIME AND
RESOURCES. BUT I TELL I TOTALLY
CONCUR WE NEED TO DO MORE IN
THAT ARENA. I WILL SAY BIG WITH
PANDEMIC IT'S NOT SPECIFIC TO-
ENGLISCHER OR NON ENGLISH
SPEAKING PEOPLE. EVERYBODY HAS
HAD A- STRUGGLE WITH IT AS WE
ALL KNOW JUST BECAUSE OF THE
SHEER MASSES IN THIS YEAR
VOLUMES. SO YEAH THAT'S NOT A
GOOD SITUATION I TOTALLY AGREE.
SO IF I COULD JUST RESPOND TO
THAT YOU'VE GIVEN THAT SAME
ANSWER FOR THE LAST SIX MONTHS
WE'VE ASKED YOU THIS QUESTION
IN MANY MANY WAYS WERE TOLD YOU
GUYS ARE WORKING ON IT- WE TOLD
WE'RE TOLD THAT THEY'RE GONNA
BE IMPROVEMENTS ON THE PHONE
LINES AND EMAILS ON THE FORMS.
NONE OF US HAVE SEEN IT WE
HAVEN'T SEEN ANY IMPROVEMENT IN
THIS AREA- AND I'M AT A POINT
WHERE WHEN A CIVIL RIGHTS
ORGANIZATION BRINGS THIS TO MY
ATTENTION- I THINK WE ARE ON
ON. ON VERY DANGEROUS GROUND
YOU'RE VIOLATING THE CIVIL
RIGHTS. OF OUR CONSTITUENTS LET
ME JUST. ADD A COUPLE MORE
POINTS FROM CHALLENGES TO AXIS
OF THE REPORT. ALSO LAYS OUT
THAT CALIFORNIA'S WITH
DISABILITIES ARE INCREDIBLY
CHALLENGE IN ACCESSING THIS AND
I THINK THAT NUMBERS. BETWEEN
10215% OF OUR STATE. AND THEN
REPORT ALSO LAYS OUT THAT IF
YOU'RE A LONGTIME PERSON THAT
DOESN'T HAVE ACCESS TO. A
COMPUTER- YOU'RE REMARKABLY
CHANNELS IF YOU ADD ALL THIS
UP. BETWEEN NON ENGLISH
SPEAKERS. CALIFORNIANS WITH
DISABILITIES CALIFORNIANS
WELCOME. THAT'S AT LEAST OVER
HALF OF OUR- WHO REPRESENTS
SOME OF OUR MOST VULNERABLE
CONSTITUENTS WHO ARE
CHALLENGERS I WANNA MAKE THAT
POINT. ON MODERNIZATION I KNOW
THIS REPORT CALLED FOR A HALT.
OF THE MODERNIZATION EFFORTS
THAT HAD BEEN. AN ELEVEN YEAR
PROJECT THREE YEARS IN THE
MAKING. AND I THINK IT MADE
SENSE TO HOLD THAT REPORT BUT I
AM CONCERNED OF WHAT THE LONG
TERM PLAN AS I LIKE TO ASK. MR
FONG ON THE CALL. WHAT IS YOUR
PERSPECTIVE ON WHAT NEEDS TO
HAPPEN ONCE WE CLEAR THE
BACKLOG OF THE NEXT STEPS OF
MODERNIZATION. HOW CAN WE- USE
THE BEST AND BRIGHTEST OF OUR
STATE WHEN IT COMES TO
TECHNOLOGY INNOVATORS TO.
REALLY. PUT THIS I. T.
CHALLENGE BEHIND US. THANK YOU-
STATE MEMBERSHIP WITHOUT
QUESTION HAPPY TO JUMP IN HERE-
SPECIFICALLY TO THE- PSM
PROJECT I MEAN REFERENCE HERE-
WE- ARE ASKED AND READY. TO
WORK WITH- EDT AS SOON AS THE
BACKLOG IT'S CLEAR- THERE ARE
SEVERAL ITEMS WE'RE GOING TO BE
FOCUSING ON ONE IS TO WORKING
WITH THE OFFICE OF DIGITAL
INNOVATION- WORKING WITH FROM
MY PROCESS RE ENGINEERING
ASPECT. LOOKING AT THE CURRENT
OPERATION IN POLICY AND
PROCEDURE ASPECTS OF THE EIGHTY
TO TAKE A LOOK WHAT IMPROVEMENT
THAT CAN BE MADE. SO IT'S NOT
NECESSARILY APPLYING TECHNOLOGY
TO THE EXISTING PROCESS BUT
USING TECHNOLOGY AS A WAY AND
AS ENABLE OUR TO STREAMLINE THE
PROCESS. AND I BELIEVE- L. A.
O. WAS ALSO REFERENCING THIS
THAT IT'S REALLY BAD POLICY
TECH OF COMBINATION. IS WHAT WE
NEED TO LOOK AT MODERNIZATION.
SECOND TO THAT THERE ARE THREE-
MODULES IF YOU WOULD OUR FOCUS
FOR THE BSN. THAT IS-
DISABILITY INSURANCE AS WELL AS
PAID FAMILY LEAVE THAT'S ON TOP
OF- UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE. AND
WHEN THE RE ASSESSMENT BEGINS
NEEDS TO LOOK AT HOW ARE THE
PRIORITIZES JOKES WITH APPLY.
AND THEN SPECIFICALLY APPLY TO
THE IMMEDIATE NEEDS ON WHAT YOU
DID THE SAME PROVIDE. AND THIRD
ITEM MOST IMPORTANT IS THAT
FROM A USER- INPUT ASPECT. NOW
THAT THIS PANDEMIC HAVE A GREAT
CREATED YOU KNOW IT'S A
TREMENDOUS OF- EXPERIENCE THAT.
THIS WOULD GAIN Y EDT IN TERM
OF WHAT THE BEST WAY TO SERVE-
THOSE- CLAIMANTS OR INDIVIDUALS
NEED SERVICE FROM EDT. TAKING
DOES IMPORT ESTHER DRIVING THE
FOCUS AND THE PRIORITY AND HOW
TO BE. A STREAMLINED TECHNOLOGY
SYSTEMS ARE NEEDED TO PROVIDE
THOSE IS GOING TO BE INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT. AND WITH ALL OF
THAT- AS YOU MENTIONED.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHEWED OUT WE
HAVE GREAT ASK IN THIS OF. AND
WE DO NEED TO SOLD. INPUT AS
WELL AS INNOVATIVE IDEAS FROM
MANY OF THE FIRMS IN VARIOUS IN
SIZE AND THAT SHOULD BE BY
DESIGN SO WE CAN HEAR- MANY
DIFFERENT APPROACHES IN
RESOLVING THIS PROBLEM. THANK
YOU KNOW THAT'S GONNA BE AN
ONGOING CONVERSATION INTO THE
COMING YEARS- I KNOW I'M GONNA
DEFERRED QUESTIONS AROUND FRAUD
TO THE NEXT PANEL ALTHOUGH I'M
ASSUMING AT EDT WILL STILL BE
AVAILABLE FOR QUESTIONS AFTER
THAT. ONE FINAL COMMENT AND
SAID THE QUESTIONS AND THAT IS
ABOUT THE RECOMMENDATIONS IN
THIS REPORT SO THE STRIKE TEAMS
FINISH ITS WORK AND I THINK THE
TOP CONCERN MANY OF US HAVE IS
THESE ARE GREAT
RECOMMENDATIONS. HOW DO WE
ENSURE THEY'RE ALL GONNA GET
DONE WE LEARNED TODAY THAT
FIFTY THREE OF THE HUNDRED
ELEVEN RECOMMENDATIONS AREN'T
EVEN IN PROGRESS. AND WE
HAVEN'T RECEIVED AN ACCOUNTING
OF WHAT THE SIX SIX AND SO. MY
QUESTION TO THE DIRECTOR IS I'M
ASSUMING YOU SUPPORT THE
RECOMMENDATIONS FROM THE ELIO
ABOUT A PROGRESS TRACKER SO
THAT WE CAN SEE EXACTLY WHERE
ALL THESE RECOMMENDATIONS ARE-
LIKE TO ALSO ASK THE STREET
TEAM WHAT IS GOING TO BE YOUR
INVOLVEMENT FOR ENSURING THESE
RECOMMENDATIONS ARE DONE LET ME
JUST. NOTE FROM DISTRICT TEAM
REPORT. THAT THERE WERE MANY
INSTANCES IT WAS IT WAS
FASCINATING READING BECAUSE WE
LEARN FOR EXAMPLE. THAT EVEN
THOUGH THE STRIKE TEAM
RECOMMENDED. THAT EDT TURN OFF
CERTAIN THINGS THAT WERE
FLOODING PLANES FOR MANUAL
PROCESSING. EDT RESISTED THAT
AND DISTRICT TEAM CONCLUDED
THAT EDT COULD'VE AVOIDED
SENDING HUNDREDS OR THOUSANDS
OF CLAIMS TO MANUAL PROCESSING
IF IT. AND LISTEN TO THIS TRACK
TEAM REPORT. DISTRICT ALSO.
WROTE THAT A NUMBER OF THESE
ISSUES WERE SO SIMPLE TO FIX
THAT THERE IS NO EXCUSE FOR WHY
THEY WEREN'T DRESSED PRIOR TO
THE RELEASE OF THIS REPORT. SO
MANY OF US READ THIS. ARE
CONCERNED BECAUSE WE PROVIDED
MANY OF THE RECOMMENDATIONS IN
THIS REPORT TO EDT FOR MONTHS
AND WE WERE NOT. WE WERE NOT
LISTEN TO. SO THE CONCERN IS
NOT THAT THE STRIKE TEAM IS DON
WHO'S ACTUALLY GOT A WHOLE EDT
ACCOUNTABLE. FOR GETTING THIS
DONE SO. SO TO DIRECTOR
HILLIARD. LOVE TO KNOW IF
YOU'RE GONNA BE. AGREEING WITH
THE L. A. RECOMMENDATIONS
AROUND PROGRESS TRACKING AND TO
THE STRIKE TEAM ONE UNDERSTAND
YOUR ROLE MOVING FORWARD YES
ABSOLUTELY WE ARE WE'VE
ACTUALLY ALREADY UPLOADED OUT
WE HAVE A TRACKER GOING. SO
WE'RE JUST FINISHING UP- IN THE
NEXT SEVERAL WEEKS TO FINISH UP
UP THE DATES THAT WE NEED IN
ORDER TO. OF FOR EACH AND
EVERYONE OF THAT RECOMMENDATION
SO ABSOLUTELY I THINK IT'S A
GREAT IDEA. WHEN CAN WE RECEIVE
THAT. I WOULD SAY BY THAT WOULD
BY THE END OF THE MONTH GREAT.
AND THEN TO MADAM SECRETARY-
AGAIN I WANT TO THANK YOU AND
YOUR COLLEAGUES FOR LEADERSHIP
IF IT WERE UP TO ME- YOU GUYS
WOULD KEEP WORKING WITH EDT
VERY CLOSELY FOR THE NEXT SIX
TO TWELVE MONTHS. I KNOW YOU'VE
GOT A LOT OF BALLS ON YOUR
PLATE BUT JUST CURIOUS WHAT
WILL THE INVOLVEMENT OF
DISTRICTING BE MOVING FORWARD.
MEMBERSHIP IF I COULD- STEPPED
IN FOR. A SIGNATURE RICHARDSON
AND IN FACT AFTER THIS I'D LIKE
TO HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY IF YOU
WOULD ALLOW TO OFFER ME TO
PROVIDE SOME CLARIFICATION BACK
ON THE ID ME A STEP TO STICK
TOGETHER. SO THIS IS A QUICKLY
ON THE STRIKE TEAM CONTINUE
ROLE- WE DOES THIS IS A
CONSTANT CONVERSATION AND WE'RE
BEING VERY. OPEN WITH EDT ABOUT
CONTINUE INVOLVEMENT
SPECIFICALLY FROM DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY AND OFFICE OF A
DIGITAL INNOVATION. AND UP IN
CITY TEASE ROLE IN THE
OVERSIGHT WILL BE MONITORING OF
A LOT MORE CLOSER. WITH
IMPLEMENTATION ON THESE- STATS
START ADDRESS AT. INVITING OF A
RECOMMENDATION. AND WITH THE
DATA DRIVEN APPROACH IF THINGS
ARE AND IF WE'RE NOT SEEING
IMPROVEMENT. IN THE EXPECTED
TIME FRAME. AND THERE'S GOOD
DATA AS WELL AS EVIDENCE OF
BACKING BUT THE RESULTS WHY.
THAT WOULD BE THE MEASURE THAT
NEEDS TO BE VERY MUCH-
IMPLEMENTED TO CONTINUE TO
FIGURE OUT IS THERE SOMETHING
ELSE IS CAUSING THAT. OR IS
THERE ARE SOME I'M DISCOVERY
ISSUE THAT PERHAPS THAT'S
CREEPED UP. AND I THINK THAT
LEVEL OF A VERY MUCH IN BED IT
INTERACTION. AS WELL AS
CONSTANT COMMUNICATION AND WITH
THE SUPPORT FROM THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE- WILL BE ABLE TO STAY
QUITE ENGAGE IN TERM OF THE
IMPLEMENTATION. OF ET. HAPPY TO
ENGAGE WITH YOU AND APPRECIATE
YOUR INVOLVEMENT I KNOW OF THE
APARTMENT HAS BEEN DEEPLY
ENGAGE AND I THINK IT'S BEEN. A
VERY MUCH A PART OF THE
POSITIVE. MOVEMENTS WHEN IT
COMES TO THIS REPORT. THANK YOU
MISTER TERRIFIC THANK YOU
MISTER CELLOPHANE. ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER-
COOPER THANK YOU FOR INVITING
ME OF- THE CHAIR OF THE JOINT
LEGISLATIVE AUDIT COMMITTEE
OBVIOUSLY LOOKING AT EDT- SO
REALLY APPRECIATE YOU TAKING
LEADERSHIP AND- I KNOW A LOT OF
MY COLLEAGUES HERE CHAIRS OF
OTHER COMMITTEES THAT. WERE
THIS IS A VERY PERTINENT
INFORMATION I HAVE TWO QUICK
QUESTIONS AND I DID HEAR IT AND
MISS HILLIARD'S. PRESENTATION
BUT YOU KNOW ONE I DO
APPRECIATE THAT HE DID HE'S
WORKING ON THE HUNDRED AND
ELEVEN STRIKE TEAM
RECOMMENDATIONS. EVEN THOUGH AS
MR TO POINT. IT OUT FIFTY THREE
OF THOSE TO HAVE NO PROGRESS ON
THOSE. BUT JUST WANTED ASK
BECAUSE YOU DON'T MIND OF THE
WOODS. I'M GETTING A LOT
COMPLAIN LIKE I KNOW A LOT OF
MY COLLEAGUES ARE ABOUT THE
CALL CENTERS. AND WHEN I READ
THE STRIKE TEAMS REPORT. YOU
KNOW AND WHEN I READ WHAT
STRUCK OUT TO ME WAS THAT. WHEN
INDIVIDUALS WERE CALIFORNIANS
CALL THE D. D. FOR ASSISTANCE
AND HELP. NINETY EIGHT POINT 6%
OF THEM. WERE TOLD TO CALL BACK
BECAUSE THEY COULDN'T RESOLVE
THAT ISSUE ON THAT FIRST CALL.
AND SO MISS HOLDER IF YOU JUST
HELP ME UNDERSTAND HOW THAT'S
BEING ADDRESSED. AND WHY WE
HAVE SO MANY INDIVIDUALS ARE SO
FRUSTRATED. HOW IS THAT JUST.
IF YOU COULD JUST EXPAND A
LITTLE BIT ON THAT BECAUSE I
DIDN'T HEAR THAT IN YOUR
PRESENTATION PLACE. YES SORRY I
DIDN'T TO PROVIDE A CALL CENTER
UPDATE THIS TIMES THAT I DID AT
THE LAST HEARING BUT- WE
CONTINUE TO PROVIDE TRAINING-
RIGHT NOW A LOT OF THAT
TRAINING WERE PUTTING ON HOLD
WHILE WE WORK THROUGH THE
BACKLOG. BUT AS SOON AS A
BACKLOG IS CLEARED WE'LL BE
DOING EVEN MORE TRAINING. AND
NEWSLETTERS WE ALSO I
IMPLEMENTED OVER THE SUMMER. A
DATA MANAGEMENT SYSTEM SO
PEOPLE COULD QUICKLY FIND
ANSWERS AND BE ABLE TO RESPOND
TO OUR AGENTS. WERE ALSO-
MERGING OUR CALL CENTER- AND
PROVIDING SKILL BASED ROUTING-
IN THE NEXT WEEK I THINK-
OCTOBER TWENTY SECOND. OF WHICH
WILL HELP CLAIMANTS GET TO A
PERSON IS TRAINED IN SPECIFIC
AREAS. SO WE TAKE THE CALL
CENTER WERE REALLY WORKING HARD
TO. MAKE SURE IS AN EXCELLENT-
SERVICE FOR OUR CUSTOMERS. GOT
IT AND WHAT IS YOUR RESPONSE
JUST TO THE STRIKE TEAM REPORT
THAT ACTUALLY SAID WHEN THEY
WENT TO SOME OF THESE CALL
CENTERS THAT PEOPLE WEREN'T
PICKING UP THE PHONES. AND NOT
ANSWERING PHONES BECAUSE
OBVIOUSLY IT'S VERY FRUSTRATING
FOR A LOT OF CALIFORNIANS
AROUND THE STATE WHO WERE.
TRYING TO GET ANSWERS AND SO IF
YOU HAVE. A RESPONSE TO WHY
PEOPLE WEREN'T PICKING UP. THE
CALLS AT THESE CALL CENTERS YOU
KNOW INDIVIDUALS ARE HIRED. TO
ANSWER THESE CALLS AND NOBODY'S
ANSWERING THE CALLS AND- AND I
KNOW THAT THERE WAS SOME
DISCREPANCY BECAUSE PEOPLE
STARTED WORKING FROM HOME BUT
THERE SHOULD STILL BE SOME
ACCOUNTABILITY. FOR ACTUALLY
DOING THE JOB. ALL THE PEOPLE
THAT WORK AT THAT ARE IN THE
OFFICE OF. THE WORKING IN THE
CALL CENTER- ALSO DO CLAIM
FILING. SO THEY'RE NOT ON THE
PHONE ALL THE TIME I CAN'T TELL
YOU WHAT THE STRIKE TEAM SAW AT
THE TIME. BUT THE MAJORITY OF
PEOPLE THAT ANSWER PHONES ARE
WORKING FROM HOME THROUGH OUR
VIRTUAL NETWORK. WE HAD WE HAD
IS A MUCH SMALLER AMOUNT A
STATE WIDE IN OFFICES OR
ANSWERING PHONES. AND AGAIN
THOSE PEOPLE WERE ALSO DOING
CLAIMS FILING- SO THEY'RE
THEY'RE NOT ON THE PHONE FULL
TIME. AT ANY POINT SO AT. I
WASN'T THERE SO I CAN'T I CAN'T
SPEAK TO WHAT WHAT THEY- CAN
YOU DO CAN YOU SPEAK TO PERHAPS
THE METRICS USED TO MAKE SURE
THAT THERE'S ACCOUNTABILITY TO
ENSURE THAT PEOPLE ARE DOING
THEIR JOB IN. RESOLVING SOME OF
THE NOT ONLY ANSWERING THE
PHONES FOR RESOLVING SOME OF
THE CLAIMS. WHERE THEY'RE ON
THE CALLS. JUST A LITTLE TRICKS
YOU USE AND THE RESPONSE THAT
THE ACCOUNTABILITY TO MAKE SURE
PEOPLE ARE DOING. THEIR JOB
ALREADY DD. UP YES SO I MEAN I
DON'T HOW THOSE METRICS RIGHT
ON ME BUT- NEEDLESS TO SAY OF
ALL THE FOLKS WORK. UNDER
MANAGERS THAT MONITOR VERY
CLOSELY. AND WORK WITH EACH
PERSON TO DEVELOP THEIR
PERFORMANCE AND MAKE SURE THAT
THEY'RE- AT MEETING OR
EXCEEDING PERFORMANCE AND IF
THEY'RE NOT THEN- ADDITIONAL
TRAININGS PROVIDED. YOU KIND OF
CORRECTIVE ACTION. YOU KNOW
ANYTHING SELL. AND I JUST
WANTED TO HIGHLIGHT THIS
BECAUSE THIS IS ONE OF THE
FRUSTRATIONS I HEAR FROM A
DIFFERENT CALIFORNIANS UP AND
DOWN THE STATE YOU KNOW THEY
WANT TO KNOW LIKE WHO'S BEING
HELD ACCOUNTABLE ARE THINGS
BEING DONE WHEN THEY READ
REPORT WHERE YOU KNOW LIKE I
SAID NINETY EIGHT POINT 6% OF.
PEOPLE ARE NOT GETTING THEIR
ISSUE RESOLVED AT LEAST ON THAT
FIRST PHONE CALLER EVEN
SUBSEQUENT CALLS I BELIEVE THE
CHAIRMAN ASKED EARLIER- WHAT'S
LONGEST BACKLOG BUT STILL
MONTHS. ONCE WAY HERE WE ARE
YOU KNOW ALMOST HALF A YEAR
LATER SIX MONTHS IT'S PEOPLE
ARE OBVIOUSLY STILL FRUSTRATED.
SO IF I COULD GO BACK AND TELL
THEM LOOK THESE ARE THE METRICS
IS OUR MAKING SURE THAT. EDT IS
BEING HELD ACCOUNTABLE IN THE
PEOPLE ARE ANSWERING IN
RESOLVING CASES- YOU KNOW THAT
WILL GO A LONG WAY I THINK- FOR
THE COMMUNITY OR FOR
CALIFORNIANS. YEAH ONE OF THE
BIGGEST IMPROVEMENTS THAT WE'RE
MAKING- THIS WAS- BASED ON-
WORKING WITH OTHER VENDORS THIS
SPRING. WAS WERE IN THE PROCESS
OF INSTITUTING A COMMAND CENTER
OVER OUR CALL CENTER. AND
PUTTING IN- WHOLE SOFTWARE
SYSTEM IN ORDER TO- ACTUALLY
COMPILE METRICS. WE JUST HAVE
WE'RE IN THE PROCESS OF DOING
THAT SO-WE'RE REALLY MOVING
TOWARDS THAT ACCOUNTABILITY.
AROUND THAT SO SOON. OKAY GREAT
I THINK WE HAD WHO WE
APPRECIATE SOME OF THAT MAYBE
IT'S ON THE DASHBOARD SO THAT
ACCOUNTABILITY OF THOSE METRICS
THAT ARE BEING USED- WOULD BE
GREAT I THINK AS FOLLOW UP. BUT
MY SECOND QUESTION WAS REALLY
CENTERED ON YOU GUYS HAVE
TALKED A LOT ABOUT ID ID
MEDIANET. BEING ABLE TO RESOLVE
A LOT OF THE ISSUES THAT YOU'RE
SAYING OVER AT EDT- OBVIOUSLY-
WE'VE BEEN SEEING A LOT OF
MEDIA ACCOUNTS AND EVEN THEIR
OFFICES HEARING OF A LOT OF
CASES- FOR INSTANCE WHERE
SOMEBODY'S BEING MAILED. YOU
KNOW TEN LETTERS OR MULTIPLE
EDT DEBRA CARDS TO ONE ADDRESS
AND TRY TO FIGURE OUT WHY OVER
EDDIE EDT THIS WASN'T FLAGGED
IN THE FIRST PLACE TO SAY LOOK
THERE'S GOT TO BE AN ISSUE
HERE. IF TEN TWENTY THIRTY
FORTY FIFTY. YOU KNOW DEBIT
CARDS ARE BEING MAILED TO ONE
ADDRESS OR OR LETTERS ADDRESSED
TO MULTIPLE PEOPLE BUT STILL
GOING ONLY TO ONE ADDRESS. NOW
IS IT ME GONNA FIX ALL OF THAT.
YES IT DOES ADDRESS THAT
BECAUSE WE KNOW AT THE VERY GET
GO AT THE FRONT END WHO WORK
THERE THAT PERSON WE'RE DEALING
WITH IS THE PERSON. OF ACT THAT
WILL HELP. GOT IT NOW AND NOW.
THE BIG QUESTION WHY THAT
WASN'T DONE BEFORE BUT LET'S
SET THAT ASIDE FOR A SECOND.
WHAT IS BEING DONE TO MAKE SURE.
AS WE MOVE FORWARD YOU'RE
YOU'RE TRYING TO CAPTURE THE
FRONT END BUT ARE YOU DOING
ANYTHING IN THE BACK AND WITH
INVESTIGATORS OR ANYTHING ELSE
TO LOOK AT SOME OF THESE-
FRAUDULENT CLAIMS. OH
ABSOLUTELY SO AND I HAND OUT
THAT I PROVIDED YOU EARLIER
THERE'S A SECTION ON FROGS AND
LYFT THAT'S WHERE INVESTOR
DICTATORS COME IN AND THEY WERE
UTILIZING A VARIETY OF TOOLS
WHETHER IT'S FRONT THROUGH OUR
DEPARTMENT OF LABOR- IF I MEAN
I SCRIPT TRYING TO LIST IT ALL
THERE FOR YOU. BUT WE YEAH YEAH
YOU KNOW WE TAKE IT VERY
SERIOUSLY AND WE HAVE PLENTY
UNFORTUNATELY WE ARE PLENTY OF
LEADS. GO IT WOULD YOU BE ABLE
TELL ME AT THIS TIME BECAUSE
THE LEGISLATURE DID ALLOCATE-
RESOURCES AND MONEY. TO EASY
EARLIER IN ANTICIPATION OF. THE
CASES THAT WE DO BUT- HOW MANY
MORE. INVESTIGATORS ON THE
FRONT SIDE DID YOU HIRE A READY
DD. WE DIDN'T ADD- MORE
INVESTIGATORS. AT THIS POINT
WHERE WE FEEL WE ARE FILLING
BUT OF. OKAY IT WOULD YOU HAVE
ANY IDEA HOW MUCH MONEY
TAXPAYERS OF LOST DUE TO SOME
OF THESE FRAUDULENT CLAIMS. NO
THAT'S NOT SOMETHING THAT WE
TRACK. OKAY IT'S A LITTLE IS
BECAUSE YOU'RE A GOOD MAN
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS HELLO MISS
BETWEEN NORTH. GUESTS WILL COME
BACK TO THAT TOPIC NINETY THAT
YOU FOR THE PROMPT
CONVERSATION- THE BIT TECH- A
TIME. THINK YOU MISTER CHAIR-
SO FIRST JUST WANNA SAY THANK
YOU SECRETARY RICHARD SEND OFF
FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP AND- ALSO
FOR THE AT. THE WORK OF YOUR CO
LEAD MS PODCAST AND DOES YOUR
ENTIRE TEAM AND SHE SAID WHO
HAVE BEEN WORKING TIRELESSLY
AROUND THE CLOCK IN ORDER TO.
ADDRESS THESE CRITICAL ISSUES
AND I BEGIN TO MAKE PROGRESS
AND- START TO DO A BETTER JOB
SERVING THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA WE DO. GREATLY
APPRECIATE THAT I'M JUST I WANT
TO START WITH A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS FOR THE SECRETARY
AROUND ID ME SO. THAT WE HEARD
THE L. A. O. IN IN HIS AT IN
YOUR TO AN ALLEY OWES
TESTIMONY. MISTER ALAMO AND
MENTIONED THAT THEY HAD ID NEED
TECHNOLOGY COULD HAVE PROBABLY
SHOULD HAVE BEEN IMPLEMENTED
YEARS AGO. I SECRETARY
RICHARDSON. DO YOU SHARE THAT
ASSESSMENT. AND IF. HI THIS IS
A- IN THE AGAIN I- WANTED TO
SEE IF IT'S OKAY FOR ME TO-
COVER THE SPECIFIC QUESTIONS ON
BEHALF OF US SECRETARY
RICHARDSON. YES PLEASE THANK
YOU. YES FROM A STRIKE TEAM-
ASPECT THE IDENTITY
VERIFICATION- YES THE MAIN
CAUSE FOR A LOT OF THE
BACKLOGS. AND THE NEED FOR
IMPROVED THAT AT THE VERY FIRST
STEP IS SOMETHING THAT
OBVIOUSLY BASED ON THE STRIKE
TEAM ASSESSMENT THERE'S
EVIDENCE SUPPORTING THAT. I
WOULD SAY DIED- YES WHAT WOULD
YOU KNOW POPE THAT THIS WAS
IMPLEMENTED EARLIER BUT I
THINK- IT'S ALSO FAIR TO SAY
THAT WITH THE A STRIKE TEAM WE
HAVE TRUE EVIDENCE AND DATA
SUPPORTING THAT DECISION SO.
IMPLEMENTING RIGHT NOW IS THE
RIGHT THING TO DO. AND FIVE.
MIKE MY COLLEAGUES AND AS A
MEMBER CHIU RAISING QUESTIONS
ABOUT. WHETHER OR NOT THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF ID ME IS
LIVING UP TO THE EXPECTATIONS
OF THE STRIKE TEAM. I JUST
PROVIDE US A LITTLE MORE
INFORMATION ON THAT FRONT THAT
IS THE IMPLEMENTATION FAR.
MEETING YOUR EXPECTATIONS AND
WHAT PERCENTAGE OF CLAIMS ARE
ACTUALLY BEING RESOLVED
AUTOMATICALLY BECAUSE OF THE
IMPLANTATION OF ID ME. THANK
YOU FOR THE QUESTION- I DO THAT
BUT WHAT'S WANTED TO HAVE A
CHANCE TO CLARIFY- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHOOSE REFERENCE ON THE
PERCENTAGE WELL AS WELL- I LIKE
TO SEPARATE OUT TO PERCENTAGE
THAT AND- BEING USED IN
REFERENCE ONE IS DE ID MEANS.
PERCENTAGE OF NUMBER OF
INDIVIDUAL WHO APPLY FOR
VERIFICATION OF THEIR IDENTITY
AND HAS BEEN ABLE TO PASS THAT
THE DENTAL T. WAS THE
SUCCESSFUL- APPROVAL OF SIXTY
FOUR AND AS OF TO DATE THAT
ALREADY ONE UP TO SEVENTY
PERCENT. THAT PERCENTAGE IS
DIFFERENT THAN THE NUMBER OF
CLAIMANTS OR THE PERCENTAGE
THAT- THE STRIKING REPORT HAS
STRIVE FOR AUTOMATION- AT T.
WHICH YOU HAVE SEEN AS NINETY
ONE OR 94% SO THE KEEP THINKING
OF THIS WAY OF INDIVIDUAL WHO
APPLY FOR ID NY IS SEEKING A
VERY STEP TO GETTING THEMSELVES
DOWN TO FIND THROUGH A
VERIFICATION PROCESS. THEY MAY
OR MAY NOT IMMEDIATELY GO TO
YOU I ONLINE AT EIGHTY TO APPLY
FOR A CLING. SO THAT PERCENTAGE
AS OF- SHARON HAS MISSION. WE
ARE WORKING CLOSELY WITH EDT
AND EDP IS MONITORING THAT ON A
DAILY BASIS TO SEE HOW THAT
PERCENTAGE IS BEING ACHIEVED.
BUT THE NINETY ONE NINETY FOUR
PERCENTAGE IT'S ABOUT THE U. I.
ONLINE NOT THE SAME AS THE ID
NEED VERIFICATION PERCENTAGE
WHICH CURRENTLY IS SIXTY FOUR
TO SEVENTY PERCENT. AND AS IN
JUST FOR THE MOTHER POINT OF
REFERENCE- ID ME IMPLEMENTATION
IT'S AT A NATIONAL LEVEL- AT
THE FEDERAL LEVEL THE FEDERAL
VETERANS AFFAIR. AS WELL AS
SOCIAL SECURITY MINISTRATION
JUST TO NAME A FEWHAVE
IMPLEMENTED IT AND SEVERAL
OTHER STATES. SO ON THIS
NATIONAL AVERAGE THE PASSING
RATE OR SO SAYS IS HOVERING AT
ABOUT EIGHTY PERCENT. AND FOR
THE STATE THAT HAVE YOU KNOW
HIGHER PERCENTAGE OR COMPLEXITY
POTENTIALLY DUE TO FRAUD. THE
AVERAGE THAT WE HAVE SEEN IS
HIRING BETWEEN SEVENTY TO
SEVENTY FIVE PERCENT. SO WITH
THAT. FROM THE EARLY INDICATION
THAT WE HAVE SEEN WE ARE
ACTUALLY QUITE HAPPY WITH THE-
PASSING RATE OF. 70% ACHIEVED
BUT AT ANY. OKAY ALL RIGHT
ANDERSON THANK YOU FOR THAT
THANK YOU FOR THAT. I'M AND
FIVE DIRECTOR HILLIARD COUPLE
OF QUESTIONS FOR YEAR- SO. I'M
NOT TOO TO BE LOOKING BACKWARDS
BUT I THINK I'M JUST TRYING TO
WRAP MY HEAD AROUND. AT THE
ASSESSMENTS IN THE STRIKE TEAM
REPORT AND REALLY WHERE WE GO
FROM HERE SO WHEN WE HAVE HAD
WE'VE HAD TWO PREVIOUS HEARINGS
AND- YOU BLAMES THE DEPARTMENT
BACKLOG AND THAT THE FIVE
ISSUES IN THE NIGHTMARE THAT
WAS UNFOLDING AT U. D. D. ON
TWO THINGS YOU BLAME IT ON THE
LEGACY SYSTEMS. ISSUES AND THEN
YOU BLAMED IT ON A LACK OF
STAFFING AND WERE FIVE MOVING
TO HIGHER AND I THINK ACTUALLY
DID HIRE SOMETHING LIKE FIVE
THOUSAND PEOPLE AS I READ THE
STRIKE TEAM REPORT IT'S
ACTUALLY REALLY A FUNDAMENTAL
REBUKE. OF BOTH OF THOSE
STRATEGIES ARE BOTH OF THOSE
ASSESSMENTS SO. AND IT NUMBER
ONE IS THE STRIKE TEAM REPORT
POINTS OUT THAT THIS BACKLOG IS
DO YOU. NOT TO OUTDATED
TECHNOLOGY BUT TO OPERATIONAL
SHORTCOMINGS SO DO YOU AGREE
WITH THAT ASSESSMENT WELL FIRST
OF ALL IT AT. IT'S MORE OF THE
CHECK I SEE IT MORE OR THE
TECHNOLOGY WHERE THE ID ME WAS
SO INSTRUMENTAL BECAUSE ONCE
THE WAY PROGRAM CAME INTO PLAY
I'M FROM AN OPERATIONAL
STANDPOINT IT WAS A VERY SLOW
PROCESS SAYING THAT WE DIDN'T
HAVE THE CORRECT TOOLS TO HELP
WITH OPERATIONS. AND THEN ONCE
WE DID WE IMPLEMENTED RECENTLY-
THAT'S JUST PUTTING US IN A
MUCH BETTER POSITION. OKAY AND
I IN TERMS AS THE HIRING OF HE
HAS THOUSANDS OF NEW STAFF
MEMBERS THE STRIKE TEAM REPORT
POINTS OUT THAT THAT WAS NOT
ONLY JUST A TOTAL WASTE OF
TAXPAYER DOLLARS BUT THAT IS
ACTUALLY COUNTERPRODUCTIVE AND
FIVE. ULTIMATELY MADE THINGS
EVEN WORSE SO AND THEY ADVISE
YOU TO STOP HIRING THOSE PEOPLE
I GUESS TWO QUESTIONS. DO YOU
AGREE WITH THAT ASSESSMENT AND
NUMBER TWO WHAT IS THE PLAN NOW
WITH THOSE FIVE FIVE THOUSAND
NEW PDT STAFF MEMBERS. SO IT
WASN'T A MATTER THAT WE DIDN'T
NEED EVERYBODY IT WAS A MATTER
OF HOW WE WERE- ALLOCATING OUR
STAFF- AND WHILE WE'RE TRYING
TO TACKLE THE BACKLOG. SO WE DO
NEED ALL THESE PEOPLE AND- OUT
WE JUST MOVE THEM TO DIFFERENT%
AREAS OF RESPONSIBILITY UNTIL
SUCH TIME TO GET TO THE BACKLOG
AND WE CAN CONTINUE TO THE
TRAIN THEM. NOW WE HAVE ABOUT
EIGHTEEN HUNDRED PEOPLE STILL
WITH US FROM OTHER DEPARTMENTS
AND OTHER BRANCHES WITHIN OUR
DEPARTMENT THAT WILL BE
RETURNING OVER THE NEXT SEVERAL
MONTHS SO ALL THE PEOPLE THAT
WE HAVE HIRED THAT- ARE ALREADY
HELPING TO MITIGATE AND BRING
DOWN THE BACKLOG. THAT'S NOT
SOME OF THE LESS COMPLEX STUFF
BUT NO THERE NEVER THE LESS
IT'S ALL GOES TO THE BACKLOG I
WILL CONTINUE TO BE ABLE TO
PICK UP THEIR TRAINING AGAIN
FOLLOWING THE BACKLOG BEING
BURNED DOWN. SO AGAIN THAT. IT
IS EVERY SINGLE PERSON IS
NEEDED- IT'S JUST A MATTER OF
HOW WE WERE UTILIZING- AND
ALLOCATING OUT THE WORK. I
THINK I AM I WOULD I WOULD SAY
AND WE CAN UNFORTUNATELY IT
SOUNDS IT LOOKS LIKE SECRETARY
RICHARDSON'S NOT HERE SO
PERHAPS WE CAN GET ONE OF THAT
DISTRICT TEAM FOLKS TO CLARFY
THE ASSESSMENT BECAUSE- THE WAY
THAT I READ THE ASSESSMENT. IS
THAT IMPLEMENTATION OF A
RELATIVELY STRAIGHTFORWARD
COMMERCIALLY AVAILABLE
TECHNOLOGY FIX FOR IDENTITY
VERIFICATION THAT WOULD HAVE.
IT YOU HAVE KEPT 40% OF CLAIMS
FROM GOING TO MANUAL PROCESSING
WOULD HAVE OBVIATED THE NEED.
TO HIRE. THOUSANDS OF
ADDITIONAL STAFF MEMBERS THAT
THAT WAS HOW I READ DISTRICT
TEAM ASSESSMENT WHICH SOMETHING
WAS DIFFERENT THAN. YOURSELF AB.
AND SO I GUESS JUST MIGHT MY
FINAL QUESTION IS THAT THE
STRIKE TEAM AB REPORT NEEDS THE
TAG IN ADDITION TO SOME OF
THESE TACTICAL ISSUES. IN ORDER
TO MOVE EDT FORWARD THERE NEEDS
TO BE A SHIFT IN CULTURE AND A
TRANSFORMATIONAL CHANGE DO YOU
BELIEVE THAT YOU ARE THE RIGHT
LEADER TWO OCCASIONS THAT SHIFT
IN CULTURE AND TRANSFORMATIONAL
CHANGE TO GET THIS DEPARTMENT
ON TRACK. YOU KNOW I ABSOLUTELY
DO BELIEVE I'M THE RIGHT LEADER
AND I HAVE TO SAY WITH THE NEW
APPOINTMENTS OF ART TO NEW
CHIEF A DEPUTY DIRECTORS AND
OUR- LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR AS
WELL AS OUR NEW GENERAL
COUNSEL. HAS ALREADY BROUGHT ON
SOME GREAT IDEAS TO THE
FOREFRONT ANDWE'RE STARTING TO
RE LOOK AT THINGS THINGS AND
WAY THAT WE HAVEN'T BEFORE. I
HAVE TOTALLY EMBRACED IT I- I
APPRECIATE THEIR INPUT AND
THEIR GUIDANCE AND WE- ARE
FOLLOWING THE GUIDANCE AND AS A
COLLECTIVE YOU KNOW. MAKING
DECISIONS AS A COLLECTIVE BODY.
I THINK WE'RE ON A GOOD PATH.
THANK YOU AND THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR. OKAY JUST ONE QUESTION
FOR MR BEFORE YOU OUR SECOND
PANEL. REGARDING YOUR TWENTY
SEVEN INVESTIGATORS. HOW MUCH
FRAUD HAVE IDENTIFIED SO FAR I
DON'T KNOW THE NUMBER OF FRAUD
WE RIGHT NOW HAVE SEVENTY FIVE
ACTIVE INVESTIGATIONS GOING ON-
AND- LIKE I SAID WE HAVE TWENTY
SEVEN WE DIDN'T ADD A LOT OF
RESOURCES BUT WAIT THEY ARE
CONTINUING TO HIRE.
UNFORTUNATELY HIRING PEACE
OFFICERS IS A VERY LONG PROCESS
OF BUT THEY ARE ARE IN THE
HIRING MODE. OKAY WE'RE GONNA
GO AHEAD AND SWITCH TO OUR NEXT
PANEL IN HOPE OF SORRY MISTER
NAZARIAN. OKAY ONE OKAY. SO
WE'RE GOING TO SWITCH TO OUR
OUR SECOND PANEL IN OUR SECOND
PANEL. WE HAVE LISTER FRIEDMAN
THE MAYOR OF CITY OF BEVERLY
HILLS AND ALSO MARK- PUT WHO
THE SYSTEM CHIEF OF POLICE FOR
THE CITY OF BEVERLY HILLS AND A
FORMER MEMBER OF THE SECOND A
POLICE DEPARTMENT. AND THERE
ARE FEW OTHER REMOTE LOCATION
INVENT NICE. MISTER MAYOR CAN
YOU HEAR ME. YOU HEAR ME YES.
OKAY GO AHEAD AFTER MAYOR OKAY
WE JUST STARTED THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
MAYOR LESTER FRIEDMAN FROM THE
CITY OF BEVERLY HILLS. THANK
YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO
REPRESENT BEVERLY HILLS HERE
TODAY FOR THIS IMPORTANT
DISCUSSION. THE COVERT NINETEEN
PANDEMIC HAS DRAMATICALLY
AFFECTED BUSINESS DISTRICTS
ACROSS CALIFORNIA. AND BEVERLY
HILLS IS NO DIFFERENT. WE'VE
SEEN MANY STOREFRONTS CLOSED
PERMANENTLY WHILE OTHERS HAVE
DRAMATICALLY TRANSFORMED TO
MEET NEW HEALTH AND SAFETY
STANDARDS. AMID THESE CHANGES
WE ALSO SAW AN INCREASE IN
TRAFFIC AND PARKING VIOLATIONS
THE OPEN USE OF MARIJUANA IN
PUBLIC. AND THE APPEARANCE OF
ILLEGAL STREET VENDORS AND
GAMBLING ON OUR ICONIC RODEO
DRIVE. AS OUR POLICE DEPARTMENT
INQUIRED FURTHER OUR MERCHANTS
ADVISED THAT THEY HAD SEEN A
SIGNIFICANT INCREASE IN CASH
PURCHASES. AS WELL AS THE
FREQUENT USE OF EDT CARDS. THIS
BEGAN THE COMPREHENSIVE
STRATEGY BY OUR POLICE
DEPARTMENT TO PROBLEM SOLVE AND
ADDRESS THE CRIMES THAT WERE
OCCURRING ON RODEO DRIVE AND
THROUGHOUT OUR BUSINESS
DISTRICT. WITH THE CHAIRS
PERMISSION I'D LIKE TO TURN TO
OUR ASSISTANT CHIEF OF POLICE
MARK COOPER WOULD. TO DISCUSS
THE PROACTIVE STEPS WE TOOK TO
MITIGATE THESE CRIMES AND THE
UNFORTUNATE MISUSE OF CRITICAL
UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS IN
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU.
GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRPERSON COOPER
CAN YOU HEAR ME OK IT'S LIKE
YEAH. YEAH OKAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR ALLOWING THE MAYOR AND
I THIS OPPORTUNITY. TO OUR
COMMUNITY AND BEVERLY HILLS AS
NEVER EXPERIENCE THE ISSUES
THAT WE HAVE SEEN IN THE LAST
SIXTY DAYS TO THIS LEVEL AND WE
REALLY RECEIVED DAILY
COMPLAINTS FROM ALL FACETS OF
OUR COMMUNITY. AS A RESULT WE
TOOK A GROUP OF OFFICERS LED BY
A SERGEANT AND REALLY ASK THEM
TO GO DOWN TO OUR BUSINESS
DISTRICT. AND TO USE THE FAMOUS
SERRA MODEL OF PROBLEM SOLVING
THROUGH COMMUNITY OR ANY
POLICING. WHAT IS THE SERRA
MODEL WE SCANNED THE PROBLEM WE
ANALYZED WHAT WAS PROBABLY.
CREATING THE PROBLEM. WE
RESPONDED TO THE PROBLEM AND
NOW WE'RE IN THE ASSESSMENT
PHASE WHERE WE'RE LOOKING AT.
WHAT WE CAN DO AND WHAT HE CAN
DO TO HELP RESOLVE FURTHER
ISSUES AND REALLY TO MITIGATE.
FUTURE OF CURRENTS IS OF IN MY
TWENTY SIX YEARS THE MOST. YOU
KNOW THE MOST FRAUD I'VE EVER
SEEN- WITHIN A SIXTY DAY PERIOD
IN MY IN MY TWENTY SIX YEARS
AND THAT INCLUDES MY TIME WITH
THE CITY OF SACRAMENTO. WHAT WE
WERE SEEING WAS THERE WAS A
THERE WAS A NEED TO MEET WITH
OUR BUSINESS COMMUNITY AS WELL
BECAUSE WE REALLY HAD TO
EDUCATE THEM ON WHAT THE FRAUD
WAS THEY WERE SEEING-
INDIVIDUALS COMING UP WITH- AS
MANY AS FOUR TO FIVE FRAUDULENT
EDT CARDS AT ONE TIME. AND THEY
WERE COMING IN WITH LARGE
AMOUNTS OF CASH UP TO THIRTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS AT ONE TIME
THROUGH THIS ERA MODEL AND
DIFFERENT INVESTIGATIVE
TECHNIQUES THAT WE DEPLOYED. IN
THE LAST SIXTY DAYS WE'VE
ARREST OVER A HUNDRED PEOPLE
FREE DD FRAUD MOST ALARMING IS
WE RECOVERED THIRTEEN FIREARMS
AND WHY IS THAT ALARMING ALONG
RODEO DRIVE THEY HAD NOT
RECOVERED A FIREARM IN EIGHTEEN
YEARS AND IN THIRTY DAYS WE
RECOVERED THIRTEEN FIREARMS. WE
WERE COVERED OVER TWO HUNDRED
FRAUDULENT EDT CARDS WITH AN
ESTIMATED STREET VALUE OF OVER
FOUR MILLION DOLLARS WE
RECOVERED OVER FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN US CURRENCY.
WE WERE COVERED OVER FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS OF US POSTAL
MONEY ORDERS. AND THE MOST
ALARMING THING WAS WE WERE
SEEING MOST OF THE PEOPLE
ARRESTED WERE COMING FROM OUT
OF STATE WITH NEW YORK LEADING
THE WAY. GEORGIA NUMBER TWO AND
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA HAD
SIXTEEN PEOPLE- THAT USED OF
THAT AS THE RESIDENCY WE
IMMEDIATELY SET UP A HOTLINE.
TO TRY TO GET MORE INFORMATION
FROM OUR COMMUNITY AND ONCE WE
RELEASED ALL THIS INFORMATION
INTO THE MEDIA WE HAD TO CREATE
A HOLIDAY BECAUSE WE WERE
RECEIVING CALLS FROM EVERYONE
THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND
THROUGHOUT THE NATION. WE
CONTACTED OUR LOCAL OUR STATE
AND OUR FEDERAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
PARTNERS TO INCLUDE EDT. AND WE
ASKED THEM TO HELP US WITH THE
ADJUDICATION AND THE FOLLOW UP
PIECES OF THESE CASES. AS YOU
ALL ARE WELL AWARE OF IDENTITY
THEFT AND FRAUD RELATED CASES
ARE AND- ARE ARE VERY LABOR
INTENSIVE AND THEY TAKE A LOT
OF TIME FROM A DEPARTMENT OUR
SIZE. I'M HAPPY TO SAY THAT WE
HAVE PARTNERED FEDERALLY WITH
THE INTERNAL REVENUE SERVICE.
THE DEPARTMENT OF LABOR TO
ADOPT A MAJORITY OF OUR CASES.
WE ARE GOING TO- HAVE THE REST
OF- LOOKED AT THROUGH THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY DA'S OFFICE. AND
WE HAVE AN AGREEMENT WITH. THE
STATE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE
AS WELL. WELL THIS ALL SEEMS
POSITIVE I CAN TELL EVERYBODY
WE WILL NOT ARREST OUR WAY OUT
OF THIS PROBLEM. WE NEED TO SEE
SYSTEMATIC CHANGES THAT ET D.
THAT WE HAVE ALL GOT TOGETHER
AND ARE GOING TO OFFER. SOME OF
THE SOLUTIONS THAT WE THINK
WILL HELP ET DE. MORE
IMPORTANTLY WE'RE MORE THAN
HAPPY TO PARTNER WITH EDT AND
HELP THEM WITH SOME OF THE
THINGS THE BRIGHTEST MINDS IN
OUR INDUSTRY AT THE FEDERAL THE
LOCAL ON THE STATE LEVEL HAVE
OFFERED. WHAT ARE THOSE
SOLUTIONS. I D. DOT ME
VERIFICATION TOOLS A STRONG
START WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO
IDENTIFY THE PEOPLE THAT ARE
MAKING THESE CLAIMS EITHER
THROUGH A GOVERNMENT ID LIKE A
PASSPORT OR DRIVER'S LICENSE.
THIS IS A BIG ONE THE NEXT ONE
ALLOW ONLY ONE CLAIM PER
APPLICATION PER IP ADDRESS. WE
NOTICED ADDITIONALLY OUR FOLLOW
UP WE'VE SEEN AS MANY AS A
HUNDRED CARDS ISSUE. UNDER THE
SAME I. P. IF ONE IP ADDRESSES
ONLY ALLOWED PER ONE CLAIM THAT
WOULD HELP A LOT. ALLOW ONLY
ONE CARD TO BE SET TO ONE
ADDRESS OR ONE PO BOX WE WERE
COVERED AS MANY AS ONE HUNDRED
CARDS IN THE CITY OF BEVERLY
HILLS. ALL IN DIFFERENT NAMES
TO ONE ADDRESS. DISCONTINUE THE
BACK PAY WE WERE SEEING SOME OF
THESE CARDS BACK LOADED WITH
ALMOST TWENTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
ON. HAVE EIGHTY D. DEPOSIT THE
MONEY INTO A LEGITIMATE BANK
ACCOUNT. DISCONTINUE ALLOWING
CASH WITHDRAWALS FROM THE ATMS
WE WERE SEEING PEOPLE
WITHDRAWING AS MANY AS A FELT
AS MUCH AS A THOUSAND DOLLARS
PER CARD RIGHT IN FRONT OF US
ON VIDEO AND LITERALLY THROWING
THE ENVELOPES AWAY IN THE
NEARBY TRASH BAND AND GRABBING
THE NEW CARD OUT OF A NEW
ENVELOPE AND WITHDRAWING
ANOTHER THOUSAND DOLLARS FROM
THE BANK OF AMERICA ATM.
DISCONTINUE ALLOWING US POSTAL
MONEY ORDERS TO BE PURCHASED
WITH THESE CARDS. AND THEN
LASTLY LET'S FIND A WAY
TOGETHER TO REGULATE WHAT AID
CAN AND CANNOT BE USED FOR WITH
THESE CARDS I THINK WE ALL
AGREE THE CARDS WERE NOT MEANT
TO SHOP ALONG RODEO DRIVE. IN
CLOSING WE APPRECIATE WE
RESPECT AND WE KNOW THAT EIGHTY
D. PROVIDES A LEGITIMATE
RESOURCE TO PEOPLE WHO TRULY
NEED THE HELP. THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IS A VICTIM. HOWEVER
THE IDENTITY THEFT VICTIMS ARE
ALSO GOING TO BE DEALING WITH
THE AFTERMATH OF THIS FOR MANY
MANY YEARS TO COME.
SPECIFICALLY NEXT YEAR THEY'RE
GOING TO RECEIVE A TEN NINETY
NINE. WITH INCOME THAT THEY'RE
GONNA BE EXPECTED TO CLAIM.
THAT IS NOT THEIR INCOME THEY
DID NOT EARN THAT. BUT THEY'RE
GONNA HAVE TO WORK WITH THE IRS
FOR YEARS TO GET THEIR NAMES
CLEAR. AND AGAIN I WANT TO
REEMPHASIZE THE CITY OF BEVERLY
HILLS WANTS TO BE PART OF THE
SOLUTION. PLEASE INCLUDE US
WE'D BE MORE THAN HAPPY TO WORK
WITH THE DIRECTOR OF EDT- IN
OFFER ANYTHING ELSE THAT WE CAN
PROVIDE. AS FAR AS A LONG TERM
SOLUTION. THANK YOU. OKAY THANK
YOU. JUST REAL QUICK AND THIS
IS A GOOD FOR THE BIG ISSUE
WITH THIS AND OBVIOUSLY OF THIS
BEVERLY HILLS AND WE'RE SEEING
THIS THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA- SO
I BELIEVE THE SYSTEM SHEILA
THINKING FOR TESTIFYING ALSO
THE MAYOR. BUT WHAT WAS ALSO
WE'RE SEEING WITH THIS. ON A
BANK CARD BECAUSE I'M I'M A FAR
OKAY. I CAN WITHDRAW SILVA HER
DOLLARS. MOST BANKS HAVE LIMITS
ARE NO LIMITS THESE CARS. BUT
YOU KNOW BACK TO THE I. P. AT
ADDRESS AND ADDRESS OBVIOUSLY
YOU'RE A WORKING FAMILY MAY
HAVE TO. BUT I'M NOT SURE MY
COLLEAGUES ARE OF THIS. IF YOU
HAVEN'T OF. DELIVERY ON YOUR AD
SO IF YOU. REQUESTED THROUGH
THE STATES POSTAL. THEY WILL
SEND YOU. A PICTURE. OF YOUR AS
WILL BE ARRIVE THAT DAY OR THE
NEXT DAY. SO WHAT'S GOING ON
FOR OF USEFUL. IF I'M MISTER TO
I'M BACK I'M USING ADDRESS. I
WILL PLAYING IT AND HAVE A POST
OFFICE IN ME A PICTURE OF YOUR
IS COMING DAY SOME SURE TO LET
YOUR- INTERCEPT MAIL. THE NEW
INTO THAT RIGHT NOW SO FULL ARE
DOING THIS BEING SENT TO HOUSES
WHERE NO ONE LIVES THERE. YOU
KNOW THINGS LIKE THE SO THAT'S
WHISKEY. IS INFORMED. THROUGH
THE US MAIL SYSTEM YOU NEED
WITH WATER YOU MAY. THAT'S
GOING TO BE A. YOU SEE THE
FOLKS ARE DOING THIS AND ALSO-
SINCE BANKAMERICA SINCE THE
DEMOCRATS ARE TO. TAKE A LOOK
AT HOW MANY MONEY ORDERS ARE
BEING GENERATED STATEWIDE AND
THERE'S. ONE PLACE TO GO TO I'M
NOT GONNA SAY THEY GET MOST THE
MONEY ORDERS ARE AND WHERE IT
WAS IN JUST I GUESS WE NEED TO
TRACK RAISE MONEY- GOING
BECAUSE THERE IS A TRAIL AND I
KNOW HE DOESN'T REALLY HAVE A
NUMBER OF. A FRAUD BUT- EIGHT
IT CAN CERTAINLY IN THE
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS DID NOT. A
BILLION DOLLARS A LOT OF MONEY
OUT THERE AND I KNOW THE- THE
ISSUE WAS INITIALLY PAY THE
LEGITIMATE CLAIMANTS FIRST AND
GET THAT OUT THERE AND WE DID A
BETTER JOB THAT THAT THEY'RE
GETTING BETTER BUT- AT SOME
POINT WE TO TURN TO THE FRAUD
ISSUE. AND WITH TWENTY SEVEN
INVESTIGATOR STATEWIDE. THEY
CAN'T DO IT THEY'RE NOT DOING
IT THEY WILL NEVER DO IT. GOD
BLESS THEM BUT- IF FALLS ON
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT THE
SHOULDERS. OF THOSE FORCED TO
DO IT WE'RE GOING TO DO MORE
WITH THAT SO. MISTER LUCKY. YES
THANK YOU WHAT I WOULD LIKE TO
DO IS JUST NOT THE SIZE HOW BIG
THIS PROBLEM IS AND MY DISTRICT
ALONE WE'VE RECEIVED. NEARLY
SIX HUNDRED FIFTY ENVELOPES
THAT WE SUSPECTED FRAUDULENT
BECAUSE THE NAMES OF THESE
ENVELOPES THAT ARE ON THESE
ENVELOPES NEVER LIVED AT THE
ADDRESSES THEY WERE SENT TO.
THESE ARE ALSO SINGLE FAMILY
RESIDENCES NOT MULTI UNIT
COMPLEXES SO THERE'S NO REASON
FOR CONFUSION. MANY OF THE
ENVELOPES HAVE AS WE'VE BEEN
DISCUSSING THESE DEBIT CARDS
FROM BANK OF AMERICA. WHICH ARE
LOADED WITH THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS. BECAUSE WE'VE BEEN
TALKING. VERBALLY I WANT TO
CREATE A VISUAL THERE IS ARE
THE LETTERS RIGHT HERE. THAT WE
RECEIVED IN ABOUT ONE MONTH.
THIS IS MY DISTRICT ALONE WE
HEARD THE EVIDENCE. SENATE AND.
IT'S PRESENTED BY THE POLICE
OFFICER- JUST PREVIOUSLY. IN
BEVERLY HILLS I IT I SUBMIT TO
YOU THAT STATEWIDE THIS IS A
GARGANTUAN PROBLEM. I WOULD I
WOULD LIKE TO SUGGEST. THAT THE
GOVERNOR RECOGNIZE THIS PROBLEM
FOR WHAT IT IS BECAUSE THESE
ARE STATE RESOURCES THAT ARE
GOING TO BE BADLY BADLY NEEDED
AS WE'RE- GONNA BE FACING
DEFICITS IN OUR BUDGET HERE IN
THE NEAR FUTURE. WE NEED TO.
INVESTIGATE AND HAVE THEM
MITIGATION PROCESSES IN PLACE
RIGHT AWAY BECAUSE THIS PROBLEM
IS GOING TO CONTINUE TO GROW
AND I WOULD HOPE THAT WE COULD
SET UP WITH A TASK FORCE THAT
COULD HELP UNITE LOCAL
RESOURCES AS WELL AS BECAUSE OF
STATE RESOURCES ARE WOEFULLY.
UNABLE TO HANDLE THIS- PROBLEM
AND SO I WOULD HOPE THAT WE
WOULD GIVE IT THE ATTENTION IT
DESERVES BECAUSE THESE.
CIRCUMSTANCES ARE. GOING
WITHOUT ANY KIND OF
INVESTIGATION IN MOST CASES. WE
NEED TO DO BETTER THAN THIS OUR
RESOURCES ARE. NEED TO BE
RESPECTED AND THAT'S ALL I HAVE
MISTER CELIS. THANK YOU
APPRECIATE THE BEST COVERAGE
SAID IN A SPECIFIC QUESTION AND
I BELIEVE IT'S THE SYSTEM G.
FOR THE CHIEF AND MAYBE THE
MAYOR BUT WHEN YOU INVESTIGATED
THESE CASES IN YOUR OWN
JURISDICTION. OBVIOUSLY YOU
DON'T HAVE A I DON'T BELIEVE
YOU HAVE ID DOT ME I LIKE YOU
D. D. IS NOW IMPLEMENTING LIKE
HOW DID YOU. FIND THESE CASES
WERE ABLE TO DO THIS BECAUSE I
WANT TO SEE WHAT YOU GUYS HAVE
DONE AND FIGURE OUT WHY ET DE
HASN'T DONE THE SAME THING.
YEAH SO WE- IT WAS REALLY A
CASE BY CASE BASIS WE- THE
SHORT ANSWER IS WHEN WE MADE.
THE WHATEVER INVESTIGATIVE STOP
WE DID. WE NOTICED THAT THE
CARD HOLDER I DID NOT MATCH THE
PERSON THAT WAS DETAINED. AND
THEN WHAT WE DID IS WE ALSO
TOOK THE RECEIPTS FROM WHATEVER
RETAIL ESTABLISHMENT- THAT.
THAT THE MERCHANDISE WAS
PURCHASED FROM AND WE'RE ABLE
TO MATCH THE FRAUDULENT DEBIT
CARD TO THE REALLY THE STOLEN
MERCHANDISE OF THE MERCHANDISE
THAT WAS PURCHASED WITH THE
FRAUD SO DOES THE SHORT ANSWER
IS WE WERE ABLE TO- IDENTIFY
THE PERSON WHO WE HAD DETAINED.
AND WE SAW THAT THAT WAS NOT-
THE PERSON ON THE CARD AND THEN
YOU REALLY- ASKED A QUESTION
THAT SEGWAYS INTO THE FOLLOW UP
BESIDES THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
WHO THE CARD IS REALLY- IN THE
NAME OF. IS VERY CHALLENGING
AND VERY LABOR INTENSIVE. GOT
IT. SO WHEN YOU FIRST IDENTIFY
THE INDIVIDUAL HOW DID THAT
HAPPEN WAS THAT BECAUSE OF
SOMETHING IDENTIFIED FOR ME
DEAR DID WAS THEY ARRESTED ON
ANOTHER CHARGE. HOW DID YOU
INITIALLY IDENTIFIED THE
INDIVIDUAL AND WHICH LED TO
OBVIOUSLY THE BIGGER
DISCOVERIES. A LOT OF TIMES IT
CAME FROM A CALL FOR SERVICE
FROM OUR BUSINESS COMMUNITY-
SUBJECTS WOULD BE TRYING TO
PASS A FOUR TO FIVE EDT CARDS
AT ONCE AND THAT WAS A- A RED
FLAG FOR THE BUSINESSES WE
REALLY EDUCATED OUR BUSINESS
COMMUNITY FROM THE START. ON
WHAT TO LOOK FOR WE DID A LOT
OF PUBLIC SERVICE ANNOUNCEMENTS
A LOT OF COMMUNICATIONS ON WHAT
THE CARDS LOOK LIKE AND THAT
THEY'RE ONLY SUPPOSED TO HAVE%
ONE AND TO ASK FOR. A
LEGITIMATE FORM OF ID TO VERIFY
THE CARD HOLDER SO WE RESPOND
TO A CALL FOR SERVICE IS ONE-
IS ONE SCENARIO THAT WE HAD A
LOT OF AND THEN THE OTHER ONES
WOULD BE JUST GOOD OLD
FASHIONED POLICE WORK WE'D MAKE
A TRAFFIC STOP WHICH LED TO A
LEGAL SEARCH OF THE VEHICLE.
AND WE WOULD FIND THE EDT CARDS
AND THE FIREARMS AND THE LARGE-AMOUNTS OF CASH CONCEALED
WITHIN THE VEHICLE THOSE ARE
REALLY PROBABLY THE TWO MOST.
PROMINENT AND REOCCURRING-
CASES WE HAD WITH THOSE TWO
EXAMPLES. THANK YOU I
APPRECIATE THAT A MISTER
CHAIRMAN PERHAPS WHEN IT'S
APPROPRIATE WE CAN ASK YOU D.
D. AS A FOLLOW UP YOU KNOW WE
WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
HAD. FLAGS WHEN MULTIPLE THINGS
WERE SENT TO AN ADDRESS LIKE MR
LACKEY AS A WHOLE. KERRYON OF
MAIL ALL. TO ONE INDIVIDUAL I
JUST WHAT ARE WE DOING THAT
ALSO FOR AS THE ASSISTANT CHIEF
TALKED ABOUT. WE'RE TRYING TO
USE FOUR FIVE DEBIT CARDS AT
ONE SINGLE TIME AT ONE BUSINESS
I THINK THEY SHOULD RAISE A RED
FLAG SOMEWHERE WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT TO. IDENTIFY THAT
ARE HAVE THE FRAUD
INVESTIGATORS LOOK INTO THAT.
AND SO WHEN IT'S APPROPRIATE
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN. ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS TO
THE COMMITTEE. YEAH OKAY SO NOT
NOTHING RIGHT NOW NOTHING RIGHT
NOW FRONT. OKAY LAGOS MISTER
NAZARIAN. OKAY THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR. I HAD SOME QUESTIONS FOR
THE FIRST PANEL AND BEFORE I
START LIKE TO ECHO THE
SENTIMENTS OF THE SOME OF MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE ALREADY
THANKED- SECRETARY RICHARD
SENATE MISS PARKER FOR THEIR
WORK. I VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
THE SPEED AND THE- LEVEL OF
DETAIL AND DEPTH THAT WAS PUT
INTO THE STUDY. SO FIRST AND
FOREMOST. I HAVE A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS OUT START WITH THE
PROCESSING OF CLAIMS BEING SO
SPECIALIZED AND COMPLEX THAT IT
REQUIRES A- EIGHT HUNDRED PAGE
TRAINING MANUAL. AND THREE
YEARS OF EXPERIENCE SCHOOLING
AND FORMAL TESTING. TO REQUEST
FROM AN ENTRY LEVEL ACCOUNTING
TECH TO AN ACCOUNT ONE AND
ADDITIONAL THREE YEARS TO
PROGRESS TO THE SUBSEQUENT
TEARS AND THIS IS ALL PART OF
THE STRIKE. TEAM REPORT. SO
FIRST. WHERE ARE WE WITH NEW
EMPLOYEE HIRINGS AT THIS POINT.
MISS TAYLOR YES WE'VE HIRED
ABOUT FORTY TWO HUNDRED PEOPLE-
TO DATE- WE STILL HAVE
ADDITIONAL PEOPLE COMING IN AT
THE TIME THE STRIKE TEAM MADE
THEIR THEIR RECOMMENDATIONS WE
ALREADY HAD A JOB COMMITMENTS
MADE TO PEOPLE SO WE WANT TO
HONOR OUR JOB COMMITMENTS. OF
BUT AS OF THIS MOMENT WE'VE
BROUGHT IN FORTY TWO HUNDRED
PEOPLE HOW MANY MORE WE GET A
HIGHER. ABOUT A THOUSAND. ABOUT
A THOUSAND MORE. AND REMEMBER
WE DO HAVE TWO THOUSAND PEOPLE
THAT ARE GOING TO BE GOING BACK
TO THEIR ORIGINAL PRO AND TO
OTHER DEPARTMENTS IN THE NEXT
COUPLE MONTHS. SO GIVE ME OF
THE TOTAL OF FIFTY TWO HUNDRED
TWO THOUSAND ARE GOING TO GO
BACK SO WE'RE GOING TO BE LEFT
WITH. THIRTY TWO HUNDRED. SO WE
HAVE RIGHT NOW TODAY WE HAVE
FIFTY SIX HUNDRED. WE HAVE
EIGHTEEN- EIGHT LOW OVER
EIGHTEEN HUNDRED THAT ARE FROM
OTHER BRANCHES EIGHTY THE OTHER
DEPARTMENTS. THAT ARE SCHEDULED
TO GO BACK IN THE NEXT THREE OR
FOUR MONTHS. AND THEN WE ALSO
HAVE THE LOIT- UNTIL THE END OF
DECEMBER. SO WE'RE AT SEVENTY
NINE SEVENTY ONE- RIGHT NOW AND
THEN WE'LL WE'RE STILL BRINGING
ON BOARD PEOPLE AND SO WE HAVE
ABOUT ANOTHER THOUSAND TO GO.
SO THAT BRINGS US TO ALMOST
NINE THOUSAND. OKAY SO. YOU'RE
GONNA BE AT A THOUSAND BUT OF
THAT THOUSAND EIGHTEEN HUNDRED
ARE GOING TO GO BACK TO THEIR
BRANCHES AND I SUSPECT. ANOTHER
THREE OR FOUR HUNDRED OR SO ARE
WITH DELOITTE IS THAT ACCURATE.
WELL HOW ABOUT NINE THOUSAND
AND TWO THOUSAND WILL BE GOING
BACK TO THEIR BRANCHES AND FIVE
HUNDRED FROM BELOIT SO FIVE
HUNDRED FROM THE WAY. OKAY.
WHEN WAS THE LAST TIME THAT THE
EIGHT HUNDRED PAGE TRAINING
MANUAL IS UPDATED. WE HAVE A
TRAINING UNIT THAT CONSTANTLY
IS UPDATING OUR MANUALS AND IN
FACT I THINK AS YOU. MAY
REMEMBER OVER THE SUMMER WE
CONTRACTED WITH THE COMPANY
NAME ADVENTIST AND WOMEN MOVING
ALL OF OUR TRAINING MATERIALS
INTO. TRAINING MANAGEMENT
SYSTEM THAT HAS REALLY HELPED
PEOPLE BE ABLE TO BRING UP THE
INFORMATION THEY NEED AT AND I
LOOKED AT HER FINGERTIPS. SO
WE'RE TOTALLY TRANCE YOU KNOW
TOTALLY AT. COOK UPDATING AND
MODERNIZING OUR TRAINING
MATERIALS SO THAT THE REALLY
REAL TIME AND- YOU KNOW ALLOWS
PEOPLE TO RESPOND QUICKLY SOME.
WE'LL BE GLAD TO PROVIDE YOU
THE SLIDE DECK ON IT AT A LATER
DATE IF YOU'D LIKE TO SEE ALL
THE SPECIFICS OF WHAT THAT
ENTAILS. I I'D BE VERY CURIOUS
TO AND I BY THE WAY DON'T.
APOLOGIES BUT I DON'T REALLY
RECALL THE CONVERSATION FROM
SUMMER HAVING TO DO WITH THE
SPECIFIC ASPECT SO- I'M HAPPY
TO REVIEW MY NOTES AGAIN BUT I
DIDN'T SEE ANYTHING. BUT. I'D
AND I'D BE VERY INTERESTED TO
SEE WHAT'S BEING DONE BECAUSE I
I'M I'M JUST WONDERING. IF THE
NEW HIRES ARE EXPECTED TO.
ANSWER QUESTIONS HOW WOULD THEY
EVEN REPAIRED. TO PROCEED WITH
OFFERING THEIR SUPPORT AND HELP
WHEN THERE IS SUCH AN
EXHAUSTIVE TRAINING MANUAL
REQUIRED FOR THEM TO BE ABLE TO
DIGEST. WHAT TRAINING IS
ENTERED IF YOU DON'T DIGEST
NINE HUNDRED PAGES AND- AND YOU
WAIT TILL THE END TO PUT START
PERFORMING WORK WITH. PEOPLE OF
DIFFERENT- SKILLS DIFFERENT
WORKLOADS- UP AND GIVE THEM
TIME TO BECOME PROFICIENT THEY
GO INTO TRAINING AND THEY ALSO
HAVE MENTORS- AND THAT'S WHERE
WE WERE HAVING A LITTLESTRUGGLE BECAUSE THE MENTORS
WERE OR ALSO. ON THE OUR
EXPERIENCE FOLKS SO. BUT IT
DOES TAKE TIME AND IT TO IT IN
ORDER TO HAVE A WORK FORCE UP
AND RUNNING AT THE LEVEL THAT
YOU NEED. I WHEN WE STARTED
THIS WHOLE THING WITH THAT AT
THE BEGINNING OF THE YEAR WHAT
WAS THE NUMBER OF EMPLOYEES AT
AT YOUR DEPARTMENT WELL AT
WITHIN ARE YOU AYE PROGRAM OR A
LITTLE OVER TWO THOUSAND.
THAT'S IT OR THAT'S AT. SO IN
ARE YOU OUR PROGRAM WELL I'M
SEEING IN ORDER TO BE ABLE TO
COMPARE TO THE SEVENTY NINE
SEVENTY ONE TOTAL THAT YOU HAVE
NOW. AND MOVING UPWARDS TO
ABOUT NINE THOUSAND WITH
ANOTHER ADDITIONAL THOUSAND
HIRES. COMPARING APPLES TO
APPLES WHAT WERE THE TOTAL
NUMBER OF EMPLOYEES AT THE
BEGINNING OF THE YEAR. WE HAD
ABOUT TWO THOUSAND AND IF
YOU'RE COMPARING APPLES TO
APPLES AND- IF YOU TAKE THE-
NINE THOUSAND AND BACK OUT TE
REDIRECT STAFF EMPLOYED THEN
YOU HAVE APPLES AND APPLES. SO
RIGHT WHAT'S RIGHT OKAY SO I'M
ASKING THAT BECAUSE I'M JUST
TRYING TO GET A SENSE IF ONCE
WE GET TO NINE THOUSAND AND
THEN WE CUT BACK BY ANOTHER
TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED WE'RE WE'RE
ROUGHLY AROUND SIXTY FIVE
HUNDRED. SO ON AN ONGOING BASIS
WE'RE GONNA HAVE SIXTY FIVE
HUNDRED EMPLOYEES. WHICH WE
TREAT THE WHICH MEANS THAT
THAT'S THREE TIMES THE NUMBER
OF EMPLOYEES WE HAD AT THE
BEGINNING OF THIS YEAR. SO AT
AND EXPERIENCED INDIVIDUALS ARE
DWARFING THE NUMBER OF
EXPERIENCED INDIVIDUALS. HOW IS
THAT BEING MANAGED. WELL I- FOR
ONE THING THAT NEW HIRES ARE
LIMITED TERM BECAUSE WHEN THE
PANDEMIC UNEMPLOYMENT AND
PROGRAM STARTED THE CURES ACT
IT WAS TEMPORARY IN NATURE- SO
AT SOME POINT THEY WILL OF. NOT
BE WORKING FOR EDT ASSUMING
THAT CONGRESS DOESN'T PASS
SOMETHING IN THE END OF
DECEMBER AND WE HAVE SOMETHING
ELSE TO TAKE ITS PLACE OR TO
CONTINUE IT. SO OKAY AND WHEN
DO YOU SEE THAT TAPERING OFF.
ALL THIS WHEN. WHAT WOULD YOU
SAY SIX MONTHS. A GOOD SIX
MONTHS- ASSUMING IT'S NOT
EXTENDED. SO WHAT AND WHAT
WOULD THE NUMBER COME BACK DOWN
TO WOULD IT GO BACK TO AGAIN
TWO THOUSAND OR- IT COULD BUT
WITH THE NEW TOOL THAT THE-
STRIKE TEAM PROVIDED US. IT'S A
BURN DOWN CHART I AS I REFER TO
IT IS A PREDICTIVE MODEL WHERE
WE CAN PUT IN INVENTORIES
WORKLOADS AND STAFFING AND
FIGURE OUT EXACTLY WHAT WE NEED
AND MAKE ADJUSTMENTS IN BETWEEN
THE WORKLOADS. SO THAT'S WHAT
WE'LL BE USING MOVING FORWARD
TO- MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE THE
RIGHT NUMBER OF STAFF- AT THE
RIGHT LEVELS UP TO MEET ALL OF
OUR WORKLOADS. RIGHT NOW IT
SAYS WE NEED ALL OF THEM. K.
BUT SAID. LET'S LOOK AT THINGS
ON A ON A THIRTY THOUSAND FEET
VIEW- THE STRIKE TEAM HAD MADE
SOME EXTENSIVE NUMBER OF-
DETAILED RECOMMENDATIONS DO YOU
WHAT DOES EDT OR DO YOU AND
YOUR LEADERSHIP TEAM AGREE WITH
ALL OF THEM. YES WE DID AGREE
WITH ALL OF THEM. JIM WHO'S
GOING TO BE IN CHARGE WITH
IMPLEMENTING ALL THE
RECOMMENDATIONS. AND WHAT
TIMELINE. SO WE WILL HAVE A
TIME LINE COMPLETED BY THE END
OF THE MONTH- AND WE'LL BE GLAD
TO PROVIDE YOU ARE MATRIX- THAT
THAT SHOWS ALL THE
RECOMMENDATIONS AS WELL AS THE
WHEN WE EXPECT TO IMPLEMENT
THEM- MOST OF THEM AND I THINK
NINETY ONE OF THE HUNDRED AND-
ELEVEN R. I. T. US SOLUTIONS.
OF SO R. I. T. BRANCH WILL BE-
IMPLEMENTING THOSE IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH ARE YOU AYE
BRANCH- AND OUR NEW CHIEF
DEPUTY DIRECTOR CAROL WILLIAMS-
HAS OVERSIGHT OVER THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF ALL THOSE ON
STRIKE TEAMS RECOMMENDATIONS.
OKAY SO THEN THE NON NINETY
PLUS SAFETY OF STRIKE TEAM
TALKED A LOT ABOUT THE CULTURE
OF DVD AND THE CHANGES THAT
NEEDED TO BE MADE. EDT AGREE
WITH THE ASSESSMENT. I THINK
THE MAIN EXCHANGE OF CULTURE
AND HOW WOULD THEY GO ABOUT
CHANGING THE CULTURE. THE MAIN
CULTURE CHANGE YOUR THEY'RE
REFERRING TO IS REALLY AROUND-
FRAUD AND- HOW WE ARE LOOKING
AT THE BALANCE OF MAKING SURE
WE PAY PEOPLE YET PROTECT THE
FUND- AND THAT'S A TRICKY
BALANCING THAT IS VERY
DIFFICULT. SO AGAIN AND I THINK
PART OF OUR CULTURAL CHANGE
WHICH I REALLY APPRECIATE AS
WITH THE HIRE OF A NEW
EXECUTIVE TEAM. THAT I
MENTIONED EARLIER WITH OUR NEED
TO CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTORS AS
WELL AS A NEW CHIEF COUNSEL-
AND NEW LEADS DIRECTOR- HAVE
ALREADY SHOWN IMPROVEMENT BUT
THE BRAND. NEW FRESH IDEAS AND
A NEW LOOK AT THINGS SO I
WELCOME THAT AND- THERE THEY'VE
ALREADY BEEN EXTRAORDINARY AND
WE'RE GETTING IN AND MAKING
SURE THAT- IS REFLECTIVE IN A
CULTURE. THAT WE'RE ALL PROUD
OF. SO THEN I DON'T WANT. HEY
BENEFITS SINCE AND SPEAKING OF
THE FROM ISSUE. AND GIVEN THE
FACT THAT IT WITH YOUR YOUR
MORE. AS AS IT WAS POINTED OUT
WITH SOME OF THE PREVIOUS
QUESTIONS THAT MORE OF THE- IT
SEEMS LIKE THE APPROACH AND THE
LEANING WAS TO- NOT PAY AND
ASSUME THAT THERE'S FRAUD AND
SO VERY FEW GO THROUGH EXHAUST
THE VERIFICATION. WHERE WAS
THAT COMING FROM WAS THERE A
HIGH RATE OF INCIDENCE. FOR A
FRAUD OR WAS IT- THE
SPECIALIZED IN SPECIFIC REGIONS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE WHAT WAS.
WHERE WAS THAT THINKING AN
APPROACH BASED ON YEAH THAT
THOSE ARE PERCEPTION- AND LIKE
I SAID IT IS A VERY HARD
BALANCE- I THINK WE'RE REALLY-
FOCUSED IN WAS A COUPLE YEARS
AGO THERE IS A NATIONAL IT'S
CALLED SPRING BREAK BREAK CASE
AND HIT THE UNEMPLOYMENT ASSIST
AND- INSURANCE PROGRAMS HARD
THROUGHOUT THE NATION-
DEPARTMENT OF LABOR HAS- WAS
THE ONE THAT REALLY LED THE
CHARGE AND WORKING WITH ALL THE
STATE'S. BUT THAT'S WHEN WE
REALLY STARTED A COUPLE YEARS
AGO WE REALLY STARTED SEE AN
INFLUX OF- PEOPLE HAVING OTHER
PEOPLE'S ID AND OTHER
IDENTIFYING INFORMATION SO THEY
COULD INFILTRATE OUR SYSTEMS
WORKING REALLY BAD WAS WHEN
CONGRESS PASSED THE PANDEMIC
UNEMPLOYMENT ASSISTANCE PROGRAM
IMPLEMENTED THAT BECAUSE IT HAS
VERY LITTLE CHECKS AND
BALANCES- AND MADE IT JUST YOU
KNOW UNFORTUNATELY. THE
ALTHOUGH I KNOW THAT THAT THAT
THE INCENTIVE WAS TO MAKE SURE
EVERYONE GETS PAID AND THAT WAS
WHAT THEIR FOCUS ON THE%
DOWNSTREAM THE FACT WAS THAT
OPEN THE DOOR FOR FRAUD IN A
WAY THAT WE'VE NEVER SEEN
BEFORE. SO THEN WHAT. WELL OKAY
I WILL I WILL I DON'T WANT TO
GET TOO MUCH INTO THE FRONT
ISSUE RIGHT NOW. GOING BACK TO
THE CULTURE ISSUE REASON WHY I
WAS BRINGING IT UP AND YOU YOU
SAID THAT IT HAS TO DO A LOT
MORE FOCUS ON FRAUD I. THE
REASON WHY I WAS BRINGING IT UP
IS BECAUSE WHEN YOU LOOK AT
SOMETHING LIKE THE VERY IDEA
VERIFICATION FOR THE CLAIMANTS
AND THE FACT THAT THE SCANNER-
IN THE VERIFICATION UNIT
COULDN'T DETECT THE RED COLOR.
AND HAT CREATED QUITE A BIT OF
A BACKLOG BECAUSE INDIVIDUALS
NEEDED TO GO IN AND MANUALLY
CONDUCT THAT. THE REASON MY
ASSOCIATE THIS WITH CULTURE IS
BECAUSE WHEN YOU HAVE. WEEKLY
MEETINGS EXECUTIVE MEETINGS OR
BI WEEKLY OR HOWEVER WAY YOU DO
IT. YOU DISCUSS DIFFERENT
ISSUES AND YOU SEE THINGS THAT
YOU CAN POINT OUT TO THAT. ARE
IN MASS CREATING A PROBLEM AND
A HOLD UP. M. I AM JUST TRYING
TO UNDERSTAND. SOMETHING THAT
MAY HAVE BEEN SO OBVIOUS THAT
COULD HAVE BEEN ADDRESSED. AND
CREATED SO MUCH BACKLOG. HOW
WAS THAT NOT READILY SEEN OR OR
COME UP IN YOUR MEETINGS I MEAN
I SUSPECT YOU DO HAVE EXECUTIVE
MEETINGS ON A RELATIVELY
FREQUENT BASIS HOW WAS
SOMETHING LIKE THAT NOT
IDENTIFIED AND BROUGHT UP. AND
IT REQUIRED THE A STRIKE TEAM
TO COME IN AND IDENTIFY IT.
ABSOLUTELY I HEAR WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING SO. THE DEPARTMENT FOR
THE LAST FEW YEARS WE'VE HAD A
PROJECT PORTFOLIO AND WE TRIED
TO PRIORITIZE ALL THE PROJECTS
ACROSS THE ENTERPRISE AND APPLY
RESOURCES AS WE CAN WHO MAKE
SURE THAT WORK- IMPLEMENTING.
ALL THE APPROVED MENTAL
DEFICIENCIES BUT LIKE ANY
DEPARTMENT WEVE GOT MORE WORK
AND THEN WE HAVE ACTUAL
RESOURCES AND WHEN THE PANDEMIC
HIT. IT BECAME EVEN MORE
CHALLENGING THAT'S WHY THE
STRIKE TEAM CAME IN THEY
ACTUALLY BROUGHT IN CAME IN AND
BROUGHT IT DITION RESOURCES-
BECAUSE I YOU KNOW THERE'S A
LOT THAT IT JUST WASN'T ENOUGH
OF US THAT WORK- ABLE TO
ADDRESS ALL THE ISSUES SWIFTLY
ENOUGH. OUR FOCUS OUR PEOPLE
ARE MAINLY ON ACTUALLY PAYING
THE BENEFITS OF PRODUCING THE
WORK. SO WHEN YOU'RE- YEAH. TRY
TO REVEL. YOUR I. . SYSTEM IN
YOUR PROCESSES AND EVERY
FUNCTION- YOU KNOW WELL ONE
FELL SWOOP IT. IS GOOD THAT
DOESN'T HAPPEN OVERNIGHT IT
JUST DOESN'T. BUT I'M POINTING
OUT TO SOMETHING VERY SPECIFIC
THAT. I WOULD HAVE HOPED WHEN
THIS IS CONTRIBUTING I THINK I
REMEMBER SOMETHING ABOUT AROUND
40% OR THIS WAS THIS HAD A
SIGNIFICANT CONTRIBUTION TO THE
LACKING OF THE PROCESS. SOME
I'M NOT EXACTLY SOMETHING LIKE
THIS ONE I WOULD HAVE ASSUMED
WOULD HAVE COME UP. RELATIVELY
QUICKLY OR OR AT LEAST WITHIN A
MONTH'S PERIOD OF TIME WHEN IT
BECOMES VERY NOTICEABLE THAT
THIS IS AN ISSUE. I WOULD
EXPECT AND WE ENCOURAGE OUR
EMPLOYEES TO- SPEAK TO THEIR
MANAGERS AND REYES ALL ISSUES
AND TALK ABOUT IMPROVEMENT- WE
HAVE MANY COURSES ON BUSINESS
PROCESS IMPROVEMENT FOR ALL OF
OUR STAFF THAT SORT OF. THE
BASIS OF YOU KNOW OUR MANTRA-
YEAH I WOULD HOPE SO TOO I'M
NOT FAMILIAR WITH EXACTLY THE
ONE YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT BUT-
YOU KNOW. ABSOLUTELY WE'RE
ALWAYS LOOKING TO MAKE
IMPROVEMENTS AND WE ARE IT'S I
MEAN AS A CONSTANT. OKAY THIS
THIS WAS SOMETHING VERY
SPECIFIC IN THE END THE REPORT
THAT DISCUSSED HOW. THE
SCATTERED WENT WHEN THE DRIVER
CALIFORNIA DRIVER'S LICENSE
WOULD BE SCANNED. THE RED INK
DYE WOULDN'T BE PICKED UP. AND
SO CERTAIN INFORMATION NEEDED
TO BE MANUALLY AND PUT. SEVEN
EIGHT THAT'S WHY I'M I'M JUST
PICKING ON SOMETHING RELATIVELY
SIMPLE THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN
EASILY NOTICED AND WOULD OF
BEEN PICKED UP ESPECIALLY IF.
MULTIPLE INCIDENTS REOCCURRING
INCIDENTS HAPPEN TO THE POINT
WHERE EMPLOYEES START TALKING
TO ONE ANOTHER ABOUT IT. IT
THAT NONE OF THAT GOT UP TO
MANAGEMENT LEVEL AND ULTIMATELY
TO YOU. NO IT DID NOT REACH ME-
AND I WOULD HOPE IT TO ITDID
GREAT- TO THE MANAGERS AND THAT
THEY WERE ACTIVELY WORKING ON
IT UP I CAN'T SPEAK TO IT. THAT
I WASN'T AWARE. OKAY WELL THANK
YOU THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MISTER DEAN. THANK YOU MR- THIS
SO I WANT TO JUST JUST TALK TO
LA- A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THIS
ISSUE THAT WE WERE TALKING
ABOUT REGARDING CULTURAL. SO IF
AWAY COULD. THE STRUGGLE TO
COME BACK. BECAUSE I HAD
SIMILAR QUESTIONS AS MY
COLLEAGUE FROM LOS ANGELES. ON
IT'S JUST REGARDING THE-
PORCHER CAN YOU IDENTIFY IS
SORT OF WHAT YOU EXPERIENCED AS
YOU WERE- LOOKING OUT EDT TO
GIVE US A BETTER SENSE OF WHAT
WHAT WHAT WHY WAS THERE OF THIS
CULTURE AND THIS FOCUS. ON
FRAUD IN AT THE SAME TIME WE
HAD A HUGE NUMBER OF CASES OF
FRAUDULENT BEHAVIOR SO SOMEHOW
EVEN THOUGH THE CULTURE WAS
VERY MUCHFOCUSED. ON FRAUD
SOMEHOW THEY THEY MISSED ALL
THIS FRAUD THAT WAS GOING ON SO
HELP ME UNDERSTAND. WHAT YOU
SAW. OF COURSE THANK YOU MR
TANG. I SHOULD FIRST AND
FOREMOST NOTE THAT. MY COMMENTS
ABOUT THE CULTURE ET ARE
SPECIFIC TO MY EXPERIENCE
INTERACTING WITH APARTMENT ARE
IN NO WAY CONCLUSIVE. AND THEN
SECONDARILY I WOULDN'T WANT TO
SEPARATE WITH A LONG STANDING.
FOCUS ON FRAUD PREVENTION PER
FEDERAL STANDARDS FOR THE
STATE'S NORMAL UNDERLYING YOU IPROGRAM ON A SEPARATE THAT FROM
FRAUD THAT'S BEEN SEEN WITH THE
PO A PROGRAM THAT WAS PASSED AS
PART OF THEIR KERR SACKED
BECAUSE THEY'RE THERE TO.
DIFFERENT ISSUES I THINK AND
ARGUE SO FIRST RELATED TO. THE
LONGSTANDING FOCUS ON FRAUD
PREVENTION. IN IN IN MY
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
DEPARTMENT AND EXPERIENCE
WORKING WITH DVD IT'S CLEAR
THAT. THAT THE DEPARTMENT IS
READING INCENTIVES FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT PERTAINING
TO MINIMIZING THE NUMBER OF
OVERPAYMENTS- THAT ISSUES AND
THAT GUIDANCE COMES FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF LABOR. AND AS ALL
STATE DEPARTMENTS DO THAT ARE
THAT ARE INTERACTING WITH WITH
FEDERAL COUNTERPARTS THAT THAT
DICTATE RULES AND REGULATIONS
THAT THAT THE PART WAS TAKING
EFFORTS TO MEET THOSE.
INCENTIVES AND MESSAGES FROM
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. THAT
SAID THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
ALSO EQUALLY PRIORITIZES THE
PROMPT PAYMENT OF BENEFITS AND-
SO WHEN WE COMPARED THE
DEPARTMENT'S TREATMENT OF THOSE
TO. HAVE WHAT'S SAY- TARGETS
THAT THAT MAY BE IN OPPOSITION
OR OR IMBALANCED- IT APPEARS
THAT THE DEPARTMENT HAS TENDED
TO PREFER FOCUSING ON FRAUD
PREVENTION RELATIVE TO ISSUING-
BENEFIT PAYMENTS IN A TIMELY
FASHION. NOW TO THE SECOND
POINT MR TANG RELATED TO FRAUD
THAT'S RECENTLY BEEN BEEN
UNCOVERED IN THE P. WAY PROGRAM
AS BOTH THE THAT SECRETARY
RICHARDSON AND- DIRECTOR SO
YOU'D MENTIONED THE FEDERAL
PROGRAM RECENTLY STOOD UP
INCLUDED VERY FEW STEPS THAT
WOULD LIMIT THIS SORT OF
ACTIVITY- IF- A FRAUDULENT
ACTOR HAD OBTAINED- IDENTIFYING
INFORMATION FROM A PREVIOUS
DATA BREACH. THEY COULD SUBMIT
THAT INFORMATION THROUGH THE
REQUIREMENTS UNDER FEDERAL LAW
FOR THE P. YOU A PROGRAM AND
THE CLAIM COULD GO THROUGH
CLEANLY THERE WOULD BE NOTHING
BUILT INTO THE DESIGN OF THE
CLAIM TO CATCH THAT FRAUDULENT
ACTIVITY. NOW WHEN ET DE DID
BEGIN NOTICING THE TRENDS IN
THIS FRAUDULENT ACTIVITY
MULTIPLE CLAIMS GOING TO A
SINGLE ADDRESS I'M JUST LOOKING
AT THE TRENDS LINES IN THE
NUMBER OF APPLICATIONS THERE
WERE SOME INCONSISTENCIES. THEY
TOOK SEVERAL STEPS TO NOT ONLY.
STEP ESTABLISHED PRODUCERS AT
THE AT THE OUTSET BUT ALSO TO
REDUCE THE INCENTIVES SO THAT
THE MAIN STEP THAT I WANT TO
POINT OUT IS THAT THAT THE
DEPARTMENT- STOPS AUTOMATICALLY
CERTIFYING PRIOR WEEKS BENEFIT
PAYMENTS. AND SO IN ORDER TO GO
BACK LIKE GET TO RECEIVE A
BACKDATED CLAIM UNDER THE POOL
PROGRAM NOW- THERE'S ANOTHER
TOUCH POINT WITH PD TO CONFIRM
THE IDENTITY OF THAT CLAIM AND-
AND THIS PREVENTS. A FRAUDULENT
ACTOR FROM CLAIMING SAY FIFTEEN
OR TWENTY WEEKS OF BACK
PAYMENTS WHICH IS WHY YOU WERE
SAYING TEN TWELVE FIFTEEN
THOUSAND DOLLAR EDT DEBIT
CARDS- THAT WERE BEING USED
FRAUDULENTLY ALL SIGNS INDICATE
AS OF NOW THAT THAT STEP.
FATHER WAS INSTITUTED SEVERAL
WEEKS AGO BY THE DEPARTMENT IS
SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCING THE
NUMBER OF APPLICATIONS- FOR THE
P. AWAY PROGRAM AND LIKELY
PRODUCING AND THAT THEY'RE NOT
A FRAUDULENT ACTIVITY THERE.
THANK YOU FOR THE CLARIFICATION
REGARDING THE PEE WEE PROGRAM
OBVIOUSLY. WITH A PROGRAM WAS
SET UP THERE ARE. THERE THE
NUMBER FIVE THERE'S A LOT OF
CONDITIONS THAT MAKE IT VERY
VERY DIFFICULT TO. ENSURE THAT.
THE ACTUAL PEOPLE ARE THE ONES
WHO DESERVE TO CLAIM SO OR SO I
DO UNDERSTAND THAT SIR THANK
YOU FOR THAT CLARIFICATION. HOW
DO SO BASED ON YOUR
OBSERVATIONS. HAVE YOU SEEN A
SHIFT SO THAT THERE'S NOT MORE
OF A BALANCE THAT YOU SAID YOU
HAVE TO- SIMILAR INCENTIVES ONE
ON THE AMOUNT OF TIME TO DO A-
LOT TO PROCESS THE CLAIM AS
WELL AS THE- OVER THE- OVER
PAVE THE MINIMIZING
OVERPAYMENTS. SO IF YOU SEE ME
AT LEAST A SHIFT TO MORE OF A
BALANCE SO THAT THERE IS MORE
FOCUSED ON THE AMOUNT OF TIME
IT TAKES TO PROCESS A CLAIM. I
MUST SAY THAT I AM NOT IN A
POSITION. TO HAVE SEEN A SHIFT
INTERNAL ACT EDT AND WHETHER OR
NOT IT IS OCCURRED OR IS
OCCURRING- WHAT I WILL SAY. IS
THAT THE STRIKE TEAM REPORT
CLEARLY. ILLUMINATES THIS
BALANCING ACT AND CLARIFIES
THAT EDT HAS HISTORICALLY
TENDED TO FAVOR FOCUSING ON
FRAUD RELATIVE TO BENEFIT
TIMELY PAYMENT. AND IN THIS
REGARD WE BELIEVE THAT THE
REPORT ITSELF AND THIS
ASSESSMENT AND THESE FINDINGS
ARE AT LEAST IN IDENTIFYING THE
CULTURAL BALANCE THAT THE
DEPARTMENT MUST STRIKE- SHOULD
AT LEAST. THROUGH FACILITATE
THIS CONVERSATION THE ONE THAT
WE'RE HAVING HERE TODAY- GOING
FORWARD SUCH THE LEGISLATURE
CAN ALSOPROVIDE GETS INPUT ON
WHERE IT WOULD PREFER THE
DEPARTMENT LAND ON THIS BALANCE.
THANK YOU I JUST WANNA GO BACK
TO THE DIRECTOR HILLIARD. SO
ON. IT GIVEN THE JUST THE L. L.
AS I'LL JUST CALL AND
OBSERVATION RATHER THAN A-
DATA. BASE AND THE ONLY WAS
OBSERVATION WHERE YOU HAVE THE-
SIMILAR FEDERAL INCENTIVES FOR
MINIMIZING OVER PAYMENTS AS
WELL AS- ON MAKING SURE THAT
PEOPLE ARE PAID IN A PROMPT
MANNER. HAS THE DEPARTMENT
STARTED TO MOVE. THE STAFF IN A
MANNER SO THAT CLAIMS ARE
GETTING PROCESSED IN A IN A
FASTER. AND FASTER MATTER.
DEFINITELY THROUGH ALL THE
FISHING SEASON ID ME AND THAT
THE WHOLE REDIRECTION OF
PUTTING STAFF. EXPERIENCE STAFF
ON THE COMPLEX CASES. I MEAN.
IT YOU KNOW IT. THANKS STAFF OR
PAYING BENEFITS TIMELY HIS
ISN'T CREDIT IS FOUNDATIONAL TO
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT TO US- NOW
I KNOW THE STRIKE TEAM FELT
THAT WE HAD A MORE PROPENSITY
TO FRAUD- WE REALLY JUST BEEN
TRYING TO. LET YOU KNOW BOUNCE
BOTH AND BOTH ARE VERY
IMPORTANT TO US BUT I WOULD SAY
BETWEEN THE TWO- PAYING PEOPLE
THINK PEOPLE YOU AYE BENEFITS-
HAS A HIGHER NOT THEN THE
FRAUD. SO WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO
MAKE SURE WE'RE ADDRESSING
BOTH. BUT OUR TOP TOP TOP
CONCERN IS MAKING SURE THAT
PEOPLE ARE RECEIVING BENEFITS
WHICH THANK YOU IN A CAN YOU
CAN YOU JUST FOR THE COMMITTEE
JUST EXPLAIN TO US. HOW THAT'S
BEEN COMMUNICATED TO THE STAFF.
HELLO THANK YOU. WE PROVIDE A
NEWSLETTER. FOR CONCERTS EVERY.
I SEND OUT DIRECT MESSAGES OF
THE DEPUTY DIRECTORS
COMMUNICATED IT I MEAN IT'S-
IT'S ALSO IN OUR TRAINING
MANUALS AS FAR AS THE
IMPORTANCE OF PAYING BENEFITS.
I MEAN IT'S THE LABOR IS
EVERYWHERE- THOSE ARE ALL VERY
BROAD- YEAH. COMMUNICATIONS I'M
YOUR THOUSAND PEOPLE WHO WORK.
WITH YOU BUT YOU ALSO HAVE
DIRECT. SUPERVISORS TO SERVE
YOU. HI WITH YOUR SENIOR TEAM.
TALKED ABOUT IT AND TALKED
ABOUT HOW TO GIVE THAT
DIRECTIVE TO YOUR SUBORDINATES
DOWN SUPERVISORS CENTER
MANAGERS ALL AROUND THE STATE.
RIGHT I HAVEN'T STARTED THERE
YET I'VE STARTED WITH OUR
GENERAL COUNSEL AND OUR CHIEF
DEPUTY DIRECTORS IT JUST
STARTED. WE HAD A DISCUSSION
ABOUT THAT AT ALL I'VE ALREADY
AND LISTEN MY GENERAL COUNSEL
TO TAKE A LOOK AT THE POLICIES
AND PROCEDURES OF ALL THE
BRANCHES TO ENSURE THAT THEY
ARE YOU KNOW NEARING THE KIND
OF DEPARTMENT WE WANNA BE PROUD
OF. SO HE WILL USE YOU TALKED
YOUR GENERAL COUNSEL TO MAKE
SURE YOU'RE NOT DOING SOMETHING
THAT'S- IN VIOLATION OF LAND.
FORCES YEAH. I'M HAVING- MAKE
SURE THAT- LOOKING AT ALL THE
POLICIES THAT ITS IT'S- IT'S
PROTECTING OUR CLAIMANTS I WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT. WE'RE DOING
RIGHT BY THEM THAT'S THE
INCENTIVE BEHIND IT. BASED ON
WHAT YOU JUST SAID IT SOUNDS
LIKE THERE HASN'T BEEN ANY-
DIRECT. VERBAL CONTINUOUS.
COMMUNICATION TO YOUR
MANAGEMENT STAFF. NOT IN
SPECIFIC WEEK IF WE YOU KNOW
FRAUD 49% AND PAYING BENEFITS
51% I MEAN WE TAKE THOSE VERY
SERIOUSLY BUT IT IS SOMETHING I
CERTAINLY COULD. OF LOOK AT AND
I THINK YOU FOR THE FEEDBACK
AND- GIVEN THE STRIKE TEAMS
REPORT THAT'S PROBABLY IS A
GREAT OPPORTUNITY TO BROADLY
SORT OF LAY THE FOUNDATIONAL
LOOK OF WHERE WE'RE GOING IN
THE FUTURE I THINK THAT'S AN
EXCELLENT SUGGESTION. THANK YOU
I DID JUST COME BACK TO THE
DASHBOARD I APPRECIATE THAT THE
DASHBOARD WAS VERY MUCH. ON
IMPLEMENTING THE BUDGET BILL
THAT WAS PASSED FROM NOW AGAIN
THOSE WERE SPECIFIC ITEMS TO BE
IMPLEMENTED. BUT THEY DIDN'T
LIMIT YOU FROM IMPLEMENTING
ADDITIONAL ITEMS SO JUST IN
LOOKING AT YOUR DASHBOARD MY
HAVE A PULLED UP ON THE
COMPUTER IT'S VERY DIFFICULT TO
TELL. HOW IT'S WILL NOT
DIFFICULT IT'S IMPOSSIBLE TO
TELL HOW LARGE THE BACKLOG IS
UNLESS I STARTED SURFING AROUND
YOUR- YOUR WELL DESERVE REASON
WHY THE BACKLOGS NOT EASILY
IDENTIFY HI FIVE WILSHIRE ON UP
ON THE DASHBOARD. SO RIGHT NOW
WE REALLY HAVE TO SET THE
DASHBOARDS GOING ON WE HAVE THE
DASHBOARD THROUGH AB ONE OH
SEVEN AND WE ALSO HAVE THE
DASHOARDS IT- WE HAVE NOW JUST
PUBLICLY LAUNCHED AS A RESULT
OF THE STRIKE TEAM. SO IT WAS
OUR INTENT TO WORK WITH THE
COMMITTEE AND RECOMMEND THAT WE
REPLACE THE LANGUAGE IN THE ONE
OH SEVEN. ALL UP WITH THE NEW
DASHBOARD- PRESENTED BY THE-
RECOMMENDED BY THE STRIKE TEAM
BECAUSE WE FELT AND WE AGREED
THAT IT'S MUCH MORE INCLUSIVE
OF. YOU KNOW EVERYBODY BOTH
PEOPLE THAT YOU KNOW WORK THAT
WE HAVE IN Q. AS WELL AS
PEOPLE- STOCK- AND YOU KNOW
DON'T KNOW WHAT TO DO YOU KNOW.
SO THAT WAS GOING TO BE OUR
NEXT STEP WAS TO PUT A REQUEST
AND IS TO LOOK AT- CHANGING
REQUIREMENTS OF AB ONE OH SEVEN
WITH THE AND REPLACING IT WITH
THE NEW DASHBOARDS IT JUST GOT
CREATED. THE NEW WITHIN THE
DASHBOARD I'M I'M LOOKING AT
YOUR POWER. H. FIVE IS. IS THE
ONE UNDER THE NEWSROOM. THAT'S
RIGHT YEAH RIGHT NOW SO THAT
THAT'S WHAT I'M LOOKING AT IS
THE NEW DASHBOARD. THAT'S NOT
PART OF ONE OH SEVEN THEN- THAT
THAT THAT IS THE NEW DASHBOARDS
WERE AS- RECOMMENDED TO THE
STRIKE TEAM. AND THERE'S TWO
TWO ONE ONE FOUR ONE FOR
INITIAL CLAIMS ONE FOR
CONTINUED CLAIMS. AND WHERE'S
THE OTHER ONE OKAY BECAUSE YOU
ONLY MENTION TO YOUR POWER
POINT YOU JUST MENTIONED A NEW
DASHBOARD. AND THAT'S WHEN I
AND I. AND I BROKE DOWN TOO SO.
TURN TO PAGE. SO SLIDE FIVE- IT
TALKS ABOUT THE TO THE NATIONAL
CLAIMS BACKLOG IN THE CONTINUE
CLAIMS BACKLOG THERE'S TWO
DASHBOARDS CURRENTLY BEING
PRODUCED AND- DISPLAYED ON OUR
WEBSITE. WE'RE THE SECOND ONE
I'M I'M NOT SURE NEWS ROOM. SO
I CAN SEE WHAT WHAT YOU'RE
LOOKING AND I'LL BE GLAD TO
EMAIL THEM IF YOU LOOK AT AGAIN
I'M I'M AT THE- YOU SEE THE
BULLET RIGHT AFTERWARDS ON YOUR
OWN POWER POINTS AS THE NEW
DASHBOARDS CAN BE LOCATED VIA
EDIE'S NEWSROOM. YEAH HARBANS
WEBSITE SO THAT'S WHAT I'M NOT
I'M NOT I'M NOT RIGHT WITH
WEBSITE AMONG NEWSROOM. AT THE
VERY BOTTOM OF THE NEWS ROOM
THERE'S THE UNEMPLOYMENT.
INSURANCE DATA DASHBOARD. SO
THERE'S A DATA DASHBOARD THAT'S
PART OF- THE WHAT'S IN THE NEWS.
PRESS RELEASE IT YOU CAN SIT ON
THE FRONT PAGE THEY'RE ALL
SHOULD ALSO BE A LINK TOTHE
TO- DASHBOARDS. ONE NINETY ONE
FOR CONTINUED CLAIMS I THINK
THE PART OF LINKS OKAY. YEAH
THE SERVER SO I THINK- PHONE.
THE CHALLENGES IS JUST OUT OF
MY- NO MY MOTHER CALLING FROM
SERVICE REITERATED. IS THAT IT
IS. YOU'LL GET A BE NICE TO
HAVE SOMETHING THAT WE DON'T
HAVE TO GO SEARCHING THROUGHOUT
YOUR WEBSITE TO GO FIND THAT
IT'S ALL IN ONE PLACE- IT'S
VERY DIFFICULT TO GO BACK AND
LOOK AT HISTORIC TRENDS
BECAUSE- I WILL CLICK ON THAT
INFORMATION- ALSO IS THERE A
REASON. WHY THE BACKLOG IS NOT
ON THE DASHBOARD. THE BACKLOG
IS ON THE DASHBOARD ON THE
INITIAL CLAIMS AND CONTINUING
CLAIMS THAT'S CLOSE ALL OF OUR
THAT THE PDF FROM SORRY OKAY.
IS THERE REASON THAT'S NOT ALL
IN ONE PLACE. IT I'M NOT I'M
NOT SURE WHAT YOU'RE REFERRING
TO IF YOU HAVE SOME SUGGESTIONS
ON WHERE YOU THINK WOULD BE
BETTER HOUSE DIED WOULD LOVE TO
HEAR IT NOW I THINK. IT'S USING
YOU KNOW THE FACT THAT IT'S
HARD TO SPEND FIVE MINUTES AND
YOU HAVE TO WALK ME THROUGH IT
AND- I'M SITTING HERE ON YOUR
WEBSITE DEMONSTRATE THAT IT IS
CONFUSING. THEY DEMONSTRATE
THAT THE DATA IS NOT EASILY
ACCESSIBLE. SO IT WOULD BE NICE
TOO AGAIN TO HAVE IT ON ALL OF
THE PLACE TO BE TO MAKE IT
VISUALLY EASY TO LOOK AT- THE
MORE LINKS OU DO- IT'S GREAT
FOR IT ON DATA GEEKS WHO LOVE
SPENDING TIME ON YOUR WEBSITE
BUT FOR MOST. PEOPLE THAT'S NOT
WHAT THEY WOULD BE LOOKING AT
AND THAT'S DEFINITELY NOT WHAT
I WOULD LIKE TO SPEND TIME
DOING AND THEN IN ADDITION TO
THAT IS THERE A REASON WHY YOU
DON'T HAVE THE AMOUNT OF TIME
IT TAKES TO PROCESS. A CLAIM ON
YOUR DASHBOARD. OF WE DO HAVE A
BURN DOWN CHART THAT WE WORK AT
WHICH I REFERRED TO EARLIER IS
NOT PART THE DASHBOARD BUT- WE
CERTAINLY COULD PUT ON THE
DASHBOARD SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
I THINK I THINK COULD BE
HELPFUL ON THE BECAUSE I THINK
IT WOULD DEMONSTRATE THAT
YOU'RE YOU'RE MAKING PROGRESS
AND THAT THAT THE CLAIMS ARE
BEING PROCESSED IN A FASTER
FASHION. YEAH SO THAT IT WOULD
JUST BE IT WOULD BE BASED ON
DATA RIGHT RIGHT NOW YOU'RE-
YOU'RE TELLING US THAT BUT THAT
THIS WHERE YOUR YOUR DRONE DATA
WHAT COOPERATE THAT. GO GOING
BACK TO THE JUST STAY STICKY
WITH THE BACKLOG- YOU YOU
MENTIONED THAT YOU ANTICIPATE
THIS ONE POINT SIX MILLION
PERSON BACKLOG TO BE CLEARED BY
JANUARY TWENTY TWENTY ONE ON AS
OF JANUARY TWENTY TWENTY ONE
THAT HOW LARGE WOULD YOU
ANTICIPATE AT THE BACKLOG THAT
YOU HAVE BEEN ABLE TO GET TO-
BIG BECAUSE IF THIS IS NOT A
STATIC NUMBER BASED ON THAT
PARTICULAR POINT IN TIME BUT I
ASSUME. UNDERSTOOD YEAH CASES
WILL BE COMING IN FOR HELPING
ABOUT GLOBAL YOU HAVE IN
JANUARY TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
EXACTLY WE WILL NOT HAVE A
BACKLOG AND THE NEW TOOL THAT I
REFERRED TO BEFORE THAT- WE'RE
ABLE TO PUT IN OUR RESOURCES
PUT IN OUR WORK LOAD IN
PROJECT. THIS WAS ATOOL THAT
CAME OUT OF THE STRIKE TEAMS-
EFFORTS- HAS ALLOWED US TO
PREDICT AND PROJECT AND- FIGURE
OUT HOW MANY STAFF ARE NEEDED
SO ARE BURNED DOWN PLAN. TO
LIQUIDATE THE BACKLOG THROUGH
JAN IN JANUARY AND THEN
MAINTAIN WORKING INVENTORIES
MOVING FORWARD FROM HAT SO WE-
YES WE DO NOT ANTICIPATE
ANOTHER BACKLOG UNLESS OF
COURSE YOU KNOW. THAT SOMETHING
OUT OF OUR CONTROL CHANGES BUT
AT THIS POINT WE'RE ON TRACK TO
REACH YOU BURN IT DOWN AND BE
ABLE TO MAINTAIN. GREAT SO IF
I'M APPLYING FOR THE CLAYMORES
EVEN CONSTITUENTS OF OURS
APPLYING FOR CRIME IN JANUARY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. THEN WE
ANTICIPATE THAT THAT CLAIM
WOULD BE FILLED IN A IN A
TIMELY FASHION AFRICANS AS A
LIKE THREE WEEKS. RIGHT THE
THREE WEEK TIME FRAME YES OKAY.
AND MANY REMARKS TODAY IT'S
JUST. BUT A EVEN MORE WILL BE
WITH HIDING IN PLACE YEAH I
KNOW YOU KNOW FORTUNATELY WE
NEVER GET JUST LIKE I'M SURE
YOU NEVER REALLY GET TO HEAR
ABOUT THOSE WE NEVER HEAR ABOUT
US THE PEOPLE WHO GET PAID IN
THREE WEEKS WE DON'T THEY DON'T
KALRA RIGHT. RIGHT SO
UNFORTUNATELY JUST JUST LIKE
YOURSELF THAT THE CASES THAT WE
HEAR ABOUT ARE REALLY THE MOST
DIFFICULT TOUGHEST- YOU KNOW
SET STATUS CASES SO KNOW MY ARE
CAN TO ROUTE RECEIVE. SEVERAL
PROCEDURAL CALLS FOR MORE
RECENTLY REGARDING THE BANK OF
AMERICA CARD SET UP AND
SUDDENLY FROZEN. AND CAN GIVE
US A SENSE AS TO SORT OF Y. Y.
Y. ARE THEY BEING. AND YOU KNOW
WO'S WHO'S ACCOUNT TO BEING.
FROZEN WITHOUT SOMETHING THAT
THE DEPARTMENT DIRECTED AT THEM
DO WITH THE SYSTEM AND THAT THE
BANK IS DOING. THIS IS PART OF-
THE BANK OF AMERICA'S- FRAUD
PROTECTION. SERVICES I GUESS-
AND THAT'S WHAT I'VE MENTIONED
THAT- B. OF A AND R. ET AND IT
LABOR AGENCY WERE MEETING THIS
AFTERNOON. TO WALK THROUGH
EXACTLY WHAT WAS GOING ON WHAT
YOU KNOW WHAT MAKES SENSE AND
LOOK AT THAT BALANCE AGAIN
BETWEEN- YOU KNOW PAYING CLAIMS
VERSES YOU KNOW FIGHTING FRAUD.
BECAUSE SO WE'RE AGGRESSIVELY
TAKING A LOOK AT THAT. THANK
YOU FOR THE COULD BE HELPFUL I
KNOW THAT YOU HAVE- YOUR WEEKLY
CALLS WITH OUR VARIOUS DISTRICT
OFFICES I THINK CAN BE HELPFUL
TO. GIVE IT GIVE US AN UPDATE
ABOUT WEEKLY CALL JUST TURN UP.
YES WE UNDERSTAND AS WE'RE
GETTING- A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT
CALLS COMING IN. HOW DO HOW DO
WE CONTINUE TO ADDRESS THEM.
OKAY THANK THANK YOU APPRECIATE
IT. THANK YOU. FROM THROUGH
YOUR HOME ONCE ET DE REALIZE
THAT'S FRAUD SUSPECTED BUT
STILL DO YOU GUYS TAKE. IF WE
IDENTIFY FRAUD HAS BEEN- SO THE
COUPLE DIFFERENT ROUTES I MEAN
IF IN MINISTRY TO FLEE WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT THE CORRECT
PERSON ISN'T BING HARMED AND
WE IT JUST THEIR ACCOUNT TO.
ENSURE THAT IT YOU KNOW BUT
THEY'RE BEING SEPARATED FROM
THE FRAUDSTER AND THEN AS FAR
AS THE FRAUDSTER GOES- IT IS
ELEVATED TO OUR INVESTIGATION
DIVISION. OF TO LOOK AT.
PURSUING CRIMINAL ACTION. YOU
HAVE NOT NO IDEA HOW MANY CASES
YOU CURRENTLY HAVE PENDING. WE
HAVE STE I KNOW WE HAVE SEVENTY
FOUR OPEN CRIMINAL CASES RIGHT
NOW- AT AT. SO THAT THAT'S WHAT
WE HAVE OPEN RIGHT NOW.
PREPENDED MAKE HOW MANY
EMPLOYEES WORK- TELECOMMUTERS
WORK TO HOME. COUPLE THOUSAND
MAYBE- ARE NOT MORE ABOUT AUDIT
STAFF- AND YOU KNOW PEOPLE WERE
HAD MORE MOBILE KIND OF. BUT
NOW YOU KNOW WE'VE GOT THAT 78%
WORKING AT HOME WHICH- THE
ADDAMS KNOWLEDGES IT IS A
CONCERN OF MINE OBVIOUSLY- MOST
EMPLOYEES DON'T HAVE STATE
ISSUED. LAPTOPS IS THAT CORRECT
NO THEY DO- WE OUTFITTED ALL OF
OUR FOLKS WHEN WE- WHEN THEY-
BECAME TELEWORK CURSE SO WHAT
PERCENTAGE I MEAN ALL SEVEN HOW
MANY WORK AT HOME RIGHT NOW SO
SEVEN THOUSAND WORKING OKAY.
80% OF ALL OF EDT STAFF. L.
LARGE SO THAT 7880% HAVE STATE
ISSUED LAPTOPS. OKAY YES
ACTUALLY BUT THAT'S ACTUALLY
PRETTY GOOD BUT STILL IT IT'S
DIFFICULT OBVIOUSLY IT WORK
PEOPLE GET SET UP FOR ECONOMICS
AND DIFFERENT THINGS SO THAT
WORK IT IS A DIFFERENT AMOUNT
SORRY AT HOME IT'S VASTLY
DIFFERENT WORKING ON A LAPTOP
AND GETTING THINGS DONE THE
WORKING ON DESKTOP AND HAVING
MONITORS AND WHAT NOT. WE
PROVIDE DOCKING STATIONS AS
WELL AS- MULTIPLE SCREENS-
BECAUSE WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THERE IS A SUFFICIENT AT HOME
AS THEY ARE IN THE OFFICE. SO
IT DEPENDING ON THE WORK KIND
OF WORK THEY'RE DOING WE MAKE
SURE THEY HAVE THE PROPER
EQUIPMENT TO PERFORM IT AS IF
THEY WERE IN OFFICE- BUT I MEAN
IT'S A GOOD THING COMMITTEE FOR
THAT BECAUSE MOST STATE
AGENCIES DON'T DO THAT AND EVEN
HERE THE CAPITAL. A LOT OF
FOLKS THAT HAVE THEIR OWN
DEVICES I'M SURE SOME EMPLOYEES
WORKING. ON SMARTPHONES OR
LAPTOPS BECAUSE YOU KNOW LET'S.
WORK SHOULD PROVIDE THAT SO
THANK YOU GUYS FOR DOING THAT
FOR YOUR EMPLOYEES. MISTER
KING. JUST ONE QUICK FOLLOW UP
QUESTION SO. REGARDING THE NEW
PROPOSED DASHBOARD WAS KEBABS
GOING TO BE SENDING A JOINT
LEGISLATIVE BUDGET COMMITTEE
LETTER. TO ADDRESS THAT ISSUE-
I KNOW IT IT WAS GOING TO START
WORKING ON THAT NEXT. THAT WAS
OUR THAT WAS I THOUGHT OKAY.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU. MISTER
JUNE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
SOMEONE HAD GO BACK TO THE
TOPIC OF FRAUD AND WE'VE
LEARNED A LOT IN THIS HEARING-
FROM THE BEVERLY HILLS
ASSISTANT CHIEF THIS IS THE
MOST PARTY SCENE IN TWENTY SIX
YEARS FOR CALLING MR LACKEY SIX
HUNDRED FIFTY ENVELOPES JUST IN
THAT SUITCASE JUST FROM HIS
DISTRICT. AND WE LEARN THERE
ONLY TWENTY SEVEN STAFFERS IN
THE EDT FRAUD UNIT- EVEN THOUGH
YOU HAVE CAPACITY TO HIRE OVER
FIVE THOUSAND NEW STAFFERS FOR
DEPARTMENT OF NINE THOUSAND
PEOPLE ONLY SEVENTY FIVE ACTIVE
ACT INVESTIGATIONS AFTER NEXT.
IT'S GREAT TO HAVE THIS
INFORMATION IT'S PRETTY
SHOCKING JUST HOW LITTLE WORK
THERE SEEMS TO BE DEBT DOWN IN
THIS AREA. SO THERE WAS A PRESS
INVESTIGATIVE REPORT RECENTLY.
THAT REPORTED THAT WITHIN YOUR
DEPARTMENT YOU HAVE TO
TERMINATE LEAST THIRTY THOUSAND
ADDRESSES. WITH AT LEAST TEN
SOCIAL SECURITY NUMBERS
ATTACHED TO. EACH OF THEM. AND
I KNOW YOUR APARTMENT AS FAST
ABOUT IT AND YOU HAVE REFUSED
TO. DENIER CONFIRM WHETHER
THAT'S THE CASE COULD YOU TELL
US. IS THAT THE LEVEL OF FRAUD
THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT. SO AS
I'M SURE YOU CAN APPRECIATE OF
THE REASON WE DON'T SPEAK ABOUT
THAT. TECHNIQUES OR USING OTHER
NUMBERS THAT WE'RE USING IS WE
JUST DON'T WANT TO TIP OFF
FRAUDSTERS IF WE TELL THEM IF
WE TELL YOU WHAT FOR DOING THE
PUBLIC OVER DOING THE NOT JUST
WORK AROUND THAT AND- COMMIT
FRAUD. IN IN THAT IN THAT AREA.
SO AND WE DON'T KNOW AND- YOU
KNOW AT HINDER THE INTEGRITY OF
OUR INVESTIGATION SO. I'VE
HEARD THAT AS THE LINE FROM
YOUR- COMMUNICATION SECRETARY-
I REACH OUT TO YOU IN A COUPLE
OF OCCASIONS OF THE PAST MONTH
ON SEPTEMBER THE SECOND
SEPTEMBER THE TWENTY FIFTH JUST
ASKING QUESTIONS AROUND FRAUD.
NOT RECEIVED ANY ANSWERS MYSELF
NOT IN ASKING IF YOU CONTINUE
TO IGNORE REQUESTS FOR
INFORMATION FROM ALL AGES
LEADERS OR JUST SOME OF US WERE
ASKING BUT WE HAVE QUESTIONS.
MY PERSPECTIVE SOMEONE WHO USED
TO BE PART OF LAW ENFORCEMENT
IS. IF SOMEONE'S BREAKING INTO
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF HOMES AND
STEALING PERSONAL PROPERTY. HE
WARNED THE PUBLIC. YOU ADDRESS
THE CRIME IF SOMEONE IS
STEALING TENS OF THOUSANDS. OF
PEOPLE I DON'T PEOPLE'S
IDENTITY. HE WARNED THE PUBLIC
YOU ADDRESS THE CRIME IF
SOMEONE'S BREAKING INTO. TENS
OF THOUSANDS OF BANK ACCOUNTS
YOU WARN THE PUBLIC YOU ADDRESS
THE CRIME IN THIS INSTANCE. WE
HAVE MULTIPLE CRIMINAL RINGS
STEALING FROM TENS OF THOUSANDS
OF PEOPLE IDENTITIES. FROM BANK
ACCOUNTS FOR PERSONAL PROPERTY.
IN YOUR APARTMENT HAS BEEN
SILENT. AND YOUR YOUR
DEPARTMENT'S BEEN SILENT YOU'RE
YOU'RE YOU'RE SAYING YOU DON'T
WANT TO OF COURSE WE DON'T WANT
TO TELL FRAUDSTERS HOW TO DO
THEIR JOB THIRTY DOING THEIR
JOB BUT YOU'RE NOT WARNING THE
PUBLIC ON THE LEVEL OF FRAUD
THAT'S HAPPENED YOU GIVEN NO
DETAIL ON THE TYPES OF CRIMES
ARE BEING COMMITTED AGAINST
PEOPLE SO THAT PEOPLE. CAN BE
AWARE OF WHAT TO LOOK OUT FOR.
WE'VE DONE A LOT OF PUBLIC NOW.
IS WELL AS IN OUR I NEWS
RELEASE EVERY THURSDAY. WE
DRESS FRAUD EVERY THURSDAY ON
WHAT PEOPLE NEED TO DO WHAT
NEEDS PEOPLE NEED TO LOOK OUT
FOR. SO YOU KNOW WE'VE DONE A
LOT OF MESSAGING AROUND THAT
BECAUSE YOU'RE YOU'RE RIGHT
UNLESS PEOPLE. KNOW THAT THEY
CAN'T PROTECT THEMSELVES AND
THAT IS VERY IMPORTANT TO US.
AND WE NEED THE PUBLIC'S- I ON
IT AND UNDERSTANDING AND BEING
ABLE TO. HELP HELP DEAL WITH
THIS. NOW IT'S JUST A- SOME OF
US WERE WERE TALKING ABOUT THE
FACT THERE'S A MUSIC VIDEO. ON
THE WEB WITH FOUR HUNDRED
THOUSAND VIEWS ON HOW EASY IT
IS TO THE FRAUD EDT. ARE YOU
AWARE THIS. YES. ON A DIFFERENT
SIDE SO OUR DISTRICT STAFF.
EVERY EVERY COUPLE OF WEEKS WE
WOULD TALK TO YOUR STAFF OF A
WHAT TO DO WITH CONSTITUENTS
WHO GET THESE ENVELOPES AND- WE
HAVE OUR COLLEAGUE MR LACKEY
WHOSE COLLECTED THEM IN A
SUITCASE- ARE STAFFER TOLD.
THAT IF OUR CONSTITUENTS DIDN'T
WANNA PUT POSTAGE BACK ON THE
LETTERS TO MAIL BACK TO
DEPARTMENT THAT THEY SHOULD
JUST THROW THE ENVELOPE AWAY.
WHICH SELLS LATERALLY
TANTAMOUNT TO DESTROYING
EVIDENCE OF FRAUD. HOW IS IT
THAT WAY OUR STAFF ARE BEING
TOLD. SO WHAT WE'RE
COMMUNICATING WHAT WE'VE BEEN
COMMUNICATING TO THE PUBLIC IS
THAT- IF THEY GUESTS TO GET
THESE KIND OF ENVELOPES YOU
KNOW SEND IT BACK TO AS
RETURNED TO SENDER WHETHER IT'S
TO EDT- FOR ON THE NOTICES OR
WHETHER IT'S BANKAMERICA FOR
THE BANK CARDS. IF FOR SOME
REASON THEY DON'T FEEL
COMFORTABLE WITH THAT AND WHAT
WE'RE SUGGESTING IS THAT THEY
SHRED ALL THE EVIDENCE- IT AT
IT AT THE END OF THE DAY IT'S
UP TO THE INDIVIDUALS OUR
COMFORT LEVEL WE WOULD LIKE YOU
TO SEND THEM BACK BUT AT A YOU
KNOW IF FOR SOME REASON THEY'RE
NOT COMFORTABLE AT A VERY
MINIMUM. MAKE SURE YOU SHRED.
I'VE NEVER HEARD OF A
GOVERNMENT AGENCY SUGGESTING
THAT CRIMINAL EVIDENCE BE BE
SHREDDED- WE HAVE A COUPLE OF
US WHO. USED TO BE FROM LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND I WOULD JUST
ASK MR LACKEY FORMALLY FROM THE
CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL OR-
OUR CHAIRMAN MR COOPER A FORMER
SHERIFF IF THAT MAKES SENSE-
BUT I DON'T THINK IT DOES. LET
ME ASK ONE ONE OTHER QUESTION
YOU YOU STATED YOU HAVE NO IDEA
HOW MUCH MONEY HAS BEEN STOLEN
FROM THE STATE OR FROM A
CONSTITUENTS NO IDEA OF THE
LEVEL OF FRAUD. SO SINCE THE
BEGINNING OF THE PANDEMIC UNTIL
THE END OF THIS PAST MONTH EDT
IS SENT OUT. NINETY FOUR
BILLION. DOLLARS AND- I'M GONNA
SIT RIGHT HERE BUT I'M SURE
THERE'S BEEN AT LEAST OVER A
BILLION DOLLARS OR FRAUD. I
DON'T KNOW WHAT THAT NUMBER IS.
BUT STRIKES ME IT'S SOMETHING
THAT SOMEONE OUGHT TO
INVESTIGATE. AND IF YOU HAVE A
DEPARTMENT OF NINE THOUSAND
PEOPLE IN ONLY TWENTY SEVEN.
ARE FOCUSED ON FRAUD. WHO'S
GUARDING THE HEN HOUSE THIS IS
BUREAUCRATIC CRIMINAL
NEGLIGENCE. AND THE FACT THAT
INTERESTS THE FACT THE ATTERS
THIS IS ALSO IT WASN'T A FOCUS
OF THE STRIKE TEAM. AND IT JUST
BOGGLES OUR MINDS AT THIS POINT
THAT. THERE DOESN'T SEEM TO BE
ENOUGH ATTENTION ON THIS SO LET
ME ASK A QUESTION. HAVE YOU
CONVENE A MULTI AGENCY TASK
FORCE ON THIS. YEAH YES I HAVE
AND TELLS US. SO CHIEF MONTEREY
OF OUR INVESTIGATION DIVISION
LEAVES LEADS THE TASK FORCE AND
HE WORKS WITH OUR I. T. HE
WORKS WITH OUR INFORMATION
SECURITY AS WELL AS A PROGRAMS
ITSELF. HE AND A TASK WORK
TASK- THE WORKGROUP HAVE BEEN A
MEETING CLOSELY WITH DEPARTMENT
OF LABOR OF THE LAST COUPLE
MONTHS TO INSTITUTE ALL THE
VARIOUS TOOLS THAT I'VE LIVED
I'VE- REFERENCED IN THE HANDOUT
I PROVIDED YOU. BECAUSE YOU CAN
HAVE MORE PEOPLE BUT THE END OF
THE DAY- THE THIS KIND OF YOU
KNOW TAKE FROM A TECHNOLOGY
STANDPOINT. IS REALLY DIFFERENT
TECHNOLOGY OPTIONS- THAT REALLY
HELP THE FORENSIC REVIEW AND
DETECTION OF WHAT'S GOING ON I
THINK IS WHAT THE LAST COUNT TO
SAY YOU KNOW WHEN YOU GET INTO.
CASE BY CASE IS IT'S VERY VERY
TIME CONSUMING AND RESOURCE
INTENSIVE AND NOT NOT TYPICALLY
THE BEST WAY TO- YOU KNOW DRESS
THAT THE MASSES SO WE'RE TRYING
TO ADDRESS THE MASSES IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH DEPARTMENT. I
UNDERSTAND HAVE A LOT GOING ON-
IT JUST STRIKES US THOUGH THAT
IF YOU ONLY HAVE TWENTY SEVEN
INDIVIDUALS OUT OF NINE
THOUSAND WE'VE GIVEN YOU THE
AUTHORITY THIS YEAR TO HIRE
OVER FIVE THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS.
YOU WOULD THINK. THAT YOU
SHOULD HAVE A LARGER TEAM
DEALING WITH THIS IN FACT THE
ASSISTANT CHIEF FROM BEVERLY
HILLS STRIKES ME AS SOMEONE WHO
YOU SHOULD BRING IN RIGHT AWAY
TO HELP THIS TEAM. BUT AT THE
LEAST IT IS IT STRIKES ME AS
BUREAUCRATICALLY CRIMINALLY
NEGLIGENT THAT UNDER YOUR
LEADERSHIP THERE'S NOTHING MORE
DEVOTED TO THIS FRAUD IF
POTENTIALLY BILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
ARE BEING STOLEN FROM THE
PEOPLE CALIFORNIA FROM OUR
CONSTITUENTS WOULD YOU AGREE.
THAT AT THIS POINT YOU'RE DOING
WHAT YOU NEED TO DO WHEN IT
COMES TO FRAUD. I THINK WE CAN
ALWAYS DO MORE. ABSOLUTELY I
MEAN IT'S BEEN A- YOU KNOW AT
THE BIG YEAH. DR FOR US FIRST
PARTICULARLY THE LAST FEW
MONTHS- WHEN WE SAW A RISING UP
A FIGURE OUT VERYTHING THAT WE
CAN DO. SO I THINK WE CONTINUE
TO. PARTNER WITH EVERYBODY WE
CONTINUE TO REACH OUT OF COULD
WE DO MORE AND- ABSOLUTELY LIKE
I SAID WE ARE CONTINUING TO
HIRE IT'S JUST A SLOW PROCESS
WHEN IT COMES TO POLICE
OFFICERS OR PROFOUND PEACE
OFFICERS. MISTER CHAIRMAN.
THANK YOU MISTER YOU ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
MISS PETER NORRIS I WANT ONE
FOLLOW UP PICKING UP ONLINE AS
NEW HIRES I'D SAY MY COLLEAGUE.
FROM LOS ANGELES HAD ASKED YOU
ABOUT THE NUMBER OF NEW HIRES
THAT YOU'RE CURRENTLY PLANNING
ON AND I THINK DID YOU SAY
EIGHTEEN HUNDRED NEW
INDIVIDUALS PLAYED A HIGHER WE
HAVE FORTY TWO HUNDRED THAT WE
HIRED WE HAVE ANOTHER THOUSAND
THAT ARE. JUST WAITING FOR
THEIR START DATES OKAY AND HOW
MANY OF THOSE ARE FRAUD
INVESTIGATORS. NO THIS WAS FOR
THE U. I. PROGRAM BUT WE HANDLE
A LOT OF THE CASES
ADMINISTRATIVELY- THAT FRAUD
INVESTIGATORS ARE JUST THOSE
FOR THOSE- REALLY FOR THE RINGS
THE CRIMINAL RINGS. BUT
ADMINISTRATIVELY WITHIN ARE YOU
AYE PROGRAM OF THEIR TRAIN TO
LOOK AT IT LOOK AT THE CASES.
SEPARATE YOU KNOW MAKE SURE
THAT- ANYBODY HARM THAT THEIR
ACCOUNT IS GOOD OR CLOSE
ACCOUNTS IF IT'S- IF THEY
FIGURE OUT IT WAS PRIVATELY AND
THEY GONE THROUGH THE PROCESS
AND WE CAN TELL THAT THAT'S NOT
THE RIGHT PERSON. SO FRAUD
ISN'T JUST HAPPENED THIS ISN'T
RESOLVED AT OUR INVESTIGATION-
IT'S A IT'S IT TAKES A WHOLE
GRANTS TO ADDRESS THIS. SO OKAY
I'M SO THE STRIKE TEAM REPORT.
LITERALLY SAYS YOU SHOULD STOP
HIRING ANY NEW IT SAYS STOP
HIRING ANY NEW ONES IT IS IN
NEW EMPLOYEES SO WHY ARE YOU
STILL HIRING A THOUSAND
EMPLOYEES BECAUSE AT THE TIME
THE STRIKE TEAM CAME OUT WITH A
REPORT WE HAD ALREADY PROVIDED
JOB OFFERS TO PEOPLE SO THIS IS
ALL WE'RE DOING IS BRING THE
LAST OF THE PEOPLE ON BOARD
THAT WE HAD ALREADY PROVIDED
JOB OFFERS TO. OKAY AND WHAT
WELL I CAN I CAN UNDERSTAND
SOME OF THAT I THINK. THAT I
WOULD DISAGREE WITH THE
ASSESSMENT OF MY COLLEAGUE FROM
SAN FRANCISCO THAT. FIVE IN A
WORLD OF CONSTRAINED RESOURCES
WE NEED TO BE FOCUSING ARE
CONSTRAINED RESOURCES ON
SOLVING THE TOP PRIORITY ISSUES
AND PROBLEMS AND- THAT FRAUD
NEEDS TO MAKE ITS WAY ON TO THE
TOP OF THAT LIST BOB RATHER
THAN. JUST CONTINUING TO HIRE
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
ACTUALLY NOT. FIVE IF YOU FOR
THE STRIKING REPORT IT HAS
ACTUALLY BEEN COUNTERPRODUCTIVE
FOR YOUR DEPARTMENT. THANK YOU
MISTER TRACK. THANK YOU ANY
FURTHER QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. AS WE DISCUSSED
EARLIER WE'RE TAKING PUBLIC
COMMENT IN PERSON. AND THAT
THIS- POSITIONS ACROSS THE
STATE WITH ANY PUBLIC COMMENT
TO ONE MINUTE. IS SPEAKERS HERE
IN THE ROOM WAS MADE PUBLIC
COMMENT. CASCINA BUDDY HOW
ABOUT- MARC ARE AT OUR REMOTE
LOCATIONS.
PLEASE PROCEED. HI
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO UP
TO COMMENT MY NAME IS HE SOME
MARKERS I HAVE BEEN WORKING FOR
THE EDT FOR APPROXIMATELY FIVE
YEARS AND I'M PROUD TO WORK FOR
THE EDT BECAUSE I KNOW WHAT
IT'S LIKE TO BE UNEMPLOYED AND
I CARE FOR THE VALVES OF THE
EDT STANDS FOR ALSO PRODUCT SO
YOU LOCAL MEMBER FOR LOCAL ONE
THOUSAND. I WANT TO BRIEFLY
COMMENT ON WHAT IT IS LIKE TO
WORK AT THE E. D. D. DURING
RECORD LEVELS OF UNEMPLOYMENT.
ALL WE HAVE BEEN WORKING
TIRELESSLY TO ENSURE CALIFORNIA
WORKERS. GET THE BENEFIT OF THE
NEED. WE UNDERSTAND THAT WE ARE
ON A LIFELINE FOR MANY
STRUGGLING CALIFORNIANS. BUT WE
ARE ON UNDERSTAFFED AND
UNDERFUNDED. HOW WELL WE ARE WE
ARE BLESSED TO BE HERE WORKING
FOR THE EDT MY WERE ON MY
COWORKERS AND I HAVE BEEN
WORKING OVERTIME. AND ON
WEEKENDS.AND I WOULD LIKE TO
STRESS THAT THE I. T. STUFF ARE
SO OVERWHELMED THAT IS
INTERFERING WITH MY ABILITY. TO
BE ABLE TO PROVIDE SERVICES IN
A TIMELY MANNER. HOW FOR
INSTANCE ON IT TOOK ME OVER
THREE MONTHS. TO BE ABLE TO GET
PERMISSION JUST TO BE ABLE TO
ENTER A BASIC NOTE ON TO THE
YOU AYE SYSTEM. AND OVER. TWO
MONTHS JUST TO BE ABLE TO GET
ACCESS AND ABLE TO PER
UNEMPLOED ASSISTANCE I DO
BELIEVE THAT THE SOLUTION IS TO
FULLY FUND THE EDT. AND EXPAND
THE I. T. STYLE. WITH ACTUAL
EDT. WHO ARE HERE FOR THE HOLD
FOR THE LONG HOLD. AND NOT JUST
FOR ON TEMPORARY WORKERS WHO
ARE NOT IN INVESTED IN THE
OUTCOME. ON LASTLY BOMB THEY
ARE DISGRUNTLED DOT CLAIMANTS
WHO ARE HAVING AN EVENT OUTSIDE
THE E. D. D. AND SACRAMENTO AND
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA NO THE EDT
WORKERS ARE WORKING VERY HARD
AND THAT WE DO CARE- DID HAPPEN
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HELP EACH
AND EVERYONE OF THEM AND I DO
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TODAY THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
YOUR SERVICE I SEE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ARGUE TO THE
OFFICE. HERE IN SACRAMENTO
YESTERDAY IN THAT OFFICE- DOES
YOU LIVE IN THE WORKING SEVEN
DAYS A WEEK THERE SO YOU GUYS
ARE WORKING HARD SO. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. CELEBRITIES TO HAVE
OUR HEARING I WANT TO THINK-
GENEVIEVE. MORRIS I'M SORRY
SOMEBODY ELSE OKAY. YES MA'AM
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
pCOMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE COMMENT-
I'M DRESSED WILL ROWLANDS AND I
AM- AN EMPLOYMENT PROGRAM
RECORD EDT AND HAVE BEEN FOR
THIRTEEN YEARS AND WHAT I DO
HERE IS I INVESTIGATE AND
DETERMINE ELIGIBILITY OF THOSE
WHO REQUEST UNEMPLOYMENT
ASSISTANCE- I WASN'T HERE WHEN
WE GOT THROUGH THE 200-017-0009
GREAT RECESSION. AND MY
COWORKERS AND I STEPPED UP AND
WORKED LONG AND HARD TO HELP
CALIFORNIA RECOVER. AND WITH
THE PANDEMIC WERE STEPPING UP
AGAIN AS YOU'VE HEARD WE
WORKING EIGHT TO FOURTEEN HALF
HOURS A DAY SEVEN DAYS A WEEK.
AND WE ARE. ACCEPTING THAT THIS
IS THE COST OUR HOMES AND
FAMILIES. IN ORDER TO SERVE
CALIFORNIA- AT THE LEVEL. WHEN
THIS ALL STARTED EDT. AT ALL
LEVELS THE RACING THE- THE
ALARM ABOUT WHAT WE NEEDED
BECAUSE WE'VE BEEN UNDERFUNDED
UNDERSTAFFED AND WE HAVE AN
UPDATED TECHNOLOGY. IT'S CLEAR
THAT EIGHTY HAS NEVER BEEN
FULLY FUNDED AT THE LEVEL THAT
NEEDS AND UNFORTUNATELY. IT
TOOK A PANDEMIC TO TECH TO SHOW
US WHAT NEEDS TO BE DONE. WE
KNOW THAT THE SHORT LEVEL IS
YOU KNOW QUICK ANSWERS DON'T
MAKE FIXES WE NEED FOR YOU TO
INVEST IN THE DEPARTMENT IN THE
STAFF AND PROVIDE US WITH THE
THINGS WE NEED IN ORDER THAT WE
CAN HELP CALIFORNIA RECOVER.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ANY OTHER
SPEAKERS IN THE QUEUE. THIS IS
AREA. THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
FOR UP BUT THAT MISTER CHAIR
FOR HOLDING THIS EVENT- THIS
MEETING TODAY THIS HEARING
TODAY AS WE HAVE DISCUSSED IN
THE PREVIOUS HEARING ABOUT
MONTHS AGO OR FOR FIVE SIX
WEEKS AGO- I DON'T KNOW. GIVEN
THE ELECTION TIMELINE AND
EVERYTHING GOING ON I KNOW WHAT
THE APPETITE IS BUT I WOULD.
ASKED THAT WE STILL CONSIDER
HOLDING THESE MEETINGS I THINK
THE MORE WE QUESTION- THE
BETTER OUTCOMES WE GET SO IF-
IF IT IF EVERYONE IN THE
COMMITTEE IS FINE WITH COMING
BACK UP TO SACRAMENTO. AND TO
HOLD A HEARING. OF THIS NATURE
IN THE NEAR FUTURE I WOULD
REQUEST THAT WE DO THAT SURE MY
DID REACH OUT TO MEMBERS AND
SEE IF THEY HAVE A TIE FOR IT
THANK YOU WILL REACH OUT AND-
LET YOU KNOW HOW TO MAKE A
COMMITMENT TODAY BUT- WE CAN
DEFINITELY DO THAT. BUT I WOULD
LIKE TO MR TWO ONE MORE COMMENT
RELATED TO THIS I JUST AGAIN
WANT TO THANK THE RANK AND FILE
WORKERS EDT BECAUSE THEY ARE
WORKING AROUND THE CLOCK.
THEY'RE WORKING UNDER
TREMENDOUS CHALLENGES AND ONE
THING THAT HAS BEEN CLEAR TO ME
DURING THIS TIME PERIOD. IS
FROM MY STAFF TO THE PUBLIC TO
THE PRESS. WE HAVE BEEN. ABLE
TO GET MORE ACCURATE
INFORMATION. BETTER IDEAS
BETTER RECOMMENDATIONS OF WHAT
TO DO FROM RANK AND FILE
STAFFERS. AND WE'RE HEARING
FROM IT EDT LEADERSHIP THAT HAS
FAILED. CONSISTENTLY AND IF YOU
COULD SEE THE NODDING OF MY
COLLEAGUES AS A DEGREE WITH
WHAT I'M SAYING. I WOULD LIKE
TO BE. SUGGEST FOR THE NEXT
HEARING THAT WE ASK IT FOR SOME
WAY TO GET MORE. DIRECT
FEEDBACK FROM EDT RENDON
FARMWORKERS. IN ADDITION
HEARING FROM ET LEADERSHIP
ABOUT WHAT MIGHT BE HELPFUL
BECAUSE I THINK THEY WOULD
PROVIDE A VERY DIFFERENT
PERSPECTIVE FROM WHAT WE'RE
HEARING FROM EATING MEAT OR
SHIP. JUST A SUGGESTION. OKAY
GRAYSON GESTION SO I REALLY
WANNA THING GENEVIEVE MARIE
LOS- SHE'S STATUS COMMITTEE-
SHE'S NOT LEAVING THE BILL IS
GOING TO. STEP DIFFERENT
COMMITTEES OBVIOUSLY SHE
CHAIRED- HELP MISTER NAZARIAN
TO WHEN HE WAS A CHAIR. AND SHE
RESEARCH THAT MISTER CHANG SAID
GENEVIEVE I KNOW YOU'RE HOME.
WITH ROSAL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND- LOOK AFTER LITTLE ROSE. UP
NO FURTHER QUESTIONS THAT
BRINGS OUR HEARING TO IT THANK
YOU.